e
e e
good morning um for all the committee
members that are here uh bright and
early on time um uh a few things uh um
wanted to uh go over but uh first maybe
we'll start with the
pledge representative try would you lead
us I pledge allegiance to the flag the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
um we have a number of uh hearing
scheduled for today um and this
afternoon um at 1:30 we are scheduled
for house buil 283 which has um
attracted some attention
evidently
um um I has anyone gotten any emails
about it um so uh we will at lunchtime
move the afternoon hearings to rep's
Hall uh just in the event that there's a
large crowd it's better to um uh be set
up and everyone uh on board with what
we're doing so at lunchtime will we move
to rep's Hall um and everything will be
in place um signs will be uh displayed
with the new location um
Etc um so that's the uh the main thing
um
before we get started uh yes
representative
Hall thank you um is there any on the
general court website I wonder on the
change of location if somebody wanted to
know other than showing
up yeah I'm not sure about the general
court website but uh things will be
posted on the um the um uh the schedule
boards all over um they uh they will be
updated with the new location
so they will come here first and here as
well right yes thank you I just was
trying to avoid them coming to this
building but maybe you can't do that
thank you chair yes sir uh just question
um for the remainder of the afternoon
following that bill we we're going to be
made to stay in reps Hall yes thank you
the whole afternoon will be reps Hall
thank you from 1 pm on correct
yeah great uh thank you very much and
with that I think we're ready for for
our first hearing of the day which is
House Bill 671 establishing a
kindergarten literacy Readiness program
and the prime sponsor uh is here uh
representative um Mark
Pearson thank
you good morning Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Mark Pearson I'm a fifth term
legislator representing Hamstead
Kingston and East Kingston I'm chairman
of the children and family law Committee
of the house and I'm chairman of the
joint legislative Department of Health
and Human Services oversight committee
and I'm glad to be with you
today I come from a large family my
father was one of 12 children in the
Next Generation there were 26 first
cousins most of us lived in the same
immediate area so when it comes to a
situation that involves an individual
ual I don't just know of such people I'm
probably closely related in one or more
of them the joke in the family was we
occupy many chapters in
DSM my cousin David was not as blessed
as some of us and that he did not have a
natural ability to read nor did he have
parents who read to him when he was
young and like myself and many of our
first cousins who entered the first
grade able to read read and that was
with no kindergarten in our area David
did not learn to read even in the first
grade because there was neither remidial
reading Specialists nor the desire to
hold a student back nor any good kind of
program to help him David was passed
along through the system harming him
throughout his time in school and
throughout life it caused him trouble
much of his life and it cost the state
some
money many New Hampshire school systems
public charter private and most
homeschool families are already doing a
good job readying youngsters for the
first grade in what
follows the desire behind the proponents
of HV
671 is to close any gaps this is similar
to my family situation most of us could
read David could not but most school
systems are doing a good job teaching
young people to read There are however
some gaps some towns could use help in
this or that others in Reading Readiness
there was no judgments made at least
from
me should this bill be passed in a
kindergarten literacy read Readiness
program be established where needed
reporting of the results is mandated in
other words is what we've established
doing the job we desire are more people
entering first grade able to read are
there noticeable improvements where
improvements have been
needed this bill in some ways is a
placeholder because it appropriates a
dollar it says while the details are
being worked out should the details seem
wise to the governor and executive
counsel they would then proceed to fund
it with whatever monies are available as
they choose and we know that in lean
years as well as flush years sometimes
money can be
found it's kind of a cliche in the
legislature that we should do this or
that for the
children but sometimes that saying is
very
apropo such a program would have changed
the course of my cousin David's life and
it may well help in a positive way the
journeys of numbers of youngsters in New
Hampshire thank you Mr
chairman thank you very much for being
here with this uh legislation uh
questions from the
committee represent s thank you very
much and thank you for taking my
question um as a former kindergarten
teacher who taught reading to my
kindergarteners um I'm just trying to
understand how this I I understand the
goal of why you know why we need a
program I I just don't see in what's
written here how and I'm wondering if
you might be able to elaborate a little
bit on on like what the program itself
is and how it
works I think the pro I think the bill
is theoretical and aspirational it has
recognized a problem here and there and
the purpose of the bill according to the
folks who got behind me to put it in is
when we acknowledge that then uh we or
they can start developing a program or
more likely make use of a program that
has borne fruit elsewhere then once that
is in place they can go hat in hand and
ask for some money so it isn't as well
developed is some of the bills that I've
written or certainly as a chairman I've
seen but it's a first
step follow up yes thank you and so in
um section two it it says the
kindergarten literacy Readiness program
is a Statewide program that uses a
homebased or center-based educational
technology program etc etc is there a
specific program that you've already
identified that reflects
this homebased educa or center-based
educational technology program it is my
understanding that they are looking at a
whole variety along the way to finding
um one that they think may be the best
one to start with as they say we're
several they are several steps behind
where a lot of bills come in
at representative Hall thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question could you uh expand on that and
tell us who
they are you just said they are
developing thinking about the program
and what who's
they the person who encouraged me to put
this in is a lobbyist named Karen
Rosenberger and I was hoping she would
be here today I do not see her um maybe
there are people here who know way more
about it than I do which is not a high
bar so thank you for
coming thank you I'm gra maray thank you
Mr Taran thank you for taking my
question um I I'm curious to um know a
little bit more about the understanding
between um preschool childhood
development emerging reading play based
learning and gross motor skills and how
you would Envision that interfacing with
the requirement for a child to navigate
a platform a technology
program if you could tell me a little
bit more about sitting a four-year-old
down in front of the computer that in
that
way this will be this will be a very
typical liberal arts answer from me and
that is um good things that are already
going on in the
classroom anything that's added from
this would not be at the expense of if
they're doing good things there fine
this is about identifying places where
help and reading is needed as
well followup yes uh thank you Mr shair
and and in addition to that um would
this be a complement to formative and
summative assessment that is already
happening in a classroom that educators
are developing relationships with their
the students and then making other types
of Assessments with can you tell me how
that might work if I understand the
question correctly areas where there is
needed more help in teaching people to
read would be
introduced I did not in my conversations
with um
Miss Rosenberg hear anything like we're
going in and clean that place up it was
quite the contrary it was those programs
may actually be doing very very well in
certain other things where there is Need
for additional assistance in helping
people learn to read those things would
come in and the Assumption I took
away was again it wouldn't be slash and
burn it wouldn't be everything you're
doing is wrong it would be here's
somewhere where you need some
help but as I also said this is
really I wasn't given language that says
we've got it all figured out we just
want you to fund it they're still trying
to figure out of the various programs
that have borne good fruit around which
one would they consider being the one
that is being
offered resident woodcock
thank you Mr chairman good morning
represent sir thank you for taking my
question the chair allows I have two but
I'll start with the one that most
interest to me is um under under line 24
has the educational technology provider
is a reged nonprofit
organization I just find that kind of
limiting it would seem to me that there
would be a host of educational
technology providers that are uh not
necessarily registered as a nonprofit I
I don't know why you it's specified like
that I don't either again this will be a
question for the people who are much
closer to whatever program is being
desired thank you Mr chairman PA up yes
yeah well a question yes yes thank you
sir um the second part I'm looking at uh
line 16 when it talks about homebased U
me obviously me the program for children
home as it say in the definition I'm
trying to figure out how that would
occur if I'm a homeschool youngster um
and how how is that going to happen I do
know through um a family member who is
active in The Homeschool movement that
many
homeschool or homeschool
co-ops uh do very well in many things
but
are not good in some other things I also
know from this that numbers of
homeschoolers on certain things will
combine with other homeschooled parents
I have a staff member who has done that
in terms of science what she and her
husband do um they believe is quite
adequate it seems to be so except in
science so they've gathered a number of
homeschooling parents who are the same
we don't know science and they have
formed a cooperative and brought in a
retired person who has a master's degree
in science to teach those kids science
my assumption would be if this um lack
of
reading is in a homeschooling situation
they would do something like that thank
you thank you at least that's what I'd
recommend to
them represent Mur um thank you Mr chair
and thanks again for taking my question
on page I believe that's uh page one on
lines 29 I there's a reference to tier
one benchmarks and are you referring to
to response to intervention tier one uh
benchmarks or are you referring to
something else it's not quite clear I do
not
know uh forur the question seeing none
thank you very much representative for
being
here is there anyone else who would like
to testify I see U see a card coming
up please
sure that's fine they just pull up
another chair if he can fit it
in are we
on Yes red yep good have to come up
please drive me nuts I can't see the
person on that side good morning Mr
chair and of the committee I'm Teresa
Rosenberger I work for Bern Shure Law
Firm you could move it a little closer
okay and I represent and have for a
number of years Waterford um Research
Institute and with me is Rob Riley who
works for Waterford specifically in New
Hampshire and um I'll let him give his
testimony first and then I'll tell you
afterwards our experience with Waterford
from the beginning
good morning and thank you chair
cordelli and members of the education
and policy Administration committee my
name is Rob Riley I serve as a senior
director of operations for Community
engagement with waterford.org a
nonprofit organization dedicated to
advancing education Equity through
evidence-based scalable Solutions I've
also formerly served as an executive
director with the granite YMCA serving
families here in New Hampshire prior to
coming to Waterford I'm here today to
voice waterford.org strong support for
HB 671 the kindergarten literacy
Readiness program at waterford.org we
believe every child deserves an
opportunity to succeed regardless of
their circumstances or zip code since
our founding we have worked tirelessly
to close early learning gaps by
providing families and communities with
the resources and tools that they need
to prepare for kindergarten our Flagship
initiative Waterford upstart is a
home-based early education program that
equips children with foundational
literacy numeracy and social socio
emotional skills the program also
empowers families to be active
participants in their child's education
through family coaching resources and
ongoing support in New Hampshire
Waterford upstart has already proven its
impact during the 2324 school year over
300 children across the state
participated in our program achieving
remarkable results on average children
demonstrated significant growth in early
literacy skills as measured by our pre-
and post-program assessments most
importantly many participants finished
the program with skills at or above the
kindergarten Readiness Benchmark setting
them on a path for long-term academic
success HB 671 aligns closely with our
mission and a proven approach by
establishing a Statewide kindergarten
literacy Readiness program this bill
will ensure that every four and
5-year-old in New Hampshire has access
to highquality evidence-based Early
Learning Resources the proposed program
mirrors what Waterford upstart has
successfully implemented already in New
Hampshire and across the country some
examples of this include personalized
learning where children can engage in an
Adaptive curriculum that focuses on
reading math and science for just 15 to
30 minutes a day 5 days a week it
includes family empowerment where
parents and caregivers are supported
with multilingual coaching and resources
to actively participate in their child's
education offers technology access for
families who lack the necessary tools
where computers or tablets and even
internet connectivity can be provided
which break down barriers to
participation the outcomes speak for
themselves research consistently shows
that children who engage with Waterford
upstart are better prepared for
kindergarten which leads to improved
performance throughout their academic
Journey furthermore these results are
consistent across demographics including
children from underserved and Rural
communities HB 671 is an opportunity to
build on these successes and scale them
Statewide by investing in this program
New Hampshire can lead the way in
addressing Early Learning disparities
Empowering Families and setting children
up for lifelong success on behalf of
waterford.org I commend representative
Pearson and the other sponsors of this
bill for their leadership on this
critical issue I urge this committee to
pass HB 671 and to support its
implementation so that more children and
families can benefit from programs like
water upstart and I thank the chair and
the committee for your time and
consideration thank you very much if you
have written testimony there um when
you're finished you could just pass it
on up U to the absolutely great thank
you very much uh ask do you want to ask
him questions or shall I why don't you
go ahead then we can um bery Shore um
was hired by water for up start gosh
right there before Co um they had
started a program a pilot program in
Nashua and it was funded by the United
Way of nashwa the um city of nashwa and
uh the libraries were involved I'm not
so sure there was funding there and the
purpose was to try the program in in New
Hampshire as a pilot and as you know
there is a population in Manchester I
mean Nashville that's lower income some
new uh Americans refugees coming in ETC
so they thought let's try the program
the TR program was tremendously
successful in NASA and they really saw a
real
uptick in the um progress of the kids
and truly their Readiness to go to
kindergarten so they came to us and at
this point Nash uh I mean Waterford was
only doing
homebased and so the reason they came to
us at Bering sure was they thought we
had connections around the state and the
bottom line was getting directly to the
individual family and that was the
question how do we get to um to the
family how do we get to representative
hail and say we've got a program for
your three-year-old or four-year-old
because it was frankly personto person
this was being it was truly homebased
not provider based um so we worked over
the course of time and it was really
fascinating to see um you know where you
found the people who had the had the
three year olds or four the four year
olds to go into the program the
Department of
Education um because of the success of
nashal worked with Waterford and got a
grant through UNH for a million and half
dollars to go Statewide and again we
worked really hard Statewide but you can
well imag in the North Country you're
picking off one here one here and so Rob
got hired and I must say Rob has done an
unbelievably phenomenal job because I
think a lot of your background with the
why and early childhood education Etc so
the program was very successful but we
um we
did think that maybe we needed to see if
we could work with providers that had
been tried in other states decades ago
and the providers are kind of said no no
no um you know we do this ourselves this
program is 15 minutes 5 days a week and
it there's a coach when it was Pro
homebased there's a coach that monitors
the progress and if they see a child is
soaring here and not quite doing so well
here they will um they will will re
rejigger the program they will so if
they see a child's using it too long
call up and say what's going on and I
remember a story way back in the
beginning when the coach called up and
said it's supposed to be 15 minutes a
day 5 days a away for your child and the
child's using it 2 hours a day well it
turns out it was a family that the
parents did not speak great English
English was a second language the
parents were using the program as well
and if the folks do not have an an
internet
connection Waterford pays for it if the
folks don't have a computer Waterford
will give them a computer or a tablet
that was part of the deal with nashwa
and that was part of the deal with doe
and the Waterford would pay for the
internet connection and the computer the
state can't because it's and um so it
was really it was it really incredibly
successful the Grant from the state ran
out last June we had a whole group of
kids who were already signed up for this
calendar year and we couldn't do it we
still got the catch we're still waiting
for it and Waterford is still willing to
chip in their part that maybe I can't
remember which one of you over here ask
about the nonprofit that may be uh part
of the reason the nonprofit's in there
because it's a nonprofit water for was
able to raise money to pay for the
computers and the and the and the
internet uh that the state the state
couldn't do so um we thought a program
needs to be established you can't fund
it if you don't have it established
which is why this bill and we know it's
a tough budget year so we thought let's
get the program done if it turns out at
the end of the day there's a million
bucks we'll take it and run if it's half
a million bucks we'll take it and run or
there are other providers that certainly
can qualify and and take it run run as
well um so what Rob did is he realized
there were some school districts that
had pre and went into some of the school
districts and there are a number of
school districts that now are using
Waterford we went to London Dairy
because they have opo Tobit money and
from our perspective if you teach a
child how to read and they can go to
kindergarten ready to learn to read or
whether they learn in the first grade I
mean I had want to learned it grandchild
who learned in the first grade and I
have a dyslexic child and let me tell
you that's a whole another ball of wax
but um if you can set them up for
success and they can eventually read by
the time they in third third grade the
trajectory of those kids being
successful and not dropping out and not
doing drugs and alcohol is terrific and
so that was the whole point of this is
to get kids so their brains are are are
really ready to read so we went to
London der because they got money from
the opioid fund and we went to London
der and said can you use they had I like
$60,000 well London der was really
excited about it because they don't have
hold day kindergarten and they said to
Rob and Waterford well could you tailor
a program to use with the kindergarten
kits and the afternoon for 15 minutes so
that because they don't have full day
kindergarten they're not falling behind
and of course waterfit said yes of
course they went to the H's office asked
for the money and the H's office said no
you know we we're giving the money after
they got the problem and you're thinking
whoa there's one little line that says
prevention but you know whatever so you
know from our perspective it's a
prevention
program whether the state continues to
use water for or someone else we just
wanted to put it on the bucks so there's
the opportunity if ever there is money
it's been tremendously successful
private providers are using it school
districts are using it and their home
schoolers are using it and some people
who just are doing day when I say
daycare daycare themselves at home are
using it and the the number the numbers
are great I'm going to hand you out
three letters um each program no matter
whether it's a provider program or an at
home program has a coach so the coach is
watching and and basically saying this
is working we need to we need to work a
little bit more on that and I've got
also
um I unfortunately did not bring but one
copy but I'll send you this too it's the
Waterford uh final report from 2324 and
2223 and Rob can answer technical
questions I can answer questions about
what we tried to do in New Hampshire but
we very proud of working with water F
because it really it really has helped
kids and it's was wonderful during Co I
will say again so happy to answer
questions and thank you for listening to
a little bit of my rambling but thank
you thank you very much uh
questions rident Murray um thank you Mr
chair I'll just wait until because it
might be sorry
so I I I do have a question for you in
addition to the initial cohort size of
individuals that seems to have expanded
outside of the homebased program it
seems like your initial kit is fairly um
malleable so like one person might need
just a laptop whereas one person might
need internet connectivity and a laptop
or something else but my question really
is with regard to you mentioned um
Second Language Learners or English
limited proficiency um are you providing
transcription and translation services
in the event that an individual or a
family needs those as well yes
absolutely so we work with a translation
service uh that we have coaches who
speak um Spanish and uh Haitian Creole
but out we work with a translation
service that will um speak in over a 100
languages so if we have identified a
family that speaks outside of the
languages of our existing staff we will
coordinate with the translation service
to be on the
phone and we will translate all of our
materials into those languages for the
families as
well representative Terry
yeah um it it it sounds to me from your
uh testimony both of you that you would
find um this piece of proposed
legislation helpful to you uh could you
just describe in a little bit more
detail how it would be helpful to you in
what ways it would be helpful to you and
and also if you are aware of uh similar
legislation uh in other states um that
may have already been enacted into law
and how that would mesh with
this I can take part of it Rob can take
part of it um this is really a public
private partnership and so how we
envision this is that that waterfood
would do as it has in the past Contin to
contribute computers internet things
like the the coaches Etc and the state
would would be able to help Fray def
Fray the cost of the curriculum Etc and
and doing the other thing is by having
the legislation it really one it allows
the state to put in a little bit of
money and two it really gives gives it
um validity particularly going into some
of the the in the case of of schools
that might or towns that might want to
fund it and and as I said with like the
op money you if you if we could have
accessed that then that would have been
kids that were accessed with that money
the London Dairy where is the state
money uh could help us cover cover
others um yes there has been legislation
in other states and other states it has
been funded by the state um
we are not certainly coming in here and
asking for for total funding we' really
like to continue the public private
partnership and Rob may want to add out
that uh what I would add is yes we have
uh successfully seen similar legislation
our upstart product itself was uh
created uh from legislation enacted in
uh the state of Utah uh well over a
decade ago is legislation similar to
that is what created uh the building of
our software
representative
C thank you and thank you for taking my
question um so it it in what I'm hearing
in your testimony it sounds like you
support this legislation because it
specifically uses the program that you
represent would you still want to
support this legislation if other
companies programs like the creative
curriculum for example or which is a
play base that also still teaches
literacy skills um that was deved veled
in the 1970s um but if if it were not
your program but the program of another
company or another founder that has
nothing to do with you 100% as a as a
native New Englander and as a person who
ass sered families in Early Education in
the state of New Hampshire prior to
coming to Waterford that is my first and
foremost intent behind this bill so if
it did not happen to benefit Waterford
um I would still stand behind this bill
100% res Mur thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um we
talked a little bit about SE languages
but we also should talk about IEPs and
504s and how those uh potential
reimbursement for services through your
program or utilizing those types of
things how do you envision providers
getting reimbursed for services that
utilize a program like
this we may have to get back to you on
that one but I didn't know that this is
my ignorance I didn't know that children
pre school had an IEP and got services
but do they
H3 oh ag3
okay sorry for my
ignorance um we would that's not
something we have done in the state of
New Hampshire but we would work
collaboratively um we do believe in a um
um
a scalable model so if there was an
opportunity to work collaboratively in
that effort uh we certainly would be
adaptive to uh and open to those kinds
of
opportunities R Woodcock thank you Mr
chairman good morning I just to follow
up to your uh dialogue about the state
of New Hampshire the doe uh funding you
for this for a million and a half
dollars um is there a reason why they
they aren't funding it this year they
haven't put in their
budget it was a federal program that's
run through um through UNH and you're
only allowed to have it have one Grant
and so that's why they couldn't couldn't
fund it continue to fund it they had
told us that if we ran out of money we
had so many kids that we ran out of the
1.5 that they would find away to fund it
but unfortunately when we were running
out of money budgets were getting tight
and we could not get arper money and so
it hasn't been been it had was not
contined to be funded they didn't have
their own money to do it and they
weren't Federal programs that that point
that we were eligible for there is a
federal program though that I think
water
for we have received a an eir Grant uh
from the Department of Education for
summer learning path for the next three
years which will benefit the state of
New Hampshire uh so we will be serving
children uh for a summer learning for uh
children entering kindergarten uh so
prek and kindergarteners going into
first grade for the next three Summers
uh so in the our summer learning path is
intended to help support children in
what we would consider the summer slide
so it supports children in that summer
Gap uh to prevent summer slide it's the
same software but because our software
serves children from prek all the way up
through seven uh second grade
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for your
testimony uh forgive me if I missed
something how long has been the
Waterford been in in in
place Waterford has been uh around for
40 years okay thank
you see no further questions thank you
very much both for being here this
morning
time representative wheeler
thank you Mr chairman friends and
colleagues on the house education and
policy Administration committee uh for
the record my name is representative
Jonah Orion wheeler I represent the
towns of Peter bro and Sharon I believe
that Miss Rosenberg and the man to her
right did a good job explaining why this
legislation is important I believe
representative Pearson did the same I'm
here simply to say I support the
kindergarten Readiness program and you
can't start life without knowing how to
read and when you don't know how to read
it puts you 10 steps behind those who do
I wouldn't
be onethird the man I am today without
the books that I read and
the liter literacy skills that I had as
a as a young child so I would hope that
the state of New Hampshire moves forward
in whatever way it can to make sure that
our children are reading and standing
strong and educating themselves at that
early age as they go into school so
thank you very much Mr chairman I
appreciate you giving me the time to
affirm my support as a sponsor of this
Bill thank you very much for being here
any
questions seean thank you very much for
uh taking time to come to education
policy
committee um with that I'll close the
hearing on uh House Bill 6 71 and in a
couple of minutes we'll start the uh
next
hearing
e
e e
I think we're about set to move on to
our next
bill um and I'll just point out that um
Jen kind handed out a fiscal note that
she received about 20 minutes ago for
the prior Bill 671 so I think everyone
should have a copy of
that so with that um we're on to House
Bill
781 which is um requiring school
districts to adopt policies establishing
a cell phone free education and making
an appropriation
therefore and and um taking the hot seat
as representative litfield thank you
very
much good morning thank you Mr chairman
and thank you committee members my name
is representative Melissa Lichfield and
I represent the towns of Brentwood
Danville and Fremont New
Hampshire I come before you today with
uh one of three cell phone bills that
have been put out there this particular
session what makes my cell phone bill
different is I do have an appropriation
um one of the things that I wanted to
start by sharing with you is just simply
systemic problems require systemic
Solutions a study by Professor Michael
pner at the University of Oregon found
that if you are focusing on something
and get interrupted on average it will
take you 23
minutes for you to get back to the same
state of
focus and my thought is if you've got a
kid on a class that's 50 minutes long
and their cell phone is
pinging one ping two pings your entire
focus is gone for that entire class
period also the writer Don bald James
Baldwin had said not everything that is
faced can be changed but nothing can be
changed until it is faced this crisis is
human-made and it can be unmade by us
too um the Pew Research Center which is
bipartisan has stated that most most
Americans back cell phone bands during
class but few are all day restrictions
68% of us adults say that they support a
ban on middle and high school students
using cell phones during class the
Washington Times October 3rd 24 um they
they are stating that cell phone banss
for public schools um for public school
students do divide parents and I wanted
to address that a little bit early on um
I know one of the biggest concerns that
the parents have is Safety and Security
and within this bill and all of the
bills that have come forward there are
exceptions if you're on IEP certain 504s
and certainly if there is a medical
issue that being said I had served for
many years on the sau6 Safety and
Security committee on that committee we
actually were the first to win an award
in the state of New Hampshire for our
progress with Safety and Security we
started just after the Sandy Hook track
try one of the things that we learned
about was there's a hierarchy with the
cell phone towers so if there is some
type of an emergency the First
Responders actually have access to that
first and these kiddos are going to fall
down at the bottom of the totem pole um
I also want to throw out to you some
hypotheticals that have happened which
we joke but it's true the kiddo's
frontal loes have not completely
developed as yet there have been times
where kiddos have thought it was funny
just harmless to text a parent saying oh
Mom oh Dad I got shot in the like it's
not funny and we can't have that sort of
thing
happening the other thing that came up
too is you hear this a lot quite often
that the parents are with good
intentions I've done it myself but what
do you want for dinner tonight right it
can wait it can wait um Florida last
year became the first state to enact a
ban on cell phones during class time as
Governor Ron decided to sign this into
law he said social media does more harm
than good more than a dozen states from
Alabama to Connecticut have followed
suit amid bipartisan consensus that
scream time damages young people
mentally and emotionally California
governor Nome signed a law that requires
every public school and Charter School
to limit or prohibit smarton smart holds
by July of
2026 Virginia governor Glenn yunin
signed an uh an ex order in July that
required public schools to implement
bell-to-bell bands by January and last
one Pennsylvania Governor Josh Shapiro
signed into law in July $100 million in
Grants I point that out because I asked
for
$250,000 and we're getting pushed back
um but he signed an executive order for
100 million in Grants to buy lockable
cell phone pouches for schools that that
um that yeah that will lock the devices
for the
day veteran teachers say that they have
observed for years that students use
phones more for cyberbullying
pornography and video games than for
texting
parents um among those who support a
band 70% say a major reason students
would develop social skills 50% say a
major reason reason it students would be
less likely to
cheat 39% say a major reason is it would
reduce bullying in the schools
so 72% of United States High School
teachers say cell phone distraction is a
major problem in the classroom High
School teachers are saying that cell
phone policies are hard to
enforce Governor um the governor of New
York has a plan to ban only smartphones
which I thought that was interesting by
the way um basically you could still use
your flip phones and your your slide
phones um the cell phone statistics
though I wanted to share this is 20
consumer Fair cure key insights almost
all Americans
98% own a mobile phone this translates
to almost 331 million people more than 9
out of 10 91% of Americans own a
smartphone each day Americans spend 4
hours and 30 minutes on their mobile
phones and check their phone 144 times
per day so like I I tried to like do a
little bit of math like it AI had said
the average American gets about 5 uh 5.7
hours of sleep per night so I round it
up to 6 hours and you know doing the
math from there um it seems to
me that we are checking our telephones
on average every 7 and 1 half minutes
during the waking
hours nearly 57% of Americans consider
themselves mobile phone addicts children
on children on average get their F first
phone at 11.6 years old which by the way
that's below the minimum age for social
media
platforms over half 62.7 n% of the
world's internet traffic comes from
mobile phones in 2023 the US Surgeon
General released a social media media
advisory nearly 70% of parents say
parenting is now more difficult than it
was 20 years ago with technology and
social media as the top two-sided
reasons um they threw out their
suggestions for policy makers and that
was you know just basically what can we
do what can we do out there um as
stakeholders in our communities
suggestions for policy makers pursue
policies that further limit access in
ways that minimize the risk of harm to
social media for all children um and
then for parents parents to create
tech-free zones
um another Pro problematic issue is
social media use has been linked to ADHD
um also social media fear of missing out
or the pervasive apprehension that
others might be having rewarding
experiences from one which one is absent
has been associated with depression
anxiety and
neuroticism also the Pew Research Center
this is
12522 um they stated that nearly half of
us teens have been bullied or harassed
online with physical appearance being
seen as a relatively common reason I 46%
at least one have experienced at least
one type of cyber bullying
listed uh within that Encompass within
that 32% have experienced offensive name
calling 22% spreading false rumors about
them 177% receiving explicit images they
did not ask for 15% constantly being
asked where they are what they're doing
or who they are with by someone other
than a parent
10% physical threats 7% having explicit
images of themselves shared without
their
consent so I had come up with
$250,000 for a grant which I realize I
probably don't have the best timing um
right during a budget year I know things
are tight so I'll just tell you that
going into it I I was at um an education
conference this past fall and to be
perfectly honest with all of you I
didn't necessarily see the cell phone
use in the schools as a problem until
that conference simply because as many
of you know you've heard me say before I
have four kiddos and they've been to
both public and private schools my kids
aren't allowed to use their cell phone
so at the middle school level it was
just no cell phone use whatsoever
whether it was don't bring it or keep it
in your backpack uh at the high school
level I know right now my daughter is
experiencing they just have shoe racks
you know the pouches when you come in
the classroom you put it in the pouch
and you take it out as you leave um they
do allow children to have it for the
last 20 minutes of study hall you know
during lunch um in between
periods but my point is that when I sat
there and I listened to this and they
talked about um how addictive the cell
phone is I have to be honest with you I
had to sit back and I had to think you
know as an adult um I think I'm addicted
to my cell phone my son for example he
was at the Super Bowl this weekend and I
didn't hear from him after the Super
Bowl and 3:00 a.m. here I am checking my
phone why didn't they text me they made
it back to the hotel safe you know so I
I do I completely understand where
parents are coming from so my thought
was that I went ahead and I researched
you know um the school districts that
are out there um the average public high
school in New Hampshire is 536 students
um I went down the list of listing you
know each of the largest schools and I
thought okay there is a program and it
doesn't have to be the specific program
it just happened to coincidentally be a
vendor that was at the conference and it
was Yonder which is what we heard about
from some people that testified here
before the nice thing about a program
like that is that $ thousand mini
computer that parents spend so much
money on is with the child at all times
throughout the day right they put it in
the pouch it magnetically closes there
are magnets let's say this is the exit
of the school where the kids just swipe
and within 3 seconds they have access to
their phone again I also personally
think it's a little bit more San I
appreciate the shoe racks I think it's a
great idea but I do think the pouch is
probably more sanitary to be perfectly
honest with you it's your own pouch so I
figured 250,000 at roughly um $30 each
that covers about
8,333 pouches I know that's woefully low
compared to the 60,000 students that we
have here I just in my thoughts I did
not necessarily see a top- down order
working with something like this because
we are so used to having our cell phones
on us at this point in time and I
honestly thought that if we were to get
a pilot program working out there with
schools that are interested I have no
doubt that they're going to show high
success rates they're going to show kids
that are happier we've heard that um
hopefully we'll have uh higher scores
out there for these kiddos and my
thought was that would help us to
organically gain more momentum and
people would say hey wow this is really
working for that district and this
District let's hop on board I also
didn't want to put out there an unfunded
Mandate of any type so I figured that
this was the best way to compromise I do
want to address too that I had put
myself on this bill I did not put any
other co-sponsors it was just simply I
have served this is my second
non-consecutive term so I per L did not
get legislation ready before I was
elected you know superstitious um so we
had a very quick window to get that
legislation in as soon as we're elected
um I did that and it was just more
important to me that I get it right with
OS and things were a little chaotic this
year versus going out there for the
co-sponsors um so that's it thank you so
much for listening I appreciate it thank
you very much represent Murray thank you
Mr chair thanks for taking my question I
think we've heard a number of bills on
different iteration
of this I just wanted to be clear when
uh we're looking at this your bill
actually requires a policy be adopted
not necessarily to stand up a pilot
program is that
correct yes
okay represent Terry yes uh thank you uh
and uh thank you for uh the the Myriad
uh of data that you have provided uh to
us today in support of the need for
action in this
area um my question is with respect to
the um the states that you have cited
who have already
acted um are there any states of which
you are
aware the policy or the requirements of
the statute have uh already been
implemented for a time and there is some
initial uh data indicating um how well
the programs are working the
restrictions yes and I can get that to
you in written form but yes there is
data and I'm and I'm drawing a blank
it's down south I don't know if it's
Mississippi or Louisiana I want to get
you the correct facts but um yes they've
actually they've actually seen a
difference a huge difference in their
test scores as well thanks repr s thank
you I just wanted to um ask the point of
clar ification and it's possible that
representative dry will actually have
more information than you might just in
terms of the way um just because I know
based on my husband's job he's at sort
of the top of the hierarchy for the um
when when sell service is uh restricted
to people um because of his nature of
being in charge of the First Responders
you know he has to have full access
right but my understanding and from
being at events where access is
restricted it's that calls are
restricted for sure and it's though
First Responders that have that direct
immediate access to calls but people are
generally able to get um text messaging
basic text messaging not images sent out
for the purposes of safety or
notification I'm I'm just wondering if
you looked at that I think about those
pouches that you're talking about that
lock as students come in and out of
school and in the incidences which you
know hopefully we won't have one
although I'm sure we will in New
Hampshire at some point um but if
students have to get to an exterior door
in order to unlock a phone in order to
contact 911 I'm just concerned about how
whereas if they're in the shoe rck on
the door it's I'm just trying to
understand how
to I I think that that's just one
particular system that yeah um and
right right um I will mention that we
will have a a subcommittee looking at uh
this as well as the other bills so um
hopefully that subcommittee
uh can delve into some of those
issues do you have a brief
response well you stole my
thunder I'm just kidding okay now so
right I understand I understand what
you're saying and first of all I don't
know the answer to you're right I it
would I also got the impression that it
would slow down the time in between um
receiving and sending messages but I
would have to verify because when I did
this work honestly it was a couple years
back so things have probably evolved
since then I would assume that we would
have the teacher would have a phone
number one of cell phone on them number
two um I would assume that there would
also be a land line that was
involved thank you very much you see no
further questions thank you very much
representative uh next Becky Wilson
uh good morning Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Becky Wilson
from the New Hampshire school boards
Association uh we are not taking a
specific position on this exact Bill we
do certainly support the intention of
the bill we understand the desire for a
cell phone policy at the local
Schoolboard level uh we certainly
support the idea of creating classroom
environments that are less distracted
all around um many of the points have
already been made I think by members of
this committee and by the sponsor of
this bill but we would just ask the
committee to consider a few points uh we
know you've heard significant testimony
about cell phones in schools uh based on
other bills as well we want to reiterate
that there are probably four or five
bills around cell phone policies in
schools just this session uh we some of
them have conflicting language or
different language then this particular
Bill we would really ask the committee
again it sounds like there will be a
subcommittee to do some work sessions on
this but that there's some collaboration
so that whatever language is coming out
of this committee um doesn't conflict
with other things that are also coming
out of this committee or other
committees um we also would just ask
again that uh the legislation allow
local school boards and District
administration to collaboratively
develop whatever policy is coming out of
this legislation based on their own
local needs their school culture
Staffing the fiscal impact that that's
that whatever uh language is coming out
in a combined bill is not too
prescriptive we certainly understand the
desire to have certain aspects of a
policy covered or certain content that
would be covered in the policy but in
terms of exactly what is managed in the
policy or who is managing it or what is
allowed or not allowed that that be left
to uh local decision- making based on a
number of factors which I think you've
talked about in many of the hearings
regarding the cell phone use um I'm
happy to take any questions thank you
very much r kuger thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question I was
wondering about uh the issue with the
Apple watch or any watch you know
they're becoming more sophisticated I'm
probably one of the last people on the
planet to get a watch but it can do a
lot um texting being one of those things
have any of the policies addressed that
usage do you know of thank you for the
question representative I can't speak
specifically to individual District cell
phone policies that are already in place
it's not currently a required by law law
policy so we don't necessarily house
samples of all of those policies that
are out there um I will speak from a
district administrator standpoint that
technology is changing all the time uh
again I think that's partially why it
would be helpful if the polic whatever
comes out of this legislation is not
very prescriptive because it will be
difficult if it is too prescriptive to
be able to adjust policies to to
adapting technology um I we have a as I
think you heard Mr Christina say
previously a fairly outdated um
electronic communications Pol sample
policy but again that does it's not
specific to cell phones in fact it came
out of a time when I think students were
carrying pagers and things like that so
I mean there a quite dated I'll just say
that uh but again to address the fact
that technology is constantly changing
what students will have access to is
constantly changing the fiscal impact of
managing that in a different way in
different districts could could change
so while we certainly understand certain
aspects needing to be included in a
policy allowing the Local District to
sort of craft that policy to meet
whatever they are seeing at a given time
I think would be really beneficial thank
thank
you represent Terry thank you uh I just
want to be sure that I I'm I'm clear
with something that you said because it
goes through the question that I want to
ask and that is you are not currently
aware of um how many school districts
have policies what the content may be um
is that correct thank you for the
question and if if regardless because
there is going to be a subcommittee
would you be in a position to be able to
furnish us with some sample policies
that you solicit if you do not from
school boards that you do not currently
may not currently be in your possession
thanks thank you for the question
representative uh we certainly will work
with the committee or the subcommittee
to try to give you whatever information
we can from local districts the majority
of local school districts have their
policies and school boards posted online
the majority of them so if if there is a
district or a school board that has a
local cell phone specific policy my
guess is it's likely posted online uh on
their website or available that way we
can try to collate some of that um we do
not necessarily gather policies on any
particular thing from any school boards
in terms of you know housing that at the
school boards Association but certainly
we'd be happy to to help the department
help the committee get whatever
information would be useful I think you
had a superintendent here previously
from pelum um who said that they had
recently instituted that so I think you
know we could at least do a little bit
of digging to try to help support that
work thank you very much thank you very
much for your testimony and the uh final
uh card that I have is for Jerry FW
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee Jerry FW here for school
administrators Association thank you for
the opportunity to speak with you uh
this morning uh I will be brief uh you
have lots on your plate today um we are
not taking us a position on one
particular um cell phone bill we do
appreciate the chair's willingness to
pull together of subcommittee uh to look
at the various bills and to talk about
uh the various impacts we appreciate the
representativ concern about smart
watches and where they might uh play
into this uh communication piece we
certainly appreciate the representatives
uh extensive research on the impact of
cell phones in schools and we also
appreciate that there's a fiscal note
attached to your particular piece of
legislation so thank you for that um
their competing philosophies um around
the use of cell phones we certainly
agree that something needs to be decided
upon in the end it's our job to make
sure that it gets done whether it's a
local policy a state law or however it
may come about um whatever the decision
may be it's our job to make sure that
that happens um representative Terry
we'd be happy to uh try to enlist from
some of our members the existing
policies and also the procedures of how
those uh policies were developed so we
appreciate that question as well as well
so that's all I have thank you very much
I see no further questions thank you
very much for your testimony and with
that we'll close the hearing on House
Bill
781 and in a couple of minutes we will
start with uh House Bill
e
e e
we are um about ready to start with
House Bill 765 consolidating school
administrative unit
and making school superintendent jobs in
elected position and uh right on Q is
the prime sponsor representative Maguire
and I will be turning the gavl over to
Vice
chair thank you very much Madam
chair um and members of the committee
for the record my name is Dan McGuire
and uh I'm very impressed you're on time
today all right
so
um the I handing out a piece of paper
does everyone have it not quite
yet oh
sorry this is the motivation for this
spell
um so what this piece of paper
shows um and these are all this is all
data from the Department of education
but it's um it's uh displayed by this
really fantastic website put on by
Georgetown University in Washington DC
called
edunom so that website is a great one if
you want to sort of
visualize um any kind of education
related data and it gets down to the the
school in New Hampshire for example you
can compare all the schools and look at
various kinds of data but anyways this
is kind of a summary page
and it shows three things first of all
it shows that that there's a serious
problem if you look at the bottom of the
page you can see uh that over this
10-year period starting in
2013 um math and reading scores on on
standardized tests have been in a
serious decline okay and um the second
thing it shows if you look at the top of
the page is that money is not the
problem right spending um per pupil is
up at an all-time high um way above
inflation and so the the the the
solution to the problem is not spending
or spending isn't affecting it in a
positive way and then the third thing
that this shows sort of indirectly is
that it's not just Co right because
there's some covid years on this page
but but the trend started prior to co so
what this says to me is that um what we
need is different methods right
different structures in education
because what we have now is not working
and and more money isn't solving the
problem so this particular bill um is
kind of a very is a very small part of
that but what it does is um it
consolidates the number of saus we have
in the state so so the number of saus we
have right now I think is
104 and it includes two that are cross
state uh boundaries there's two school
districts one that's a New Hampshire
Vermont school district one that's a a
New Hampshire Maine school district and
and those school districts are also
single district saus and and this bill
does not touch those so the bill is only
about all of the purely New Hampshire
saus and so I think there's 102 of those
this bill would reduce it to
12 okay and the way it reduces them is
to give one for Manchester and one for
nashaa so essentially no change there
because I think those are you know
cities are single district saus and um
and then the other uh the other 10 would
be the remaining part one for the
remaining parts of Hillsboro County and
nine for one for each of the of the
other counties so it's it's a uh
county-based
organization and the the goal of that is
uh basically partly its efficiency
because I tend to think um with fewer uh
with more centralization with with um
fewer superintenden and so on there
should be some economies of scale right
we can have bigger Transportation
contracts if every SAU had a grant
writer maybe when you put 10 of them
together you don't need 10 grant writers
maybe you can get by with five or
something like that same thing with HR
and payroll and all the other features
and negotiations with unions and and all
the other features of an
SAU um so so part of the goal here is
simply efficiency because and but the
second part is
also um trying to attack the the
structure a bit because right now um the
person that that um is most important is
most in control of the school system is
the school
superintendent um if you look on page
and let's see if we can find it here
um all right on
P yes so on page
seven um so in law in RSA
compliance um etc etc But it
includes a lot of direct teaching
related um things so they do they do
essentially all hiring um and they also
do you don't see it on this list because
they didn't write this as a cross out
but but what's also on this list what's
in the current law that's that's been
removed here is
curriculum and policy and and things
like that so so this bill devolves
curriculum and policy and deciding what
to teach and how to teach to school
boards right so this I think increases
local control um in a good way in the
sense that um the school board is the
closest and the to the actual situation
in their particular schools right and so
and and the superintendent in some sense
is the is the uh least accountable right
at least a School Board gets elected and
so if you're not happy with what's being
taught in your school and not being uh
you can change your school board but
changing your superintendent is sort of
one step removed because it's all the
school boards in the SAU who determine
who the superintendent is right so um so
the other thing that this bill does
along these lines of having more local
control is it makes the superintendent
an elected official not appointed and so
the superintendent would be elected by
um by their you know in the case of the
county superintendent by the the voters
in that county um in Hillsboro it would
be three different election districts
one for Manchester one for for nsha and
one for the rest of the county but but
at least they would be
elected and and so I think both of those
changes giving more responsibility to
school boards especially over
instruction related things like
curriculum um would would improve um
teaching and also um the elect getting
more more um accountability on
superintendence I think that would
improve also and I think the the
consolidation um would would help with
costs of this level of administration
because if you look in detail on what
we've been spending on education over
you know the last few
decades the costs have all been in the
non-teaching area it's not teachers that
are somehow taking a bigger slice of the
pie uh of of the dollar it's the non
teachers that's where all of this ex
expense this extra expense has been so
um I'm hoping that that this bill would
would get some more efficiency in that
area now I do want to say that when I
structured this bill um there's kind of
an easy way to do what what I want to do
here and a hard way and I went with the
hard way so um if you simply wanted to
have few
saus there's an easy way of doing it
which is you can go to the map of all
the
saus and and just start grouping them
right you could say okay take SAU 11 12
13 and 17 put those into a single SAU
and then over there you got SAU 20 and
five and 38 and put those in a single
seu like that right and so um that would
solve a number of problem s
because um some school districts
cross uh county lines right so so there
is issue the the bill considers what to
do with that and has a procedure and so
on but so
so that would make it easier because no
school distri all all school districts
would just be within an SAU it just
would be a bigger SAU um and and there
wouldn't be any problems of SP splitting
up monies right so so U because the
monies that go for that SAU would come
from a specific set of existing school
districts the bill doesn't change any
school districts in any way
um but I decided against that method
because it didn't accomplish necessarily
my secondary goal of making the SAU
itself more accountable
right because I wanted it I I chose to
put it as a part of a county or in the
case of Manchester and nashwa a city so
that its budget would be um considered
as part of the county and and so the
delegation would vote on the budget and
there would be a little bit more
oversight as to what's going on in the
SAU the SAU and the superintendent would
have some some
um more people to help them but also
some more
um some more uh control over them right
so that so that the county organization
which already has Personnel it already
has HR and payroll and all those kind of
things could help with the transition
there would be people there like County
Commissioners and so on that would help
with the transition from what we have
now to this new structure but it would
also provide some management expertise
and and control and so I I like that
aspect of it and so the bill like I said
is is a little more complicated because
of it but personally I think it's worth
it your M mileage may vary so I'm happy
to answer questions thank you any
questions representative selig
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so is it your
contention that um School
superintendents don't need to have any
qualifications as related to education
as related to um experience as an
administrator or anything else because
as an elected person there's nothing
listed in here other than being
essentially an eligible voter in that
District which means that my 18-year-old
could become the new superintendent with
without having any understanding of any
of the aspects of any of these skills
yes thank you for the question and in
general it that's true but you know you
you I doubt your um the voters would
pick your 18-year-old daughter
over you know a a more qualified person
so um we don't have any particular
qualifications for our governor
for our other elected officials right I
don't even I don't even know if County
attorneys are required to be members of
the bar or not um I'm not sure but but
the point is uh no I I think I'm willing
to trust the voters to pick someone who
is qualified and and again I see this
role by moving the the um curriculum and
those aspects of teaching down to the
school board and principal level um to
be there'll be less of the teaching
specific aspects of the superintendent's
job and more of the administrative
aspects followup thank you so for
followup um I I think about the way that
our brand new superintendent in my
district has come in and spent time
getting to know children in the district
teachers in the district um the
different challenges that are very
specific to our small District to
identify what's going to be in the best
needs of our students and I I came from
teaching in a district that was County
based where there was a lot of very
remote supervision how do you see the
superintendent having sufficient time to
actually know what all of the different
needs are of the very very um schools in
our counties given that there's been no
structure or way to transition to that
type of a model
yes thanks for the question but again
I'm I'm just going to go back
to I think those local um
aspects should be local and should be
the responsibility of the school board
right now the school
board I I've never seen my my local
school principal without the
superintendent sitting next to him you
know the superintendent
has um has too much of a role in my mind
and and the local people who know what's
going on the school board and their
principles and and other Administration
that they hire um they are intimately
involved with the children with the
teachers and so on and so um I'd like to
see more local control and and have the
um
superintendent be more of of a straight
administrator the counties um in some
way do you share any concern that
there's potentially some you know that
you've you've done the sort of District
apportionment uh without voter input or
a conversation around that I for
potential disen fragement
issues yeah thanks for the question um
sort of yes and no I mean we have the
most representative legislature in the
country the reason there is 400 of us is
um to
give um everyone a say in in the Affairs
of the state um but we do not
allow we determine a lot of things
centrally in the
legislature um because we don't want
um scattered laws right we we don't want
um this law here and that law there and
so on so so I I guess I'm not too
worried about it because um I think that
so our legislature is twice as big as
the second biggest one it's which is
Pennsylvania much bigger state so we
have representation from every corner of
the state that will be voting on this
and votes on all of our other
legislation so I guess it that part
doesn't bother me too much and and
also again moving the SAU to being more
administrative and more um bureaucratic
if you want I don't know maybe more um
technical that kind of thing and and
less involved in actual teaching I think
that would be something locals would
appreciate right because because they
themselves would then have more control
over what's going on in their
schools thank you um so Additionally you
mentioned the conversation around County
oversight and County Commissioners um as
someone who chairs one of the county
delegations um I'm curious to understand
how you would stand up some something
like this um and without there being a
department stood up within there as
well line of Appropriations don't just
happen without there being a department
to associate them with in the
appropriation control report so I have
some serious questions about if you
could answer how that would work right
thank you yes I do see the
superintendent's office as being a
county or city in the case of Manchester
and
Nashua um level
department um if you think that I
haven't uh written the law you know as
as
um
uh completely as it should be I'm I'm
happy to entertain the changes um but
yes I I think of it as another County
official probably more important than
but similar to the county attorney the
sheriff the you know all those kind of
officials representative Terry thank you
um while um
recognizing uh the demographic uh
differences um across the
states um and in looking at um New
Hampshire uh the data that you provided
uh for
us um and and kind of moving somewhat
between the granular level and the
40,000 ft level because clearly this is
a uh proposed piece of legislation that
will um create an earthquake and
tectonic shifts um uh if if in fact it
were to be implemented in any way shape
or form slightly interrupt uh yeah the
the the state of the room
doesn't doesn't seem to agree with well
maybe it may yeah um so
so being aware that there are states
that uh administer education on a county
level for example uh Virginia with which
I'm somewhat
familiar um would you be able do you
know or would you be able to provide us
with um with data that would show us the
differences with respect to spending
inflation reading and math scores in
states that administer
education um on a on a county level
rather than on a shall we call it a
local level where we have so many we
have our districts could be
characterized in one way shape or form
is
balkanized yeah thanks for the question
I could work on this um I don't have um
specific data
as you're describing I mean there's all
different kinds of um structures in the
various States as I understand it the
state of Hawaii is a one-state school
board right so you know the it's it's it
is all over the place
quick but in view of the fact that you
are proposing a county
model it would be very helpful to be
able to look at state that administer uh
that are structured on the basis of
counties and so I'd really appreciate it
if you could do anything because I'm a
little short of staff to be thank you
yeah and I'm heading into the budget
thank you but I'm I'm heading into the
budget season and so my personal time is
is quite limited as well but I I'll see
what I can do see if I can find a paper
or something represent
Corell thank you madam chair I I'm
trying to wrap my head around the part
of it where the super superintendent is
elected um so I'm from Manchester we
have over 12,000 students over 2,000
employees 24 schools um the
superintendent over just leaving out
curriculum the superintendent is busy
going to subcommittee meetings going to
the schools um attending events when do
you foree them raising money and camp
campaigning without taking time away
from their job duties um which of course
they don't even have to be qualified for
for this so having to campaign every two
years which could mean turnover every
two years of somebody who won't
know anything about what they're doing I
how do you see that as a
positive yeah thank you for the question
so I just in general
see more control by the voters as as a
positive thing and
um I think that we've made the
superintendent just too
powerful with too little um direct
Direct Control by the voters
um
and so
that I don't feel like you know I know
my County attorney quite well I don't
feel like somehow their their job is
being short Changed by the fact that
they're
elected
um
so no I I guess I'm I'm not in line with
the premise of your
question representa Murray thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking me
a question are aren't superintendent
already at the most local premise
responsible to the duly elected boards
that they serve alongside of and are
elected boards oversee
superintendence yes thank you for the
question so it's true that the school
boards um meet as sort of a a large
school board and they they elect or they
hire the
superintendent
um but that's a step removed from the
voter and um
so whereas it's the voters themselves
that vote on the budget and the other
aspects of their school board but but
they don't have a more direct say in
what's going on at the SAU level and
because if you again if you look at
these this list on page seven and eight
it remains that there's a large large
aspect of of teach teaching that's and
and uh running of schools that's done by
the superintendent so the superintendent
is clearly the most important person in
the school system most directs what's
going on and again I feel too a little
bit too remove from the
voters representative
Lichfield thank you madam chair and
thank you representative for taking my
question so honestly you may very well
have gone over this during the
introduction I just found myself getting
so caught in the weeds you know
processing all this that I might it what
what prompted the El I understand that
you feel removed but what prompted
electing superintendent was there an
outcry within the state from
constituents voters residents saying
we're really unhappy with the current
status of how things are done or with
our superintendent in
general yeah thank you for the question
no I wouldn't say it's that it's it's
it's more that
um I'm looking at this I think based on
what I gave you earlier the the the
conclusion I gave you from this data was
that um it's the structure of our system
that needs reform it it's the way we're
going about things that needs to change
and so that led to thinking about what's
going on with the structure
realizing that um the superintendent's
the most important person they there's
no there's not very clear oversight over
the superintendent I mean
superintendent um one thing I changed
was um contact with the public is on the
list currently in law of what
superintendents do right shouldn't it be
the school board who's doing contact
with the public you know so that's one
of the things I change you know things
like that so so it's just more thought
about the structure and I I generally
think uh moving uh I I like local
control and I think that um people make
decisions better not every school within
a SAU is going to be in the same
situation right I mean some of them are
going to be performing very well and and
others less well right and so so the the
way they deal with um education has got
to be different and got to be tailored
to their own circumstances so I do think
um we'll get better
results if we emphasize local
control representative celik thank you
and thank you for taking this question
and it may be that it's more suitable to
a representative from the school boards
Association um but my understanding from
conversations I've had with our
Schoolboard members and our
superintendent and in looking at school
structure in the state is that
Schoolboard members are restricted in
their abilities around micromanagement
of classrooms and classroom models while
they're looking at curriculum as a whole
and partnering with the superintendent
with with guidance around that that they
are not to be going into the schools and
and checking these things they're not to
be interfering with classroom teachers
for the purposes of protection on a
number of different levels in both
directions and so I'm I'm trying to
understand if the school board suddenly
has full control over the
curriculum who's how is this going to be
able to be evaluated who's checking it
and how the legality of all of this
could possibly work especially if we end
up with a partisan component to what is
currently a nonpartisan
position I guess I don't see sorry thank
you for the question but I I guess I I
don't really see this difficulty
um I think that um
certainly I mean teaching is something
that's going on all the time right and
so um it the curriculum and things like
that I first of all people can hire
people who work on that they do but but
also
I I don't know that it needs um massive
change year to year that kind of thing
right I think um people can refine it
people teachers can be given more um
more leeway on on what to teach and how
um so again I I just think that um
moving things more
local um has the advantage that
that um some more more things can be
tried locally and if they work locally
then word will get out and others can
follow you know so so when you have a
more of a
topown um control from the
superintendent to the schools of this is
the way to teach and this is what to
teach and so on um they'll be less
experimentation there'll be less and and
that's not even the right word but
there'll be less
um less fine-tuning for the for the
local um Effectiveness right and
certainly people will find out if a
particular school all of a sudden uh
becomes
effective um and has you know Rising
scores and and better outcomes then
they'll people will want to know what
you doing right and and so
um making that you know not something
that's done by by some number of
superintendents but something that's
done more on the school level um I think
can't help but lead to a better
outcome any other
questions seeing none thank you
representative Maguire for coming in and
we'll see you this
afternoon you certainly will so that one
was is actually going to be in rep's
Hall oh wow okay thank you very
much Jerry
FW
sorry good morning Madam chair thank you
for the opportunity to speak with the
committee this morning Jerry FW New
Hampshire school administrators
Association here to register our
opposition for uh this particular piece
of legislation and I would be happy to
provide you with some reasons
why uh I previously testified in another
uh piece of legislation discussing the
feasibility of reducing uh saus and
superintendant um so I won't repeat that
testimony you have that but there are a
number of questions uh that arise from
this particular uh piece of
legislation uh the prime sponsor
recognized is that person most in
control uh is the school superintendent
at the local level so the question comes
to mind why then would you want to
remove that person further from the
local community uh that holds their
contract and is hel holds them
accountable
um my lived experiences as a
superintendent would indicate um either
from from any District that I've worked
in that the superintendent is a key
component of the school community
um involved uh dedicated to the local
kids the local communities and care
about results and what's happening um in
their place and if if I'm not doing a
good job my local Schoolboard can fire
me and that's happened if it didn't
happen we wouldn't need a legal aid
armor of our association it happens when
folks don't like when a school board
doesn't like the performance of the
superintendent who by the way through
most contracts have a a stipulation in
the contract that they are to be
evaluated annually by the school board
with results with goals uh that's part
of just doing business that's good
business the thought of having to run
for election every two
years I I just don't know how that
individual who is the educational leader
who there are studies and I'm surprised
it doesn't show up in the Georgetown
study that stability at the top is one
of the contributing factors to Student
Success and
achievement and so I think the the the
possibility of having to replace that
person every two years with someone who
may or may not be an educator who may or
may not really be invested in the
children and the families of the
district is a very slippery and and
scary slope you know I I site for
example there are 39 towns in Grafton
County how could one superintendent
possibly
be connected to all of those towns or in
Hillsboro County's 29 Towns how could
that's besides Manchester and Nashua how
could that person be connected to other
communities Bedford marac pelum I I just
don't know how that works in terms of
educational performance and Excellence
for kids I think that's what gets
overlooked uh in this discussion this of
this very complex bill
um I don't think I'm alone in that
thinking and looking at the online
testimony there are eight folks who sign
in support of this bill there are 700
who oppose it I think that's a pretty
clear statement that local communities
want local control and the connection to
their
superintendent um
I'll stop because I know there may be
questions you've got a busy day there's
another bill before lunch and I don't
want to disturb anybody's lunch that's
trouble thank you representative Murray
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question Mr FW do you have any
Clarity on how County apportionment or
reimagining the C counties I'm not even
quite sure if within Hillsboro County
now we have three mini itcher counties
with respect to Manchester and NASA or
if they're potentially still falling
under Hillsboro County as a whole um
when I read this piece of legislation
but do you have any idea on how this
apportionment might affect County
budgeting Municipal
budgeting thank you for the question
representative Murray I can simply say I
don't representative selig thank you
very much um and thank you for taking my
question um looking back at your
experience as a school administrator um
if you were working with curriculum
decisions did was that a decision you
would have made alone or was that
something that would have been done in
consultation with the Local School Board
of that specific School District that
might have been different from the
school district immediately next to
yours thank you for the question
representative um typically curriculum
is is developed through curriculum in my
experiences through curriculum
committees set up by um The Local
District comprised of teachers
curriculum administrators principls
parents uh and some students um and that
committee then develops their curriculum
proposals and presents those proposals
to the local school board the local
school board also is responsible for
approving the program of studies
annually for each School District so
they are kept in touch with classes that
may be uh in process of being developed
curriculum materials that are being
purchased
and um and the assessment results as a
result of those purchases thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Becky
Wilson
okay
okay thank you madam Vice chair good
morning members of the committee bar
Christina school boards Association um I
didn't put in a card I had other
meetings I didn't think I was going to
be able to make it back um in time for
this hearing and I apologize um not
having heard all of Representative
Maguire's um sort of introduction to the
bill I'm Flying Blind here a little bit
um we're opposed to the bill um I think
on one of the other bills I talked about
um you know the number of school
administrative units that have you know
in one person's opinion maybe ballooned
over the last 20 years or so
that's because local communities want
their local superintendent and they want
to be able to hire the person that they
want to hire um so they have a
connection with that community and is
not overseeing 25 28 29 other school
districts and may not even live anywhere
within within you know near near your
community um I guess some of the other
aspects too in just hearing some of the
the the conversation and questions about
putting school boards in charge of um
administrative function such as
curriculum p uh pupil governance and
discipline fiscal Affairs staff student
parental safety um you know your typical
School Board member has a 9-to-5 job um
that's why we hire professional
administrators to do this within the
course of of of of their work you know I
know plenty of Schoolboard members that
have you know work in Boston I know a
handful that work in Boston and they're
running home driving 880 M an hour I 95
or 93 they make that school board
meeting at at at 600 or 6:30 at night I
don't know how they're going to be
involved with with Educational Services
curriculum fiscal Affairs so on and so
forth um as the uh as as as the bill
seems to indicate um we also have to
remember too that you know our school
superintendents are are the educational
experts within within the school
district they have higher degrees in
curriculum instruction and assessment
fiscal Affairs and the other aspects
that go into becoming a certified
superintendent um I'd also I don't know
if the bill made any changes to RSA
194c um I apologize like I said I'm just
kind of looking at the bill for the I
guess there are some some some changes
here as well to on page seven of the
bill I guess but if you just take a look
at RSA 194 C4 the superintendent
Services um there's a a a Litany of of
of
responsibilities that the school super
superintendent is in charge of payroll
cash flow bills records and files
accounts reporting requirements
recruitment supervision and evaluation
of Staff Development review and
evaluation of curriculum compliance with
laws regulations regarding special
education Title 9 I I I'll save you the
the time of of reading through the
Litany of of of responsibilities that
superintendant are are responsible for
um that's why we have you know strong
central offices with principals and
superintendents assistant super
superintendent curriculum coordinators
special ed uh uh special ed uh uh uh
directors business directors you know
cuz running a multi-million dollar
Corporation is is need requires some
specific background and and and
expertise if you will and all the things
that it takes to to to run a school um I
just uh I feel like I'm babbling um
again I I apologize for for not being
here um at the beginning kind of flying
by the seat of my pants right now but
we're opposed to the bill um I think
some of the I made on other bills will
we'll exemplify why so with that I'm
happy to happy to answer any questions
any
questions representative
NATO thank you madam chair um I'm
looking at the graph here sir
and
uh and it seems to me that where're the
kids are losing out on the end here is
do you know uh if there was any
curriculum changes that it's really not
clicking with them
that they're they're not really
excelling in any of this because it's
you look on the doe website and it's
pretty bad uh as far as uh proficiency
scores sure thank you very much for the
question representative um just to be
clear you know I'm I'm not an
educational expert I don't know anything
about curriculum assessment or
instruction um you know you know some
people have pointed to I just I've read
you know I I I keep track on the
articles of people write relative to
public education and in New Hampshire
you know I know there have been some
questions about um a math program that
has been implemented back in 2009 or
2010 that I think was related to Common
Core don't quote me on that but I've
seen some some aspects of that um you
know Statewide you know I don't I I I
don't certainly don't track what every
school district is using in parts of
their curriculum it's just not what we
we don't have the capacity to do that at
the school boards Association so guess
the roundabout way to answer your
question is I mean I'm not certain there
may be something
in whether or not it's the curriculum
whether or not it's the method of
instruction that I'm not aware of but I
I understand your point sir thank you
very much thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you thank you Barrett
can you fill out a pink card thank
you anyone else looking to testify on HP
765 we're going to close the
hearing break
uh we're just going to take a couple
minute
break
e
e e
I'm going to open the hearing on HB
571 including Constitution Day in page
patriotic exercises required of public
schools and I recognize a prime sponsor
representative
Perez Oh I thought I did I
apologize thank you representatives for
the record I am representative Christine
Perez Rockingham 16 London da New
Hampshire I'm here to present to you
House Bill
571 which will simply add an additional
patriotic exercise to RSA
18918 presently only Memorial Day and
Veterans Day require quote exercises of
a patriotic nature end quote in our
schools during the week of said holidays
I would like to add Constitution Day to
that list and include exercises on the
Articles of Confederation and how its
failure led to our Federal
Constitution add New Hampshire
Constitution and include additional
exercises in our rights and
responsibilities as Citizens now you may
ask why the citizen piece allow me to
explain this with a very brief account
of the history of constitution day as
well as what some of these rights and
responsibilities may include in 1940
Congress approved American day setting
the thir Sunday in May for recognition
observance and
cam cation of American citizenship the
resolution originally specified the day
as citizenship day but a conference
committee changed its name to I am an
American day in 1952 Congress renamed
the holiday to its original proposed
title of citizenship day and moved it to
S September 17th the anniversary of the
signing of the
Constitution September 17
1787 in 1956 to encourage Americans to
learn more about the
Constitution as the Congress established
Constitution week which begins on
September 17th moving forward Senator
Robert bird sponsored in 2004
legislation to establish September 17th
as Constitution Day so here we are we
have American day citizenship day and
now Constitution Day but no matter the
name it represents the importance of
knowing about our Federal
Constitution as well as our New
Hampshire Constitution how and why they
became and what the distinct honor of
being a citizen under the Constitution
means what rights do we have exclusive
to us as US
citizens some of those rights include
the freedom to express yourself the
right to vote in
elections the right to run for elective
offices the right to a prompt Fair trial
by jury and the right to live here in
the United States are just a few of
those rights we have responsibilities we
must support we must defend the
Constitution participate in the
Democratic process respect and Obey
federal state and local laws respect the
rights and beliefs and opinions of
others and of course pay taxes
and serve on a jury if called
unfortunately Constitution Day is not a
Federal holiday despite attempts in
1987 but that should not undermind its
significance I urge you to vote a to
pass on this legislation and ensure that
children of all ages continue to learn
why we have the right to pursue life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
thank you for your attention and I will
take any questions
thank you any questions representative
Hall thank you madam Fe thank you for
taking thank you for taking my question
do you think at this point in time that
the constitution is not taught in our
schools I do believe it is taught in our
schools and I believe it has started in
a very young grade my concern about the
Constitution is if you learn the process
of the Constitution and it's in third
grade when and maybe in seventh grade
and maybe again if you if uh with the
requirements of um um US history I just
think that it's an it's a so important
in our lives in our every everyday lives
that there's nothing wrong with during
that week of constitution week to
reinforce our commitment to it with
education follow and follow okay uh so
do you think that the Constitution Day
isn't recognized in school do we know
that I do not know the Constitution days
I do not I do know that the only days
that are really um that are only
recognized under patriotic exercises in
RSA
18918 are Memorial Day and Veterans Day
and you know I think Constitution day is
as important and therefore it should be
recognized to have special special
speakers perhaps special program
um it's important okay thank you
representative celik thank you very much
and thank you for taking my question um
I'm not sure if you're aware but we'll
be hearing a bill later today that would
remove um civics government um history
among other things from our social
studies curriculum is mandated parts of
our curriculum and I'm I'm wondering how
you would see if that bill should
survive um despite the 28,000 people
have signed against it so far um how you
would think this bill would fit in with
that I think I'd like to take the
attitude of let's see what happens with
that bill you know um I don't think
whether you pass or if that bill passes
or fails it really will directly relate
to this because this is not part
something that is going to be in a
curriculum it's a recognition of a day
so just like when we used to recognize
children's birthdays on their birthday
in school I don't believe they do that
anymore this would be a recognition of a
day and not necessarily have to be part
of a
curriculum representative B
Bon thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question um my question
with regards to the amendment um on the
original bill that was submitted uh you
have added an amendment that it shall
include instruct
how the failure of the Articles of
Confederation led to the need for the
Federal Constitution I'm just wondering
why you added that specific um
um requirement in as opposed to just
commemorating and having other
activities that would um as you say uh P
Allegient Stars spankle Banner in the
Constitutions quite honestly I was asked
to add that and I believe I could have
the representative that asked me to ask
that speak to that um I think part of it
is is because it was it's a chain of
events that occurred in the beginning of
us becoming you know a country so I
think
it's part of the sequence of
it yeah just a follow up um and also in
terms of the time requirement it says
one session or a portion thereof um
sometime during the week I'm not quite
sure what you're actually asking that
you have it doesn't have to occur on
that day it can occur during the week of
that week um so I think that's that's
what it is it does not have to be on
that
day any other questions oh
representative Murray um thank you madam
chair and thank you for my question I I
guess I'm curious um whether or not you
would see that there might be a fiscal
impact to any of the education or
curriculum required to prepare for it to
make sure that you were um putting
something forward in a way that
addressed things in your uh the
underlying bill and the amendment which
I do need to look at um so I just didn't
know if you had seen that there was any
fiscal
impact quite honestly I can't believe
that there would be any fiscal note but
again um uh if possible if they had
speakers come in but I think that the
possibility of being able to get
speakers to come in without cost is a
very
probable um certainly people come in and
speak for Memorial Day and Veterans Day
um and then our teachers um teaching it
doesn't have to be someone from the
outside I know um I have a friend who
has um
a child in a school district that on
Veterans Day they just have a big
program that day and assembly and um you
know children who have grandparents or
fathers that are veterans they get their
pictures and so I can't really see that
there would be a fiscal impact on it
thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you representative Edwards
yeah oh
Christin uh I'm representative Jess
Edwards uh Rockingham District 31 Auburn
Candia Chester and Deerfield I I hadn't
intended to testify I'm a co-sponsor on
this but um I I it seemed that I was
called by the prime sponsor to offer
some um some background on why the
Articles of Confederation uh are
relevant to Constitution Day um as you
know from our history the Articles of
Confederation was the first attempt to
get the 13 independent states to uh
cooperate with one another and um and
and and that turned out to be a failure
for a number of reasons uh reasons I'd
be able to articulate better if uh if it
had been part of my public school
education at that's a joke um but um uh
it it did fail and it created an obvious
need for a stronger document with
stronger unity and that and that begat
the uh Constitution and uh a necessary
thing that be was introduced from the in
the Constitution that was not in the
Articles was the uh the Bill of Rights
and so the Bill of Rights at the time
was thought to be so obvious it never
needed to be documented and uh and today
the you know we we're in a world where
we're the only one with the First
Amendment right to speak our mind and
that's a that's really a critical right
and I think it's important for kids to
appreciate uh that uh we could have been
in a very different world had the
Articles of Confederation U Been you
know what what we're governed by today
so that that that's my thought on the
Articles of Confederation being included
thank you very much any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Max
SCD good afternoon my name is Max
Goddard I'm a New Hampshire citizen
representing myself I'm here to testify
um in support of this bill um I learned
about Constitution Day in my civics
class in 2009 in high school um I than
the representatives comments about the
uncertainty of the future of civics
being taught um in New Hampshire um but
uh I have actually read my uh read the
constitution on Constitution Day every
year since 2009 um I just enjoy that
that day is celebrated in this country
at all um I think it would be a great
thing to add to the addition of school I
don't really know how necessary it
really would be but I don't think it's a
horrible thing um but I would like to uh
read just a small portion of the
Constitution today um because I think
it's quite relevant um specifically the
14th Amendment section one all persons
born or naturalized in the United States
and subject to the jurisdiction thereof
are citizens of the United States and of
the state wherein they reside no State
shall make or enforce any law which
shall abridge the Privileges or
immunities of the citizens of the United
States nor shall any state deprive of
any person of life liberty or property
without the due process of law nor deny
to any person within this jurisdiction
the eal protection of the
laws um to close I just have one further
quote to read um from a recent hearing
last week uh is a quote from US District
Judge John cenor
it has become ever more apparent that to
our president the rule of law is but an
impediment to his policy goals the rule
of law is according to him something to
navigate around or simply ignore whether
that be for political or personal gain
nevertheless in this courtroom and under
my watch the rule of law is a bright
Beacon which I intend to follow I said
this two weeks ago and I'll say it again
today there are moments in this world's
history when people look back and ask
where were the lawyers where were the
judges in these moments the rule of law
becomes especially vulnerable I refuse
to let that Beacon go dark today as a
judge my job is not to only uphold the
rule of law but to protect the rule of
law
itself Birthright citizenship is a
fundamental constitutional right the
14th Amendment secures the blessings of
liberty to our posterity by bestowing to
all those born in the United States and
subject to its jurisdiction the rights
of citizenship we are all citizens
subject to the rule of law no amount of
policy debate can change that and the
fact that the government has cloaked
what is it effectively a constitutional
amendment under the guise of an
executive order is equally
unconstitutional the Constitution is not
something which the government may play
policy games if the government wants to
change the exceptional American Grant of
Birthright citizenship it needs to amend
the Constitution itself that's how our
constitution works that's how the rule
of law works because this president's
order attempts to circumscribe this
process it is clearly
unconstitutional I just want to reflect
on those comments and may they be a
reminder to all public servants that
they take an oath to the Constitution
thank you thank you I'll take any
questions any
questions seeing none thank you very
much
anybody else looking to testify on this
okay we're going to close the hearing on
HB 571 and I'll just remind everybody
that starting at 1:00 uh we will be
across the street at rep's
[Music]
Hall
e
e e
good morning or I guess it is afternoon
isn't it I've been looking forward to
this I should know it's
afternoon uh so uh welcome everybody to
Representatives Hall uh an historic
chamber um this and the Senate chamber
on the other side of the wall are the
longest continuous legislative Chambers
in the
country um and I welcome you to the
education policy and administration uh
committee um members are lined up in
front and uh we have uh four bills uh on
the docket for this
afternoon um if you haven't filled out
out a card or signed in in support um
you can do that when you came in through
the doors blue sheets to sign in in
support or opposition to a bill and pink
cards um if you want to
speak so I have a number of uh Pink
cards and I see the uh Prime sponsor so
we will get started with
hr9 which is urging the Department of
Education to emphasize stem Ed ation in
public schools and I'll just mention
that the the mics are live um I'll try
and call several people at a time so you
can line up so we can move along quickly
and I would ask that everyone limit
their remarks to three minutes except
for the prime
sponsor so welcome representative Thomas
thank you very much good afternoon Mr
chair and members of the committee for
the record I am representative Wendy
Thomas and I represent the town of marac
a few months ago was approached by team
Phoenix 4 robotics Club at the Academy
for Science and design in nasua the core
beliefs of the academy for design for
Science and design reflect the school's
dedication to inspiring engaging and
challenging students to become the next
generation of problem solvers students
with not only highly developed academic
abilities but also with a keen Global
awareness and commitment to improving
the lives of others team Phoenix is a
community team with 51 team members from
across New Hampshire it was established
during the 2007 2008 first
season ASD is a stem charter school that
supports team Phoenix by providing the
team's shop space the school holds a
lottery every year for attendance and
due to its small size the school must
turn away hundreds of applicants each
year who don't make the lottery the kids
were talking about this one day and
decided to go online and start looking
at classes offered at high schools
around the state and discovered the
reason they believe so many people are
trying to leave their traditional high
schools for ASD is likely because the
same stem class options don't exist some
towns have higher level math like
multivariable calculus and others don't
same for programming classes Robotics
and engineering classes then they
thought how can we fix this after
several meetings the team and I came up
with house resolution nine urging the
depart the Department of Education to
emphasize stem education in public
schools these very bright kids are our
future they understand that in a
changing World in order to be
competitive in the job market stem
education including software and
Robotics is vital they also recognize
that if New Hampshire places a prior
priority on stem education then it could
attract stem Industries and businesses
to our state which would then allow kids
more chances to stay in New Hampshire
for job
opportunities we understand that since
2017 the New Hampshire state budget has
included funding for the robotics
development education fund processed
through the New Hampshire Department of
Education all public and public charter
schools are eligible for this grant
program in the current state budget for
2025 there was 1.5 million over two
years for this grant
program in the latest budget for
2425 there was a
$455,000 line item that funded the xrp
program providing access to xrp robots
and training to all middle and high
schools in New Hampshire these are
positive measures taken by New Hampshire
and are greatly appreciated however will
be hearing from some of the team members
why they would like New Hampshire
Department of Education to place an even
stronger emphasis on stem
education these kids know full well how
stem training and education is enhancing
their lives and their future and they
would like all students around New
Hampshire to have the same opportunities
to be exposed to stem education and to
appreciate the economic future that stem
education will be open to them we all
know that the budget is impossibly tight
right now but this resolution is a
prayer for from New Hampshire's youth
for the
future in conclusion and I'm going to be
reading from the bottom of the
resolution this house resolution asks
that the general court and by extension
the Department of Education advocate for
the installation of stem curricula
within New Hampshire public high schools
such curriculums include dedicated
courses in robotics Advanced programming
engineering and higher level
mathematics the purpose of this
initiative shall be to develop robust
classes in each of the aforementioned
areas ensuring students not only be meet
basic standards but also gain the
exposure needed to build genuine
interest and
expertise excuse me in the previously
mentioned Fields introducing specialized
courses earlier in students academic
careers would prepare them to excel in
college level stem programs and equi
them with essential skills to succeed in
the evolving
Workforce lastly I would just like to to
let you know that some of the online
testimony that appears to be opposing
this bill was actually entered opposing
the bill that will follow this one which
is 283 so I'm going to ask you all to
please carefully read the testimonies
that you receive online thank you and
I'm I'll take any questions thank you
representative any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank
you uh I'll remind everybody that um
we're going to go with a three minute uh
time limit if you would uh first up is
prano grower from I'm sorry for any
mispronunciations from Nashua followed
by Jonathan Gale
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee for the record my name is
brov Grover and I live in nashille New
Hampshire I'm a member of Team Phoenix
which is a robotics team dedicated to
inspiring the next generation of
innovators I attend the academy for
Science and design in NASA and I'm here
today to express my strong support for
house resolution 9 which emphasizes the
need to strengthen stem education
a highly skilled Workforce proficient in
science technology engineering and
Mathematics is critical to sustaining
economic growth in the great state of
New
Hampshire yet there are growing concerns
about our ability to produce qualified
workers to meet the demands of an
increasingly stem focused economy this
is not just a national issue it's an
obstacle with direct consequences for
New
Hampshire our state will need to fill
nearly 54,000 stem jobs by 2028 this is
especially important for Industries like
biopharmaceuticals one of the most
Innovative sectors in our economy in New
Hampshire alone biopharmaceutical
directly employs over 2400 people
supports more than 11,000 jobs and
contributes $2.7 billion in total
economic
output I hope these numbers demonstrate
the high stakes of investing in stem
education I've also seen firsthand the
transformative impact of programs like
first robotics which teaches students
critical thinking collaboration and
technical skills without it I don't
think I'd be standing before you
today just imagine the possibilities if
every student in New Hampshire had
access to similar opportunities by
supporting house resolution 9 you are
investing in our students our economy
and the future of our
state thank you for your time and
consideration I urge you all to vote and
favor of house resolution 9 to build a
stronger more Innovative New
Hampshire thank you very much for your
testimony good job um hold on one second
we'll see if there's any
questions um yes representative
Cel thank you Mr shair and thank you for
taking my question um I'm just curious
if this a bit speculation but with the
learning you're getting in your high
school and then essentially intending to
go on for the future if stem education
opportunities stop at New Hampshire what
do you think would happen in terms of
your uh likelihood of remaining as a New
Hampshire resident I'm sorry could you
repeat that last part what do you if if
the um support for stem education goes
away within the state will that have an
impact on your desire to stay in New
Hampshire as a resident after uh you
graduate from high school and go on for
further
education um I think stem education is
really what opened my eyes to um the
possibility and like the different
sectors of uh engineering science math
and uh stuff like that I think if it
goes
away these students they're not going to
know what they can do in New Hampshire
and I can definitely see in the future
that there's going to be a lot of what
they scientists called brain drain which
is when students leave new students
leave their um state to go pursue
opportunities in other states you know
we need to make these kids aware of like
what's available to them so thank you so
very much thank you any further
questions see none thank you very
much uh Jonathan Gale followed
by
um uh
OA from London
Dairy good afternoon Mr chair and
members of the committee thank you for
having me here today my name is Jonathan
gal I'm from Nashville New Hampshire
and I'm also currently a senior at the
Academy for Science and design and I'm
here today to express my support for
house resolution 9 which aims to
increase stem education opportunities in
New Hampshire schools and I've been
fortunate enough to attend a school with
a lot of specialized stem electives
including engineering physics and many
coding courses but the reality is not
every school and not every student has
similar experiences like mine not
necessarily because they lack interest
but because they lack an
opportunity however I've seen the power
that giving these students an
opportunity can have recently at frrs
middle school a school just 5 minutes
away from my house I helped tutor and
start a science club for students who
had never even taken a Hands-On science
course and when I volunteered there I
could feel the excitement as they could
barely sit still in their chairs when we
would do a new science experiment each
week and I would only see the smiles on
their faces brighten up every time we
learn something new stem gave these
students an opportunity an opportunity
that sparked their curiosity and their
drive to
learn and no matter the career stem has
become an entral part of our society the
microphone that allows me to present
today the lights that lighten up this
room are an essential part of our
everyday lives yet for many students
access to sem education remains limited
by supporting house resolution 9 you are
Bing you are making an investment not
only the students of New Hampshire but
also the future of our state and the
many generations to come you are
providing them an opportunity an
opportunity that will spread from
student to student and build a stronger
New Hampshire for generations to come
therefore I respectfully ask that you
support house resolution 9 thank you
very much for your time and
consideration thank you
questions seeing none thank you very
much for being here thank
you I
wish I'm sorry if I mispronounced that
followed by yonatan
lensy uh good afternoon uh Mr chair and
members of the education policy uh and
administration committee U my name is
oik chakra and I'm a high school student
that attends the academy for Science and
design as you guys know it's a public
charter school where stem is pretty much
a big pillar of our education today I
urge you to support house resolution 9
emphasizing a critical need for
expanding stem education across all
public schools in New
Hampshire stem Fields Drive Innovation
economic growth and job creation
careers in robotics software engineering
biotechnology are rapidly expanding yet
many schools in uh many public schools
in New Hampshire lack Advanced stem
courses that prepare students for these
opportunities without early exposure to
Fields like programming engineering and
applied sciences students often miss out
on a chance to develop essential skills
and explore careers that are shaping our
future I have person ly benefited from a
strong education which has allowed me to
pursue my senior project at my school on
focusing on designing drug Delivery
Systems for breast cancer
treatment however many students do not
have access to courses that spark
scientific curiosity and prepare them
for Cutting Edge research in my
sophomore year I took an advanced
biology course taught by an excellent
teacher that knew how to spark curiosity
by supporting this resolution we can
work towards ensuring that all students
regardless of their school or their
background gain the knowledge and skills
needed to thrive in a technology-driven
world this is an investment in New
Hampshire future
Workforce economy and Global
competitiveness I urge you to take this
important step by by strengthening stem
education for all students please
support hr9 thank you so much for your
consideration thank you for being here
any questions
see none thank you very
much
janathan and followed
by uh Anana
Aram good afternoon Mr chair and members
of the committee my name is Jonathan
liny and I live in nsha and I'm a
student at the Academy for Science and
design I'm here today to urge your
support for house resolution 9 which
focuses on strengthening stem education
in our state's High School schools in
2024 the National Science Foundation
awarded New Hampshire an $8 million
Grant to advance the state's leadership
and scienic Technology this investment
will support research and Innovation at
the College of professional levels
however to fully leverage this funding
we must build a pipeline of stem ready
students starting in high
school right now New Hampshire's high
school students need better preparation
to take advantage of these opportunities
without access the highquality rigorous
stem education during their high school
years many students may find themselves
unprepared to succeed colge stem
programs or pursue careers in these
fields the $8 million NSF Grant is an
incredible resource but its success
depends on the students who will enter
these programs if we don't equip them
with foundations and stem we risk losing
the potential of this funding expanding
stem education at the high school level
will ensure that New Hampshire students
are not only prepared to excel in higher
education but also ready to lead in
fields like biotech engineering and
computer science investing in high
school stem education is about creating
a pipeline of talent that strengthens
our economy deres Innovation and
sustains you Hampshire's leadership in
stem by supporting house resolution 9
you are ensuring that every student in
New Hampshire had the opportunity to
take full advantage of programs like
those funded by the NSF Grant thank you
for your time and your commitment to our
state's future I urge you all to vote in
favor of house resolution 9 thank you
very
much
questions see none thank you very much
for being
here next was yes you got it and you'll
be followed by Isabella theres
pelomar good after oh sorry good
afternoon Mr chair and members of the
education policy and administration
committee for the record my name is an
Arun and I live in nasua I'm a member of
Team Phoenix a first robotics team
dedicated to advancing stem education
and inspiring the next generation of
innovators I'm here today to express my
strong support for house resolution 9
which emphasizes the need to strengthen
stem education in New Hampshire
introducing students to stem at a
younger age helps them make more
informed career decisions and encourages
them to pursue careers in high demand
Fields New Hampshire is expected to have
around 53,000 stem's jobs to fill by
2028 including Fields like software
development which is projected to grow
by 24% by 2030 and Engineering Fields
such as industrial and environmental
engineering both projected to grow by
18% early exposure to stem not only
Fosters interest in these fields but
also gives students a Competitive Edge
in a rapidly evolving job market
research shows that students who engage
with stem early are more likely to
pursue higher education and succeed in
these fields expanding engineering and
Robotics programs in high schools will
give students the hands-on experience
they need to develop critical skills
like problem solving teamwork and
Innovation skills that are essential for
success in stem careers these programs
prepare students not just for college
but for the workforce enabling them to
contribute directly to New Hampshire's
growing technology engineering and
Manufacturing sectors by supporting
house resolution 9 we can ensure that
New Hampshire students are ready to fill
the high demand stem jobs of Tomorrow
helping to drive Innovation and economic
growth for our state this investment in
stem education will pay off in a skilled
Future Ready Workforce that can meet the
challenges of the coming decades thank
you for your time and consideration and
I hope you can support our house
resolution
thank you very much representative SEL
thank thank you so much and thank you
for taking my question I'm going to
repeat the question I asked the first of
of the students who testified and I'm
just doing it you know sparingly given
the numbers if stem education is became
more restrictive in New Hampshire or
more limited in availability and access
um would that have an impact on your
likelihood as a young person to stay in
New Hampshire in the future and
potentially want to be here or what do
you think the impact would be I think
that there is a big chance that many
people who want to do stem in New
Hampshire and I'm sure there's a lot
that they would go to other states in
search of opportunities because um if
stem gets more restrictive in New
Hampshire then they wouldn't have as
many career opportunities and so I think
it would impact thank you very
much thank you
Isabella followed by Siri from Nashua
and Justin after
Siri good afternoon Mr chair and members
of the education policy and
administration committee for the record
my name is Isabella palaris and I live
in pelum I'm a member of Team Phoenix a
first robotics team dedicated to
advancing stem education and inspiring
the next generation of innovators I
attend the academy for Science and
design in nsha and I'm here today to
express my strong support for house
resolution 9 which emphasizes the need
to strengthen stem education in New
Hampshire Advanced stem education will
contribute to keeping young New
Hampshire residents in New Hampshire
prioritizing stem education will provide
students with the opportunity to excel
in fields such as engineering Healthcare
technology and more it would also create
a more stem focused Workforce many of
our state's students leave for education
and career opportunities elsewhere and
never return expanding Advanced stem
programs in our schools can demonstrate
that students don't need to look Beyond
New Hampshire to build successful
careers in stem fields in 2020 to 2023
New Hampshire gained over 30,000 people
79.2% being from other states this shows
that New Hampshire can attract people
outside the state to fill jobs these
jobs can already be filled by locals if
stem education is made more robust
various stem-based companies already in
New Hampshire such as BAE Systems and
thermofisher scientific would benefit
from the local Workforce already being
trained in stem Fields this would appeal
to other companies which would result in
more companies moving to New Hampshire
and creating more jobs an opportunity by
improving equal access to stem education
more New Hampshire youth will not only
be prepared for high demand careers but
also contribute to the state's economic
growth thank you for your time and I
hope you will consider supporting house
resolution 9 thank you very much any
questions see none thank you for being
here
Siri good afternoon Mr chair and members
of the House Education policy and
administration committee for the record
my name is Siri gonu and I live in
nashaa I'm a member of Team Phoenix a
first robotics team with the mission to
change the lives of Youth through
robotics I attend the academy for
Science and design in nasua and I am
here today to express my strong support
for house resolution 9 which emphasizes
the need to strengthen stem education in
New
Hampshire currently approximately 6% of
undergraduate students pursue a degree
in engineering with Fields such as
mechanical electrical and civil
engineering emerging as the most popular
together these fields represent a
substantial share of all engineering
degrees conferred when our team
researched engineering opportunities in
New Hampshire we found that not many
high schools offer engineering specific
courses by including engineering courses
students would have would ultimately
have a greater concept of the different
engineering opportunities and ultimately
providing these opportunities could lead
to a future generation that is better
equipped to contribute to the rapidly
evolving industry of engineering and
technology in New
Hampshire as a woman interested in a
stem career I feel it is important that
every high schooler has equal
accessibility to stem classes that will
help shape their career choices having
attended a stem focused School I've
personally experienced the incredible
benefits that my school has to offer and
I feel that students from across the
state should be able to benefit from
these opportunities as well thank you
for your time and consideration and I
hope you can support our house
resolution
9 thank you questions C none thank you
very much for coming
today uh Justin Hardin followed by John
Gage uh good afternoon Mr chair and
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Justin Harding and I
live in Hudson New Hampshire uh I'm a
member of Team Phoenix and a student at
the Academy for Science and design in
Nashville New Hampshire this year 400
students are projected to app platum my
school hoping to gain access to its
robust stem
curriculum however only an estimated 150
can be admitted due to space constraints
meaning the other 250 applicants lose
the valuable opportunity to develop
early interest and experience in stem
Fields like I have while New Hampshire
pried itself on its strong Workforce and
commitment to Innovation the lack of a
critical mass of Robotics and technology
companies in our State highlights a gap
in the pipeline from education to
Industry our students are undoubtedly
capable but they often lack the
resources and opportunities to engage
deeply with stem Fields during their
formative years this results in
technology startups exploring
opportunity this results in technology
startups not exploring uh opportunities
in New Hampshire which hurt
survivability in the countless
industries that we've already
mentioned in 2020 over 100,000 of New
Hampshire's 600,000 employed residents
commuted out of state for work and in
2017 New Hampshire was ranked third for
the highest percentage of workers who
worked out of state to keep workers in
New Hampshire we need to adequately
prepare our students for careers in stem
and Technology by expanding High School
stem education we can build the
foundation needed to attract and retain
Innovative companies creating a positive
feedback loop of opportunity and growth
that keeps workers in the state the need
for Action is clear by increasing
investment in stem education New
Hampshire can attract Robotics and techn
technology companies growing a fertile
Workforce prepared and capable of
supporting the ambition of prospective
employers the establishment of these
companies will significantly benefit the
state's economy and that is why I'm
urging all of you to support hr9 thank
you thank you very much any questions
see none thank you very much John
followed by Shelly W Wilkins thank you
chairman cordelli and members of the
committee um
um I just want to uh thank the students
for wonderful testimony today um I don't
have much more to
add but I think yeah I do have two
anecdotes um I when my wife and I were
looking for uh a place to live between
Massachusetts and New Hampshire uh there
were a lot of factors but one of them
was a good education and luckily we did
find that um in New Hampshire um times
are changing and stem is really very
important um so I think strengthening
our public education in stem is is
critical to New Hampshire's future um I
personally benefited from a strong
public education in science uh and um it
led to a career at computer companies
helping um roll out the internet uh and
nobody saw the internet coming when I
was in high school and there would be a
lot of things coming that we should be
preparing our student students for thank
you thank you very much for your
testimony any questions see none thank
you and uh last but not least is Shelley
Wilkins hello cool all right I'm a
amazed when I hear these young adults
speaking I'm moved by
their beyond their years wisdom
how they're able to make robotics work
is beyond
me not only that but those robotics I'm
an occupational therapy assistant I
teach people I'm a professional bosser
rner of cute little old
people I teach people how to do
Prosthetics how to put them on how to
clean them how to take care of their
stumps all of
that these young men and women that I'm
seeing
here are going to be making ones in the
future that can not only grab a baseball
they can already do that by the way we
have
those people like this are the kind of
people that years ago I heard about a
3D um people that use 3D um printing
something I just recently got into they
get the measurements for these under um
um people that don't have the money to
be able to get Prosthetics and they
build them it's people like
this that will hear their stories it's
people like this look at them nodding
their heads they're thinking about this
right now how can I do
this you already
are you've already inspired everybody
here the world is moving fast
we recently had an individual say that
the United States is going to spend $500
billion dollar for
AI just to have two days later a Chinese
company come on say we put the basically
the same thing together with a keyboard
$5 million and some bubble
gum that's
Innovation that's what all these
children here are they malive
minds are always looking for
answers I hear you your guiding other
children other adults little adults in
training that's why I say kids
are you're guiding the future
generations and you're still in school
man that's
inspiring give these children a chance
to
grow some of the people if I may just
point out Elon Musk Catherine Johnson
herie Thomas Edison Edison Clark lilan
Gilbert a leves have all used
stem all these people have helped change
the world some better some
worse I'm seeing the future right here
thank you very much for your testimony
any questions see none thank you and uh
thank you to team Phoenix for being here
with that I'll close the hearing on
hb9 and um we'll move right into uh the
next bill um in case anyone's wondering
it's House Bill 283 relative to the list
of subjects that comp that comprise an
adequate
education and uh Prime SP sponsor Dan
Maguire is U ready to go it looks like
welcome representative
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Dan
Maguire I represent the town of
epom uh this is a quite a simple Bill
there exists a list in the law in RSA
193e colon
2-a um which is the list of subjects
that must be taught in schools this list
has 11 items on it um this particular
bill would cut that down to a list a
shorter list of
six
um what there's a couple of things that
people should understand about this is
the list as it exists now has not been
in uh
law um put was put into law in
2007 so for more than 250 years people
were taught without the state telling
them what to teach
right and I've met plenty of people who
were in New Hampshire schools at that
time and they are
perfectly um intelligent and
capable the list that was put in in 2007
was a little bit shorter than this one
and over the years it has been expanded
and during that period of
time results have not been great right
the the um
the status of of uh people um of test
scores and things like that has been
declining over the last um couple of
decades to the point today where barely
50% of school kids can do English at
grade level maybe 40% math and a third
science
so the one thing the one resource that
we have a limited amount of in school is
not money it's
time and so to the extent that we make
the number of required subjects
lengthy that means the basic subjects
English math science Etc get short
shrift right and so I tend to think
think you got to walk before you can
run and and for schools that where
students are struggling in English where
they are struggling in math they need to
spend more time on those
subjects and and not um you know just
these these other subjects are nice I'm
just because some subject is not on the
list doesn't mean it will not be
taught but it will not be required and
the decision making will move to the
local authorities the school board the
principal the
superintendent and they will get to
decide what is appropriate for
them I don't think we in conquered have
some special knowledge of how to teach
or what to
teach um everywhere in the
State I think that the local people know
their own situation know their own
student body and can best
decide what and how they should be
taught and I'm Hy happy to answer
questions thank you
representative uh representative
Hall
sorry okay sorry um thank for taking my
question three years ago we had similar
legislation that was supported by a
commissioner so my question is were you
encouraged to introduce this legislation
or is this something you did on your own
accord yeah so the way I um the way I
came up with this particular thing is um
my school board in Epsom is constantly
complaining to me about over uh too many
state
mandates right and so I had a meeting
with the superintendent and the school
principal in Epsom and I said to me okay
tell me about mandates right and they
pointed to this particular list and they
said every time you add to this list it
causes us to get a specialist right we
don't have somebody who can teach
engineering we need a specialist we
don't have somebody who teaches foreign
languages necessarily we need a
specialist and so um
so that was the the the Genesis of it
was was the my meeting with the
superintendent and School
principal thank you thank you
representative
Terry thank you uh representative
McGuire from the mail that I have been
receiving uh I um have the very distinct
impression that those who are opposed to
your
bill believe or uh believe uh either
correctly or incorrectly and so I'd like
to give you an opportunity to clarify
here that your intent the stealth intent
behind your bill is that you're
attempting to uh eliminate and devastate
uh courses in these other learning areas
the ones that you have crossed out in
consideration of the priority that you
have given to certain other what we
might call Core learning areas could you
would you respond to to uh what folks
are either understanding or
misunderstanding about your motives
right thank you for the question I think
my motives are pure first of all a lot
of people complain about I work on the
finance committee so I deal with the
state budget and a lot of people
complain about the amount of state aid
to to local um School boards and this
bill has zero to do with that right the
the way that Aid is we decide how much
Aid we have available to give to school
boards is a completely separate process
it doesn't involve this particular list
so it's not about money in that sense um
but again it's it's what's motivating me
and and I think what's motivating my
local school board to say these these
mandates are
unreasonable
is the results in in the basic subjects
is so are so poor and and you know even
if 50% of kids can read at grade level
average well there's some school
somewhere where it's only
25% right and there's some school where
math scores only 20% can do math at
grade level now is it appropriate in
such a school that they take time out
from trying to do better on English and
better on math to to spend time on
Spanish or one of these other things I
mean those are good things right but and
and I'm sure in plenty of places they
will still they will have that um
because they want to um not everything
that's taught is on the list I I'm I'll
take my own example so uh one of the
best classes I ever had in middle school
was a cooking class okay I still use the
skills I learned in that cooking class
to this day I remember that class that's
not on the the list right so plenty of
stuff is taught which isn't on the list
but the but the point is when you put
something on the list you require time
to be spent on those things and that
squeezes I I would hope we would all
agree that reading is extremely is more
important than something else
so thank you further questions
yes representative
kuger thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question as
a bilingual individual I studied a world
language for nine years I ask you if you
feel this is a professional advantage
today in This Global
Society yeah thank you for the question
I personally had the four years of
French in high school I probably
remember about you know that much of it
um so I can pronounce but I don't know
that I can hear anyways um it's
certainly an advantage for some people
right to know foreign languages no
question about it um but I would say
that over
time um it's become less and less
because we are very fortunate that
people around the world are learning
English to a greater degree than we are
learning in other things right and so um
I've traveled ex extensively elsewhere I
can get along
um so you know again it's it's
useful but if you ask me would you
rather be able to do math and and deal
with numbers at a higher level or learn
French to me you got to know math right
I mean you you can have a fine life and
not know French right but you can't have
a good life and not be able to deal with
numbers because people will cheat you
you won't be able to estimate you won't
be able to deal with taxes and money and
etc
etc all those things are important right
and and French is nice but is
it is it required that's the question
any further
questions follow up followup
yes um as a teacher I can't tell you
there wasn't a day that I did not speak
Spanish to my students or to assist
office uh Personnel who needed my
assistance um but also I could say that
a doctor's office an office assistant an
architect I could go on and on that I do
feel in the society that we live in
today it is an advantage and I'm asking
do you feel that there are professions
where this is very viable and important
sure thank you r s thank you um I'm just
curious if you're aware that by
potentially having these subjects no
longer be taught in school foreign
language art technology among others
that it would make um our high school
students ineligible to attend
institutions such as the University of
New Hampshire the University of
Mississippi the University of Alabama
the University of Florida among others
that all of those colleges require these
level of classes for students to be
considered well-rounded and valued and
that for many students classes such as
art or photography or um culinary arts
or other things are their Lifeline to
survival through their high school years
if they are not students who are
necessarily College Bound but who may
not have interest in reading and and
history yes thank you for the question
so there's kind of two parts there the
college student and the and the non-oled
student so let's start with the college
student
so
um I tend to think that um a college Stu
College Bound student is probably at the
at the higher end of their reading
ability math ability science ability Etc
and so is likely to
um want to and go to other classes right
and if a school is such
that it's really up to the it would be
up to the um School Board as to to what
extent they want to make available these
other kinds of classes right so so yes
it's those other kind of classes are
important I mean I uh I enjoyed lots of
kinds of classes in my high school and I
also went well anyway forgot me but
um but as to your question of can they
not get into
colleges um I guess I didn't have my own
personal experience and that's all I
have to go by is that I don't think I
had
to I think
my Acceptance in college was based more
on standardized tests SAT and ACT and
all this kind of stuff than it was on
did I take a class in French or did I
take a class in drafting or you know
something else right so um so I don't
think in general you're going to be
somehow um forbidden from taking you
know blocked out of going to college
because of uh you didn't take a class in
Spanish or you didn't you know that kind
of
thing I I don't know okay quick followup
and and it would presumably depend on
the specific University thank you and
where our state board of education has
talked about things like heat and
buildings not being essential parts of a
core education required to be funded by
the state if we eliminate these elements
aren't we therefore telling the state
they have less of an obligation to help
educate our students for the future and
make sure that our students are truly
the best in the
nation yeah was was that a question
let's let's limit ourselves to questions
please I don't think is kind of related
to this Bill thank you chairman Celli
and represent thank you for being here
and bringing this bill for discussion
purposes uh clearly um I'm wondering why
we call it an ad adequate education when
we only providing providing
minimum cours work uh and I say that
because the amount of courses that you
eliminated initially particular looking
at all the social studies and government
piece courses why we wouldn't add change
the language in this they call it a
minimum education versus an adequate
education yeah thank you for the
question but I guess I don't
see I see the the consequence of the
list being the list goes to the State
Board of Education the State Board of
Education writes rules those rules say
You must have X number of hours of this
that and the other thing they they fill
in some of those details and so um the
net result of this bill would be more
local control it would be
more uh fewer decisions made here in
conquer um about what is taught and more
decisions made in Manchester and Nashua
and you know Epsom um about what's a
right for those particular schools one
quick followup thank you um just to
follow to that the other part of my
question deals with one of the things
that public education provides is the
opportunity for students to get an
exploration and creation of interest and
that's why they come to school they they
may not be focused on science or math or
things they may focus on art or music or
language and my concern is that these
youngsters get so turned off to school
because it's so rigidly academic that
they may not come to school and if
they're not there we can't teach them
and I'm concerned that we we're
eliminating things that may interest
students just why they come to school
school all kids don't come for all eight
subjects or 10 subjects or four subjects
most of them have an itch and if we take
them those opportunities away reducing
their opportunity for inadequate
education would you agree to that
so yes and no so so I agree that um what
interests individuals is is a giant
variety of of things right so uh what
might interest me in a school when I was
a student might not you
but but don't you think that the school
board
would understand that
argument right
um just as well as we do right so don't
you think the school board would say to
themselves um if I offer music whatever
dance um I'm going to I'm going to um
Peak the interest of my students right
and and so on so so
it's really a matter of again because
something's on the list doesn't mean it
won't be taught or it can't be taught
it's just a matter of who makes the
decision as to what's being taught and
and you know somebody in a particular
Community might have a different um idea
of what they want in that
Community than somebody else please
respond to that
question quickly please quickly
responding to your question or asking me
about that I do agree and I think if
Conan stayed out of local control and
allowed schools and local communities to
control within their curricula we would
be a lot better off instead of
legislative but not we dis assemble what
we have here thank you I'm sorry no
comments no comments from the uh
committee members were here to ask
questions and get the opinion of those
people who want to testify
representative
Terry thank you again Mr chairman and
McGuire um having spoken to us earlier
on another bill about the the uh lack of
correlation between uh increased
spending in the state of New Hampshire
over the course of the last 12 years to
the tune with respect to uh amount per
pupil of 58% while uh test scores in
reading and math have declined over that
period and have not U increased you you
appear now in this bill to be talking to
us about the priority of time with
respect to certain subject areas that
you have identified as uh being uh those
that should be considered an adequate
education do you believe hearing some of
the questions and today and the comments
that have been made elsewhere that by
spending more time in these shall we
call them core subject areas that that
would necessarily require the
elimination of a host of other number of
courses that are offered in our schools
is it is it an either
or for an individual
student I would have to say yes right
because a student is there X number of
hours per day five days a week and so on
and so if you if you're you know instead
of spending five hours a week on math
you spend 10 well that's five hours you
can't spend on something else and so but
in terms of the entire
school um I think they should have the
flexibility of saying this set of
students needs more math right and and
some other set of students they're okay
with math so therefore they can have
more flexibility or they can we can send
them to to other kinds of classes right
so so I don't think it's I think
students are in
individuals right and and we certainly
don't know in
conquered the details of Any Given
student right but but the people who
work at the school and people on the
school board certainly do know and so
let's let's uh enable
them thank you representative
Hall thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question do you see this
legislation as dividing widening the Gap
from The Haves and the Have Nots in our
state
so
look
look there are when you look
at all right I'll give you I'll I'll
I'll I'll go partway there with you okay
so one I I ear earlier today I suggested
you go to this um um education um data
website called edoms.com
[Music]
and it's to the left if they don't spend
a lot of money and it's to the right if
they spend a lot of money and it's up
toward the top if they have good test
scores and it's down to the bottom if
they have bad test scores and so on and
they also put colors based on
um characteristics of of the students
and one of those
characteristics is economic disadvantage
right so essentially what we would call
free and reduced lunch right so so one
of the the color characteristics is
um what percentage of kids in a
particular School are on free and
reduced lunch right is it 25% is it 50%
is it like
that and if you look at this
data and and you can look at you know
every school in the state then in detail
you can say what you know tell me about
Smith School in Manchester or something
it's right there but but there is a
clear
connection between the free and reduced
lunch the economic data and the
results okay so this the the kids that
perform
well are from higher economic um status
right
few free and reduced lunch and the ones
that perform poorly are from low
economic
status uh more free and reduced lunch
okay what there isn't a
relationship is left to right on
spending right some schools the the
cheapest schools in our state are
spending like
$155,000 a kid and the most expensive
are spending like 30 or something like
that right and there's no Left Right
correlation with with
results so
so the answer is economic
disadvantage is a huge predictor of how
well people are going to do in school
but but I don't see it as
necessarily connected to this bill in
the sense that
um somehow I I mean I I certainly don't
think that that
um spending less time on math can get
you better math
scores right I I think the opposite I I
I think more practice more work will get
you a better math score than less right
I mean that's the that that's the
ultimate premise of this bill and so um
to the extent that it's important for
the for the the kids and schools at the
bottom of scores to move up right to get
better
scores I think their education has to be
tailored to them and they have to spend
more time on the basics I mean it's that
simple thank
you uh see no further questions thank
you very much representative uh let me
just go over some Basic Ground rules for
the hearing on this bill um first of all
we give greater latitude in terms of
time to the prime sponsors
uh secondly for uh future speakers we'll
have a time limit of 2
minutes if you have written
testimony uh please don't read your
entire written testimony summarize it
and you can hand in uh your written
testimony up front and it'll be part of
the permanent
record please do not just repeat what
we've heard
already we're looking for information
from you and not just a repeat um of
what's been said before we have two
other bills scheduled for this afternoon
one about now at
2:00 uh my intention is to uh recess
this bill for a moment while we open and
then recess these other two bills at
their appointed time and they will be
rescheduled for a future date for their
hearings
so at this point I will
recess uh House Bill
open house bill
768 which is allowing public schools to
contract with an approved private school
I will recess that bill uh for a future
date and we will go back into now House
Bill 283 and again with a two-minute uh
time frame I'll next call on
representative Peter mahagan followed by
representative Timothy
Horgan thank you Mr chairman um I I'm
going to speak on 283 did I
misunderstand that you're not recessing
it are we still talking about
283 on that yes okay I'm going to hand
on my testimony first is that right no
just do your testimony first and then
when you're finished you can hand your
testimony in to the uh clerk right so
okay and I thank you Mr chairman thank
you uh revered committee this is my
first time actually speaking at a
testimony hearing it so it's a it's new
to me and I understand that uh
representative McGuire's motives are
pure I want to say that up front my name
is Peter mahagan for the record I
represent District 12 I also represent
um the all the French teachers that were
ever in pen Academy from 1978 until last
Friday that would be me I also represent
uh French teacher since
1978 and the drama teachers and everyone
that has performed with me at penber
Academy I want to talk specifically
about a couple of things that were just
said um the I had eight children the
eight mahagan children were on their way
to Penbrook public schools which stand
as excellent as a good reputation in the
state until in 1996 the school board
given the vicissitudes of the budget cut
music K to2 in the district they made
that 12 that they made made that choice
because it was not required and
therefore they cut it that means that
pem school stopped offering the heagan
Family Singers an adequate education
because we were musicians by design that
was our decision growing up that our
children would do music and so we pulled
them my oldest was in third grade my
next youngest was in first grade and
then we had eight coming along they
brought music back to Penbrook I started
to give you a history of New Hampshire
but in 2006 we hired one of the best
music teachers in New Hampshire has ever
seen and she restored music to the
school and my children who were already
singers came and joined the choir in the
elementary school my son became a
drummer for The Pit bin because because
public Academy could not feel the
drummer so my background is a little bit
personal and a little bit real and yes
please stick to the bill yes that's
where I'm going um here with with with
the bill
the I began teaching in 1978 when jimby
Carter came out with a with a study on
the effect of foreign languages in the
school and the effect your time is up
please wrap up in the school
okay yeah Mr
Cardell he said that you'll see it in my
testimony um foreign language makes a
difference in what happens inside the
brain and it orders the brain because
language is the first thing you did on
your own without teacher text or test
you perfected your skills before you
came to school in the first grade and
you were told you can't learn nothing
without a teacher and you understood
them perfectly because you had already
perfected your skills what language does
is it restores you to where you were on
your own learning on your own thank you
very much for your testimony any
questions for the representative see
none thank you very much is
representative Horgan here please come
on down and next will be representative
wheeler
please get ready um thank you very much
Mr chair I'm representive Timothy Horgan
from straford County District 10 the
town of Durham and I'm pleased to see
one of my fellow straford County
District 10 members uh behind the
committee table and she brought up a
very important Point already which is uh
educational institutions such as
University of New Hampshire or also put
a plug for outstanding Community College
in next town over Great Bay Community
College so students if they had an
education that was ostensibly adequate
that was limited to what's in this bill
they would probably have great
difficulty being admitted to those
institutions um one thing would they
were going on about the test scores I
used to work in for an educational
testing company those tests first of all
um are very are not very exact they're
not it's not a very exact science I know
especially I used to score openend into
questions on math tests and you would
see a lot of cases of young people
trying very hard to answer questions
when they actually obviously understood
the math but couldn't figure out how to
answer you know the word questions they
were posed with and that's an issue with
other subject areas and also just in
general kids want to learn to read write
do math all the other things because
they want to learn about things so
taking out things like history and
technology and all these other things is
um just uh just totally totally wrong so
kids the reason kids want to learn to
read want to learn to do math and all
these basic skills is because they want
to be able to do things and learn about
the world you know so just drilling them
on those subjects that can get extremely
boring um especially when the drills
they're putting through are not
necessarily that well thought out and to
double back to the testing things they
don't those testing standards uh even
though I said the tests were bad the
companies that put the tests together
think have good intentions and the tests
uh don't remain constant over time they
do tend to get at least their goals tend
to get higher over time so they they
they want to improve standards so the
you know saying the test scores um
aren't aren't getting any better ignores
the fact that the tests are not staying
the same over time so I just I think
this bill is just an extremely bad idea
and uh it should be um itl maybe even
indefinitely postponed when it gets to
the floor as soon as possible
[Music]
thanks before before we have the next
speaker there will be no no emotion
shown no clapping in this
Hall I hope that's
understood representative wheeler thank
you chairman cordelli friends colleagues
on the house education policy and
administration committee for the record
my name is representative Jonah oan
wheeler I represent the towns of petero
and Sharon this is my second term in the
legislature the legislation that we have
before us here is about the definition
of what an quate education is and to me
in the 21st century technology
engineering that is an adequate
education to me in the 21st
century the things that we have here in
this legislation whether they be the
technology and the education the
computer science and digital literacy
personal finance literacy arts education
and Musical and visual arts World
languages civics government economics
geography history Holocaust and genocide
education all of those things which have
been struck from this spill this law
that are trying to become law is
striking this from this spill that's all
part of an adequate education we know if
you walk the streets the lack of civics
education that exists here in the state
now we need to be boosting Civics
education not getting rid of it as a
requirement we need to be boosting our
technological
education standards not getting rid of
them as a requirements this is the 21st
century and while as representative
Maguire said getting rid of this from
chaptered law may not mean that every
student in the state doesn't get taught
these important subjects what it does
mean is for the schools who can't afford
these subjects that they will drop them
from the list and to answer your
question representative Hall that does
create a situation of the halves and the
hav knots I come from conal very
well-funded School 10 minutes down the
road is Conan a very well underfunded
school just because of the property
taxes in that District if we were to get
rid of these requirements a school like
component would say well we don't have
to require these things we're not going
to teach them anymore and then those
kids are set back even farther than they
already are from the lack of equal
education that we have here in our state
so let's not set our kids back in the
state of no Hampshire let's make sure
they have an adequate education that
meets the needs of the 21st century I
urge you to oppose this Bill thank you
chairman cordelli uh thank you
representative wheeler uh representative
we have a question from representative
celik
thank you and thank you for taking my
question as one of our uh youngest
although no longer the youngest members
of the House of this body would you say
that Civics education or some other
aspect of your education had an
influence in you're choosing to run for
office as an
18-year-old well I was bad at school so
I can't I I want to answer it
truthfully but uh what I can say is the
lack of a civic education means that my
students the people who are my peers
don't know what's going they say you're
in politics Jonah but they have no idea
what we do here in the legislature and
we're so connected to the people here
representative Cel as we see here with
all those that came out to testify and
the 28,000 that came to sign in on this
piece of legislation it's so important
to have people civically engaged in
their government because we are the
government and the more that we can
teach that and the more that we can make
the principles of this United States con
Constitution and the constitution of the
State of New Hampshire known to
everybody the better off our country
will be thank you very much thank you
yes represent
n thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming here and
testifying so good leader is a good
listener
and they also listen to the people who
work for them uh and to get the good
ideas how to make the machine work uh um
so my question is uh is there a general
consensus of what is the core problem of
why we're doing so uh not so good in
some subjects uh is it the curriculum is
there a curriculum change is there
distraction I mean I'm looking for
answers from teachers and I've talked to
a few and I'm still getting some
information uh but what is the core that
we need to look at
representative na that's a great
question there are teachers and parents
and principles and representatives
behind me who could probably answer it
better but what I'd say is and I know
this is a controversial subject but the
state house at least voted on a
nonpartisan basis to move forward some
legislation around this in the last bium
I'd say the state has uh forked its
responsibility to adequately fund our
Public Schools over the course of so
many decades and if we were to
adequately fund our public schools then
the gaps that we're seeing in the public
schools would not exist as much as we
do thank thank
you representative kuger I'm trying to
pull
away thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative I just wanted to make
sure that I've heard you correctly would
you concur that an illustrator an
architect a graphic designer would
benefit from art classes in high school
absolutely representative
it's so important we think of art oh
just sketches on paper but as
representative seling pointed out in her
question to the prime sponsor art
education
these what are called elective subjects
in school are sometimes the most
important subject of the day because of
the career path that it might lead
someone on just drawing on paper and
building buildings I have a few peers of
mine who are going off into architecture
because of the amazing drawing that they
draw as a kid and you could tell that
they'd be an architecture today just
based off those drawings but it also is
important because that's sometimes the
only respit that a student has
throughout the day is that moment with
the art teacher the the freedom they get
in a music class the specials and the
specialist subjects are so important for
our kids so that we're not putting them
in a box and making education so rigid
as you put representative Woodcock thank
you thank you uh thank you very
mucher next is The Honorable J
khanan followed by representative Wayne
Burton and then representative Linda
[Music]
Ryan thank you chairman cordelli nice to
see you and the other members of the
committee again um not on this subject
though uh I think this has been uh well
discussed by the legislature over time
uh the product of the legislature is
what is in statute uh and I don't think
that this bill is in the best interest
of the State uh we have a constitutional
mandate that says and has stood up over
time we are public education is to
prepare students to assume responsible
positions in Commerce in technology in
uh in in agriculture in manufacturing
this is what's in our basic
Constitution
um we are we we are needing to prepare
our students AS Global Citizens to be
responsible adults we know the debt load
that our students are facing when they
leave and become 18 leave the public
schools uh we want them to be engaged
citizens and that is the subject around
those details in the social sciences uh
we want them to be technologically
prepared these this section of statutes
has evolved over time uh Agriculture and
cooking uh were a part of a mandated
education and aren't any longer these
rules evolve and I'll give you just a
sense of where who who was behind some
of these I spent six years in the state
senate uh on the education and Workforce
committee uh chaired it for a couple of
years and worked with the chairman and
others here
uh social studies uh the enumeration of
requirements here were uh introduced by
Senator dallesandro and Senator Carson
uh the the engineering and Technologies
was introduced by Senator Bob G
uh personal finance introduced by Rick
lad computer science introduced by Terry
wolf these are not left-wing kinds of
people uh coming up with uh woke
curriculum this is uh the the basic
needs of that
technologically prepared Global citizen
responsible adults that should be the
goal of Education in the state and in
fact I I think think this the sponsor uh
should look uh further in in statute of
193 and find that uh in fact it says the
policy of New Hampshire for elementary
secondary education is to prepare for
successful participation in social
economic scientific technological and
political systems and yes languages and
arts and culture are are things that
prepare the mind for uh in different
ways so that some students students can
succeed where they may not succeed in
other things I just want two other
points one quickly if you could students
uh have math and English throughout
every 12 years of of of schooling in the
state and second that our current
structure has New Hampshire continuously
in the top five performing states in the
nation don't change this section of
statute and oppose this Bill thank you
very much thank you very
much next is um representative
Burton and followed by representative
Ryan good afternoon thank you Mr
chairman thank you to the
committee uh let's be clear about one
thing if this bill passes into law UNH
will not be able to accept an
application from a single high school
graduate in New Hampshire because they
have a requirement for two years of a
language and they have other
requirements just to apply now if UNH
drops its standards to to allow this to
happen then they'll lose their
accreditation because the the Nei
accreditation is very clear on this
general education uh referred to as the
Arts and Sciences you have to have them
in a higher education
institution it could
cost them those colleges that drop their
standards to allow this to happen and
have students come in at variance to not
get their uh not get to
college now the Constitution says more
than what was just
read the Constitution actually has
curriculum in it it says it shall be the
duty of the legisl Lors to encourage
private and public
institutions rewards and immunities for
the promotion of Agriculture Arts
sciences and commerce that's in the
Constitutional
mandate I finished with I looked I
looked at other colleges about what they
require and I found one that was very
interesting it happens to be the alma
moer of two members of the house uh
finance committee I think I think it's
called
MIT the MIT has disciplines the students
have to take eight units in the
humanities arts and social sciences if
sciencists at MIT have to take these
courses our students should be able to
take them in the public school system
thank you very much for the time thank
you
representative nice
timing uh representative Ryan followed
by representative Reed
thank you my esteemed colleagues on the
committee um I'm changing what I
originally wrote because I'm um a little
bit incested and I rate okay I am um for
full disclosure I am Linda Ryan the
state representative from nashal I
represent District 4 I'm a retired
Middle School teacher um we teach
reading writing and math in science
class we teach Holocaust in in social
studies class we read books that involve
those subjects in Reading I'm not sure
what people think we taught in Reading
if we weren't reading about things that
have to do with our government or our
country or geography or whatever okay
Second Step sorry my original point was
do we have a fiscal plan for all the
people that we're going to now put out
of jobs who own homes in our city in our
state who pay taxes because last count
that would be half the teachers in my
school around the corner from me okay
third point and this is very very
personal as a no lunch Kid trailer park
child okay if I had to only be exposed
to Reading Writing and math I would not
be standing here before you with a
master's degree in education a degree in
social work and a science certification
from Harvard summer school okay poor
kids do not lower your scores we are
number five in the country New Hampshire
is number five in the country I looked
it up again just now all right people
who don't do well in reading and writing
and math are taken out of classes like
art music and homac and sent to
additional math and reading classes as
good practice is in middle school
education right if if if your school
district isn't doing that you really
need to look at them and what they're
doing thank you questions please thank
you very much any questions see none
thank you very much next is
representative Reed followed by Mike
corkery thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members my name is Ellen Reed
I represent Rockingham 10 that's new
market and new fields for full
disclosure I have a bill in before you I
believe next week or it's coming up that
does almost exactly the opposite I'm
expanding specifically Holocaust and
genocide studies because I think we need
to teach our children things that are
important about the world and that's
exactly why this is a terrible Bill uh
I'm not going to belabor points probably
that you've already heard although
didn't didn't catch everything um but we
know that we have failing education
because we're not we know our standards
are not up to what the rest of the world
is the answer is not to teach our
children less we know that the average
person can't name the three branches of
government or who their Federal
delegation are or what the difference
between the state house and Congress is
we already know that the average person
doesn't know the difference between
Nazis and Communists who were mortal
enemies and stood for exactly the
opposite things but most people don't
know that we know that our education
system is failing the answer is not to
teach people
less but I think that this has been by
Design because if you defund a program a
social program to the point that it
starts failing
then you get to say look that program is
failing we can get rid of it it should
be privatized and that's exactly what's
been
happening so the answer is not to teach
our children less the answer is to teach
our children more and I wanted I wasn't
even going to talk on this but I have a
very specific story of my own to share I
am from South Memphis a very
impoverished neighborhood of a large
metropolitan area the population of
which is larger than this entire
State I went across the city I took
three public buses to to go across the
city because I was a gifted student and
I got to go to a public school that was
a good Public School it had a
planetarium it had an astronomy course
it was a blue ribbon presidential school
for international studies including
languages and I got to go to that school
and I had opportunities that I wouldn't
have had and I was a I took all I I'll
be brief I took all honors in ap's
courses but for one year I had to go to
my local school in the wrong part of the
city and the teaching was so different
because they did only teach reading and
writing and here's a textbook copy 10
pages out of it while they sit there and
read a newspaper and my grades went from
a to c i was a bright and gifted student
and that method of teaching where we
teach to pressure and teach to
Performance and not teach about the
world around us and en encourage that
Curiosity about the world around us took
me from a straight A student to C but I
went back to that wonderful gifted
school and I graduated second and in my
class and I got a Bachelor's in science
in molecular biology from Vanderbilt
University with a double minor in
religious studies and Japanese I speak
Japanese I lived in Japan for three
years and I got a master's up here at
UNH because of that wonderful expansive
well-rounded public school system that I
had access to thank you very much thank
you there's no questions right we're
rolling through all
right Mike corkery followed by sharah ay
hi uh my name is Mike corkery and thank
you for having me committee um I am from
Amer New Hampshire but I am on my 15th
year as a public school educator um to
be frank on this there's so much that I
was thinking of for the last three
nights going to bed but a lot of it has
already been said so I won't add to that
but I do want to add a little bit of
like a personal touch to this as a
teacher in New Hampshire for the last 14
years I've worked in rural towns like uh
Armington New Hampshire I've worked in
NASA I currently work in Manchester and
I worked in Kingston I've seen all kinds
of needs so socioeconomic racial all
that kind of thing and it has been seen
already in other states when we started
to see American governments pushing
towards the voucher system that um
there's actually a book about the south
where they say it's a 21st century DM
Crow where we are very purposly giving
lesser opportunity to certain students
because we are primarily funded on the
the local level and we don't have those
barriers at the federal government not
federal I apologize at the state
government level so the poorer towns as
it's been said before the poorer towns
with less tax money coming in are going
to be cutting these programs and you
will see teachers getting cut with this
because with the Need For Less subjects
you will see less teachers necessary and
nobody wants to pay more taxes than they
have to um to just give a a quick
analogy that I have no business being
such a skinny guy giving but education
is like being a weightlifter okay our
brain is a
muscle right now what we're looking at
is only working out our chest we're
looking for glamour muscles because
that's what our economy is looking like
right now but we are making kids devoid
of culture and we are dismissing what we
have is a United Country we have never
been taken over but I go to Poland and
they have poets in their cities all of
these things Civics um we can't have
students that know how to vote already
students don't want to come to school I
have students either not coming more
than a few times in a semester or
they're showing up 45 minutes late every
day to eliminate the one reason that
they come to school every day means that
they're not going to come back thank you
thank you very much representative SEL
thank you very much um in your
experience as a teacher we heard from
what something earlier that there's a
difference in success rates because of
with kids at different socioeconomic
levels um would you say the sole cause
of that is the school system that
they're in or would you say that they're
outside Factor I'm sorry could you just
say that last part again is the cause of
their lack of success the fact that
they're in of the school system they're
in or is their
socioeconomics uh an impact upon their
success rates um well it is a
combination and they go together I'll
try to keep this brief because it's
obviously a complicated issue but um you
know when you have a student that did
not have uh parents or let's just say
family members in general that went to
college they don't know how to navigate
that system the same way I did who uh my
father is a pharmacist and went to heavy
schooling so when I'm looking to apply
for schools the whole time he is pushing
me throughout my K12 education um so
there's that background but also I can
tell you when I worked in Farmington
we'd run out of paper when I worked at
sa heagan high school for a short time I
had 12 different colors I could do it on
that's a silly example but this stuff
matters we don't have access I I I work
for a school that we do high school y we
can't pay for tests when funding falls
down because of these sorts of things so
I think that you can't separate the two
issues
unfortunately thank you uh Sarah a
AI followed by representative
vone uh good afternoon um according to
research conducted by the Nations report
card.get United States HB 283 suggests
that we should lower that standard by
gutting our education requirements never
in my lifetime have I witnessed or heard
of a government rally behind less
education when you examine what this
bill is proposing you must question both
the motive and the potential
consequences without teaching Arts
Engineering government languages
economics Computer Sciences and most
importantly history what is left how can
you call schooling without these classes
an education at all what you are left
with is a less competitive student body
that is drastically underprepared for
the workforce is that what we want for
the Next
Generation with private schools being so
far financially Out Of Reach for many
middleclass families the state should
fulfill its civic duty to its people and
provide a quality education to all of
its citizens representative Dan Maguire
who has a PHD in electrical engineering
and computer science one of the classes
he proposes to cut should be embarrassed
and ashamed of himself for proposing to
take that away from please let's not get
personal stick to the bill please if
there are no questions thank you for
your time thank
you representative vone followed by
Phoebe and nce
winter and it's okay to come and line up
uh if you're called out to be next
Mark Malone representing eeping real
quickly um I looked at what this
bill would provide for an
education once all those requir a little
closer to the mic I looked at the bill
to to see what
requirements uh were left then I looked
across the world to find what
countries would have the curriculum that
would be required by the state of
meure one Afghanistan under the
Taliban that's what we're talking
about there's a question of time I'm
going to ask you to look at the national
assessment of educational progress the
nape scores for New Hampshire guess
where New Hampshire
is way above the country we're tops we
are number one in Reading I forget what
grade level now that's a different
test and I'm going to ask you to
remember the phrase damn lies and
statistics in the use of the testing in
New Hampshire as somebody who had to do
test a 20-year principal I know tests
and there are good tests and there are
bad tests and there are questionable
tests and I know that eping Elementary
when I was principal for a while under
the old um No Child Left Behind that was
a really good test a lot of people
didn't like it I liked it because it was
granular it was deep but guess what it
was
expensive so that test was replaced by a
cheaper test which I think is probably
the same one today because I retired if
we could stick to the bill and the
subject matter so the subject is the the
author of the bill referenced low test
scores a number of times I am
questioning whether that's a valid point
and whether that's just a just a quick
way to get to my other point there's
time and then there's money once you
take out nearly 50% of the
requirements it isn't too big a leap
when we've had arguments and believe me
from the other side of the aisle there
are lots of people trying to cut the
adequacy funding not raise it cut it
it's a logical extension to say if you
don't
need 50% of the curriculum then why
should the adequacy number be this High
it should be this high if you could wrap
up please I'm wrapped up thank
you uh phebean
followed by Shelly
wilas thank
you hello fiban
nicew former art educator of the Year
Governor
Lynch Eagle Award
recipient the New Hampshire Congress
recipient um of the
award uh
for art
education I was the district art
coordinator in conquered forgive my
Tremor I have an essential
tremor um I was the district ordinator
and conquered for 26 years and then went
to New Hampshire Institute of Art for 13
years
to
eliminate any of the Arts would
be a huge
mistake I took
a
um a boy headed for disaster got him a
job in a um framing Studio he now owns
seven art studios in kport and as a
multi-millionaire one of my jewelry
students was accepted in the league of
New Hampshire Craftsman on her
graduating day from conquered High
School the youngest student
ever to
receive uh uh to be jured into the
league of New Hampshire
Craftsman I have had I don't know how
many Naughty Boys
quote
unquote tell me after they graduated
from high school your open studios are
the reason I stayed in conquered high
school because I didn't go into the
smoking
area I didn't go down to the
cafeteria I went into the art
studio and I knew I'd be accepted
there I have 15 jewelry students who
went out to a
career some of you may know Melissa
Miller's paintings May own them she did
some of the most beautiful
paintings of the homes and the streets
in
conquer if you could wrap up please I
beg your pardon if you could wrap up I'm
finished thank you for thank you very
much for being here and I'll just take a
second to recess this hearing open the
hearing on House Bill
431 I will recess that until a later
date and reopen our hearing on uh House
Bill
283 and call upon uh Shelly thank
you next up will be Heather
robai thank
you looking at this list I can only
think
how
uninspiring this
is with in the last decade our personal
credit card amount that we owe has gone
from over 600 billion dollars to over a
trillion dollars says to me financial
literacy we should be taking advantage
of these young children's Minds teaching
them how to do that economics basic
economics a minute and a half I could
show you why drill baby drill isn't
going to do anything basic
economics Civics it's how we interact
with each other and taking away our
history learning the history of the
world we learn we lose our
place as a
leader and as a
community engineering
Technologies those that generally come
from the
Arts it uses the math
sure but as the representative was
pointing out about the
art if you can do the math of the
building the Angles and everything load
bearing of a uh facility that's one
thing but being an inspired and being
able to inspire others that's the
important
thing
um world
languages the neuroplastic and Young
when you were young and you were
learning not only did you learn the
words not only did you learn the
language of it but you learned about the
history of it as
well and music and visual
arts these help inspire you in your
every daytoday
life and please don't forget to dream
thank you thank you any questions thank
you very much uh next is Heather robati
followed by Caitlyn
brenier thank you Mr chairman and
committee my name is Heather robai and
I'm from marac I'm here today as a
parent to voice my strong opposition to
House Bill 283 marac School District
created a vision of a graduate that I'd
like to share with you that highlights
the skills and attributes marac high
school graduates should possess to
become positive community members who
are future ready whether that future be
a career in the trades college education
or in our military our graduates will be
effective and critical thinkers who
contribute positively in their local and
Global communities their public
education prepares them for this future
by developing their executive
functioning skills financial and dig
digital literacy and communication
skills in the areas of listening
speaking and writing these are the
attributes that I hope that my daughter
and all New Hampshire's children receive
through their Public School
educations this bill proposes to remove
many of the topics that have been
discussed and without these New
Hampshire's definition of an adequate
education will no longer truly be
adequate choices have consequences and
by removing these areas it sets the
stage for these subjects to be
eliminated by school districts as their
budgets are slashed because property tax
owners can no longer bear the burden of
Education costs which have been
downshifted onto them by the state as
public schools are forced to cut what's
extra these areas will be cut if private
schools are the only ones left who can
afford to offer Arts technology history
and these other areas we're creating a
disparity between families that can
afford private schools and those that
cannot as things like efas continue to
eat away at New Hampshire's education
trust fund this bill continues to erode
public education in New Hampshire
setting our children up for failure as
they enter the world without the skills
and knowledge they need to achieve their
Highest Potential by removing these
requirements the state fails to provide
New Hampshire's children with the
well-rounded adequate education they
deserve so I urge you to oppose House
Bill 283 and work to support public
education so children like the ones who
spoke so eloquently today in favor of
House Bill n can continue to grow and
learn here in New Hampshire and have
bright successful Futures thank thank
you very
much see no further questions thank you
and uh Caitlyn Bernier followed by Lisa
Walker yeah way down here thank you yes
thank you good afternoon chairperson and
education policy committee members thank
you for taking the time to listen to My
Testimony today my name is Caitlyn
Bernier and I live in marac and I am on
the School District budget committee but
I here today representing myself as a
parent in opposition of HB 283 this Bill
opens the door to start defunding public
education and is not reflective of what
the majority of your citizens believe
extreme political agendas have no place
in our New Hampshire Public Schools HB
283 was introduced only 5 days before
the public hearing because
representative McGuire knew that the
majority of constituents in every town
and city in New Hampshire would be in up
in arms with the absurdity this bill
includes as of Sunday at 6: p.m. only
almost 26,000 taxpaying members of your
communities have voted in opposition of
HB 283 this bill is an obvious attempt
at decreasing the state's Financial
Obligations to provide an adequate
public education and we see you this
bill if it were passed would see an
increase in Charter and private schools
by lowering the requirements necessary
to provide an adequate education which
takes more funds from our most
vulnerable population it doesn't take
much to connect this to all the bills in
the house currently that give more power
to local school boards allow private
schools to receive efas and the income
limit removal for said efas that takes
taxpaying dollars away from our Public
Schools this is a purposeful and
calculated agenda meant to hurt those of
us that believe in public education by
the prime sponsor I came here to testify
an opposition of H b283 and this extreme
extreme political agenda and wanted to
express to the representatives who vote
in favor of this that you do not speak
for the majority of your constituents
and that we are paying attention this
isn't an attempt to focus on core
academics like the prime sponsor said
today this is a specific elimination of
curriculum that doesn't fit his narrow
views I thank the committee members for
listening and hope you are reading the
room today and see that this bill does
not reflect New Hampshire's definition
of an equal and adequate education any
questions uh next is Lisa Walker
followed by
Nicole tianimu
good afternoon and thank you for the
opportunity to address you today my name
is Lisa Walker I live in Peterboro New
Hampshire uh I am a 30-year veteran
public educator I spent nine years as an
art teacher 21 as an administrator 10 of
those as superintendent of schools and I
was named superintendent of the year in
2022 fun fact in the last decade three
out of the 10 superintendents of the
year were all former art
teachers we are evidence of the power of
the Arts in developing the creative
thinking that's required to be a leader
in today's
world second point this will absolutely
widen the opportunity Gap representative
Maguire said that the kids who do well
in the core subjects math and English
can take other classes like art Etc and
kids who don't do well just get math and
English my 15-year-old daughter has
autism and she performs below grade
level in those core classes she loves
art she loves chorus and she has gained
so much self-confidence being a part of
the chorus at conal high school that she
now sings the national anthem solo to
start her unified basketball
games my final point over 29 , 595
people last I checked on my phone have
signed up in opposition to this bill
against 67 in support how many folks in
this room received that many votes in
the last
election my point is this you represent
the interest of your constituents and
those across the state so I do hope you
consider all of those voices and the
ones you've heard here today thank you
thank you very much for your
testimony Nicole
sorry about
that oh question I'm sorry
representative Murray thank you
representative cordelli uh Mr chair
excuse me and thank you for taking my
question well we are fifth in the nation
for educational outcomes we are 50th in
the nation for State funding if this
bill were to move forward do you see
this um effort as also negatively
impacting Workforce Development and
commerce uh areas around agriculture
through stem Medical Science and and the
Performing Arts absolutely uh you know I
I was here for the the B first bill of
the day where the students uh spoke
about the power and necessity of all of
the components of stem um and having the
exposure in our Public Schools as also I
think representative wheeler referred to
um is integral um to all of those things
that you
mentioned representative woodcock
thank you Mr chairman uh superintendent
just in terms of your experience what
would you predict would happen to
youngsters who come to school that don't
have any interest in math or science you
think that may impact
enrollment
yes represent
Cel thank you and thank you for taking
my question um speaking from a district
across the state would it surprise you
that our high school one of the most
sought-after and difficult courses to
get into is bake shop and um do you see
the a class such as bake shop covering
some of those other Essentials while not
necessarily being specifically a reading
or math class 100% when I was an art
teacher uh I made it a point to ensure
that art I was representing art as it
was represented across disciplines I
would go into math classes and integrate
art through the use of tessellations uh
you know echoing mcer I'd go into
history classes uh that we're learning
about the Renaissance and talk about
artists of the Renaissance and the the
um advances that were being made during
that time so sure in in lots of other
classes the Arts they Crosscut each
other absolutely thank you uh next is
Nicole um and followed by Janine
ler it is the policy of the State of New
Hampshire that public elementary and
secondary education shall provide all
students with the opportunity to acquire
the Knowledge and Skills necessary to
prepare them for successful
participation in the social economic
scientific technological and political
systems of a free government now and in
the years to come this is a quote taken
directly from statute 193 section E1 of
our state's law this sentence written in
1998 defines the goals and purposes of
the
statute ladies and gentlemen my name is
Nicole trch montin a New Hampshire
constituent and a member of the 2020
class of the the Bedford public high
school I will start with a question how
will any of the changes proposed in HB
283 further the clearly stated purpose
of this legislation how can a public Not
educated in the basics of Economics or
Civics participate in a free democratic
government that demands its people to
make decisions on these topics I
understand that New Hampshire public
education is reliant on our taxpayers as
a taxpayer is the education of our youth
no longer worth the our money in the
eyes of our state officials I am calling
for you our representatives to think of
the children the children of New
Hampshire who are attending or will
attend public elementary high middle or
High School are citizens of New
Hampshire and therefore the
responsibility of our state government
they are a group of people who solely
rely on representatives to represent
their needs and to pass legislation for
their benefit this Committee in the
house as a whole therefore have a great
responsibility towards New Hampshire's
children do the proposed amendments to
RSA 193e truly benefit this state's
youth I understand the proposed
amendment does not insist schools must
change their curriculum but that New
Hampshire will no longer Aid schools in
teaching the topics of History
government languages and personal
finance among others I am sure you are
aware of the following implications
schools that rely on government Aid to
teach their students these topics will
have to make changes to their
curriculums to reflect their new budgets
this will infect impoverished areas most
heavily to State the obvious no one who
works in our government on the state or
federal level level is Immortal
eventually children who experience these
changes in policy will grow up and
become members of our government how
will our government look if only
children who have grown up in affluent
areas have the necessary education
understanding to take up public office
how will our government look without
representation from protected groups
minorities are the most likely to live
in impoverished areas and how will the
government look when Representatives who
were never even shown the constitution
in school take up office could you wrap
up please I urge this committee to ask
themselves the following question when
debating the merits of this bill ask
yourselves how does New Hampshire house
bill 283 prepare students for
participation in a free government I
would argue that it does not if an
amendment is clearly disadvantageous to
a select group of people and opposes the
very ideals and purpose of a New
Hampshire statute how can it be put into
law thank you for your time thank
you uh Janine is next followed by Pam
sinat chairman and members of the
committee thank you very much for
letting me speak
um and my purpose in speaking to you
today is not to point out the many
benefits of an education that includes
the subjects that there seek this bill
seeks to eliminate because the people
before me did a much better job of that
but what occurred to me was a glaring
inconsistency between what this bill is
proposing and um what I see going on
with the education funding in New
Hampshire um I was reviewing um some
some of the expenses listed in the New
Hampshire children's scholarship uh
website for the uh fiscal year 2022 to
23 and I was amazed that there are
thousands and thousands of dollars in
expenditures for items teaching the
subject areas of art Music World
Language computer science engineering
and technology and World languages so um
at the same time we're trying to take
these subjects of the public schools
where um resources are used on an
economy of scale for the many the 85% of
the children that are in public schools
we are handing out thousands and
thousands of dollars to individuals to
learn on their own these very same
subject areas so um in summary I know
the intention is probably at the bottom
of this to make the conal lawsuit a moot
point by changing the composition of an
adequate
education but there is a glaring
inconsistency in the current education
philosophy and agenda in New Hampshire
that shrinks public resources used for
the many to scatter them for the few and
in the process decimating the education
for the many thank you thank you for
your
testimony uh next is uh
Pam is she
here uh not seeing her uh how about
Bishop Rob
held thank you Mr chair and thank you
for the members of this important
committee um I'm Bishop Rob herfeld I'm
the bishop of the Episcopal churches in
New
Hampshire my job is to travel all over
the place in New Hampshire and I
visit uh roughly 50 churches from C
Brook to Salem Kean to Portsmith North
Conway everything in between and I see a
lot of kids I'm also on the board of a
couple of a couple Independent Schools
that were founded by the Episcopal
church and I can speak to although I
wasn't planning to about that wide
obscene opportunity Gap um but that
wasn't why I came I just it was
mentioned I I wish to speak against this
bill and I'm not going to ascribe intent
I want to honor the pure intent of the
sponsor but I wish to begin with a short
but luminous
list Allan
Shephard Jonathan
Daniels Justice David sudor
and our current governor Kelly aot are
just few of the exemplary contributors
to our world they are explorers civil
suit civil servants jurists thinkers
each products of the public school
system in New
Hampshire and it was a system that was
committed to their intellectual and
personal growth and
development the value of which has
accured not only to New Hampshire but to
the
world I suspect that the schools that
they attended nasua
conquered
um
Keen included Math Science History
social science Latin Spanish French
already I'm curious
if this bill essentially says adequacy
we haven't done adequacy let's admit our
failure let's surrender and claim
victory that doesn't work in foreign
policy it shouldn't work with our kids
thank you thank you very
much uh Lisa
Gibson followed by Robert
Lawless hi my name is Lisa Gibson and um
I'm from Rochester New Hampshire sure I
moved here from Tampa Florida and I can
say that kind of from experience raising
a child in the school system in Florida
that cutting funding or diverting it to
different locations and taking away Arts
education is ridiculous for one many
many reasons but the other thing I have
to say is I'm the operations manager for
Rochester performance and arts center
and I see a plethora of students that
need art they need language they need
need a connection to learning and we
don't say come do art and play in the
theater and don't ever read a book don't
do math um our systems our sound systems
our St set design stage design lighting
all require math reading science all of
those things are necessary things the
other thing I'll say is the Arts
industry in New Hampshire sorry I'm
blind um 96 million dollars to the
economy in just New Hampshire the Arts
industry
um three million of person or three
million in tax dollars to the New
Hampshire government because of the Arts
and that's not just Performing Arts but
that's Visual Arts that's Arts across
the board um and another thing is I I
have two children or I four children two
of them are severe special needs and our
problem is not what we're
teaching in schools our problem is
teaching to standardize testing my
children continue to be pressed forward
to the next grade level even though they
don't have the building blocks to move
on that has nothing to do with history
or art or robotics or engineering that
has to do with teaching to testing
teachers are pulling their hair out to
see eye to eye with these children and
find a way to spark interest so they
they'll pick up that book so they'll do
that math Pro math problem but they're
not going to do it if you take every bit
of joy and light out of their school day
that's all I have to say thank you oh
thank you very much representative selig
thank you and I just I didn't quite hear
the name of the organization that you
work for and so I was hoping you could
say it a little more slowly sure I work
for Rochester opera house but I am the
operations manager for Rochester
performance and arts center which is our
education piece which we offer that educ
also to homeschoolers and all of that
stuff but the children that come from
our elementary schoolers schools and our
high schools and middle schools are
learning they're doing math they're
doing visual art as well as performance
art we don't we we don't tend to
minimize those subjects but we are
allowing children to find something that
will spark in them so they will pick up
those books thank you thank
you Robert Lawless followed followed by
James
Meyer good afternoon thank you members
of the committee for hearing Our
Testimony um a number of the speakers
have spoken much more eloquently than I
can about the specifics uh so I think
I'll just stick with the fact that uh
I'm probably representing a lot of other
folks in expressing outrage that we even
have to be here to oppose this bill it's
ridiculous um that we're here trying to
keep things all of the things listed
here uh in our schools uh my parents
were both uh uh teachers my dad ended
his career uh as a principal down in
Massachusetts and I spent a lot of time
talking about education um while I was
being educated I have a master's degree
uh I'm a US Army um active duty veteran
and my education was probably the thing
that uh I can point to
and the diversity of that education in
being successful
um I
think a number of folks have already
spoken about the way we fund things here
instead of having to defend common sense
um against ideas like this maybe the
representatives should think about
publicly about about how they're funding
public schools and talk with their other
representatives and actually do some
work that means something this is
ridiculous I have nothing more to say
about it thank you thank
you Mr Meyer followed by Kathleen
Slover thank you chairman cordelli and
representatives I'm Jim Moyer a resident
of Epsom New Hampshire and I oppose HB
283 joining over 25,000 citizens who
submitted opposition on the website the
bill is sponsored by my epim
representative Dan Maguire but I don't
think it represents the sentiment my
neighbors last week in Epsom we had a
doozy of a town meeting where petition
was brought in front of us that would
take away the school board's Authority
and instead put in a cap on spending on
education by an overwhelming vote this
petition was rendered harmless by an
amendment of The
People two facts were made clear to me
from the discussion on this petition one
property taxes are too high and many
residents are burdened
and so much as the fear losing their
homes in that regard this
proposal uh by uh representative Maguire
is responding to a real and great
concern but the second even more
overwhelming fact is that Epson
residents are strong supporters of the
local public schools some parents were
brought to tears as they gave testimony
because they felt that our commitment to
education was faltering and it was
potentially going to leave children
especially children with special
educational needs without
support other citizens who do not have
students in the schools Express strong
support for public education for various
reasons they want topnotch public school
education and they want you their
representatives to support the public
schools HB 283 is the antithesis of
support for public
education it's astonishing that someone
with a PhD and computer science from MIT
would Advance the bill eliminating
computer science engineering and
Technology as necessary Ed if we could
keep personalities out of this
please Fair okay uh to repeat I don't
think we should eliminate computer
science engineering and Technology as
necessary elements of public education
does anyone here really believe that
that would be beneficial would Christy
mlli
agree that we should have taken that out
of the her education I don't think so if
you could wrap up please yeah I'm going
to wrap it up thank you the word
adequate in the title of the bill
explains why HB 283 is before you the
court rulings oblig the state to pay for
an adequate education thus from a narrow
view any withering of the scope of
adequate education May save some money
but that's not the call from epom
residents they want Superior education
not minimally adequate education and
they need you to consider alternative
means to fund that that it goes beyond
regressive property taxes thank you
thank you and again I'll repeat if you
have written testimony when you finish
please bring it up and you don't have to
read your entire testimony so next I'll
call on Kathleen Slover followed by uh
Trisha Rose Bert
Masterson um thank you hi my name is
Kathleen Slover I'm from Portsmith New
Hampshire I have two boys that graduated
from uh Portsmouth High School my
youngest is a well-rounded good student
and uh when he was about a sophomore he
said you know I could be an engineer I
could be this or that but he decided to
go on uh focus on History English
polyscience Civics and he wanted to go
to Boston University Boston University
has a 10% acceptance rate you're on the
world stage competing with everyone
across the world it was a stretch
school I'm proud to say he's a freshman
uh at Boston University at the Global
Studies program there Arts World
Language computer science and a robust
diverse history program not only make
our students more competitive it makes
our communities more competitive schools
both public and private across the
country celebrate and tout these classes
and programs to draw families and
students to their school communities and
I am too very
outraged that I have to point that out I
want every kid in New Hampshire to have
the opportunities that my boys have so
please uh oppose HB
283 thank you very
much Trisha yes thank you so much
followed by uh tandi
mcgan yes my name is Trisha Rose Bert
I'm in from hancok new Hampshire I'm an
artist and a creativity and story coach
to businesses Across the Nation I
haven't ever had a child in the New
Hampshire Public School System but the
Arts uh changed my life and is very
important to me um about three decades
ago I was working as a consultant for
Harvard Business School and Fidelity
Investments and I was good at my job but
I wasn't really enjoying it so I started
figuring out what else I could do for a
living and I ended up in art school
which was a surprise because I live was
raised with a family that really focused
on hard skills like logic and math as
opposed to the softer skills like
creativity um and when I started going
to Art School while I was Consulting I
became a much better consultant because
I was learning how to think creatively
and making art and practicing art uh
really awakened my imagination and my
ability to problem solve so what I do
now I get hired by businesses because I
am an artist and they asked me to come
into their organizations to help their
their employees think more creatively um
and engage their creative sides in fact
I was just hired by the National Council
of state legislators to help their
support staff um with their creativity
so I think we have a choice uh we can
eliminate Arts programs um maybe save
some money and some Hassle and end up
hiring someone like me later on um or we
can invest in our students and in the
long term now so we can create uh
creative thinkers and problem solvers uh
creativity is something that is a musle
that needs to be flexed early and often
and and it can help our students become
better citizens and navigate their own
lives personally and professionally uh
art and creativity are not frivolous
Pursuits um it's a essential to the
bottom line actually of every industry
entrepreneurship uh and leader in our
state so I urge you to oppose this Bill
thank you thank you very
much uh tandi
Macwan if she's not here we'll move on
to Max
Godard followed by Katie
Andrews good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Max Goddard I am a
New Hampshire citizen um I grew up in
marac New Hampshire um and received an
extremely well-rounded education there
um I wish I could go on and on about the
various teachers I had and how
exceptional they were but they're not
public figure so I won't name them here
today except for one of my uh former
world history teacher is now one of your
colleagues uh New Hampshire State Rep
Peter patrino um and I will just say
that he had an extreme impact on me um
and many other New Hampshire citizens um
and enabled us to see the world from a
connected perspective
um I've been trying to understand how
the prime SP responser of this bill um
could justify reducing the requirements
of inadequate education in Hampshire um
again let's please leave personalities
out of this and stick to the uh Bill
itself I was trying to find why anyone
could justify such a bill in this before
this committee um but today um I had the
pleasure of uh hearing the prime
sponsor's specific testimony to justify
the lowering of the adequate education
requirements in New Hampshire um and his
primary uh reasoning seems to be that he
views education as a zero sum game if we
we're interested in your position
I do not believe that education is a
zero sum game teaching of one subject
does not reduce the teaching of another
subject if someone is studying civics
government or history are they reducing
the education of English a subject that
uses writing reading and comprehension
something that would be performed in all
the subjects civics government in
history would it be reducing a
mathematics education to teach personal
finance literacy computer science and
technology subjects that certainly use
it thank you any
questions next is uh Katie Andrews
followed by Cynthia
McClary good afternoon thank you for
having me I honestly didn't prepare
anything I was in preparing to speak to
you today um but as a mother of a
seventh grader in sand down I don't see
how I cannot um the people before me
have done a fantastic job of showing how
insane this bill actually is but I think
it would be helpful for you to know that
the reason my husband and I purchased
our home in Sandown and have paid over
$10,000 a year in property taxes was for
our elementary school we chose to live
there for our elementary school our
daughter got an amazing education we are
very grateful
looking at this bill she's an honors
Orchestra student she's a 504 student
what you are contemplating cutting from
this education
system makes us go our neighboring
states have quality education and
similar property taxes I don't see why
we would stay in New Hampshire if you
pass this bill I also have a question
for the sponsor I'm a little perplexed
is to how you
chose these courses to cut um why is
physical education more important than
arts or music why is personal finance or
economics not important when math is
important and it overlaps so much I I
don't understand and would love to get
some more clarification as to how these
were arbitrarily
chosen thank
you thank you very
much Cynthia McClary
not seeing her Janet
Ward good afternoon my name is Janet
Ward I live in Hopkinton New
Hampshire I am here because I am
appalled by House Bill 283 proposed by
representative Dan
Maguire how is it possible that
representative Maguire could propose a
bill in the year
2025 which would remove from core
knowledge domains World languages
engineering computer science digital
literacy Civics and government economics
and Holocaust and genocide
education has representative Maguire not
noticed that thanks to tremendous
advances in communication and
transportation technology all of us
humans inhabit a small planet where what
happens in one nation rapidly affects
all other nations among many of its
potentially damaging effects this bill
would limit the ability of our young
people to converse and communicate with
citizens of other nations and to develop
an understanding of the different ways
human governments evolve in 2025
studying C Civics is more crucial than
ever through the study of civics young
people come to understand and appreciate
the amazing possibilities of democracy
as well as the threats to our democracy
that are right now at this moment in
play the sponsor of this bill could
argue that he is only interested in
saving taxpayers money let us be honest
if that were truly the case this
committee could save taxpayers money and
protect our public schools by ensuring
that public tax dollars pay for our
public schools and are not siphoned off
via School vouchers which Escape public
oversight if we could stick to this bill
voucher dollars represent taxation
without representation excuse me if we
could stick to this bill please happily
sir but I do think what I've just said
is connected I ask each of you to
protect our democracy by voting against
House Bill 283 thank you for letting me
share my deep concerns with you thank
you Sarah mcneel is next followed by
Deborah hows
representative cordal and committee
members uh my name is Sarah mcneel and I
have lived in Warner for almost 50 years
my children have gone to the public
school system I am in strong opposition
of House Bill 283 this bill sponsored by
just one representative attempts to
remove lengthy list of educational
subjects while still maintaining that
this will provide an adequate Ed
education for our students I'll limit my
testimony to 3 points one under social
studies representative McGuire wishes to
remove Civics economics geography
history and Holocaust and genocide
education if that is done what exactly
will be taught in these Social Studies
classes what's left the National Council
for the social studies is the largest
professional association in the country
devoted solely to social studies
education with members in all 50 states
and 35 countries they Define social
studies as a study of individuals
communities systems and their
interactions uh across time and place
that prepare students for local National
and Global Civic life don't we really
want to have our students uh especially
in today's world participate in that
second point is that on August 4th
2023 Governor sonunu signed into law
Senate Bill
216 requiring Civics education to be
taught in all public and private schools
from grade school through 12th grade
this bipartisan bill was sponsored by 16
Senators this uh are we going to undo
this law that is just beginning to be
implemented in our
schools finally of all the subjects on
this list one should not discount the
one entitled personal finance
literacy imagine if all all our students
who graduate from high school got at
least a passing grade in
this thank you very much I do have uh
copies but I also have a copy of I
belong to League of Women Voters and
almost two years ago representative lad
and others spoke uh to our our
organization in addition I have about
the Civics Bill becoming law so if you
could leave that up front with one of
the committee members that would be
great thank you very much Deborah house
followed by Mike
appleberg okay is this good or I'm
getting an
echo good afternoon chairman Celli and
members of the education policy
committee I'm pleased to be addressing
you this afternoon uh my name is Deborah
house I am president of the American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire and
am here on behalf of my members and the
students we serve across the granite
state to oppose House Bill
283 uh we are in staunch opposition of
this bill which would cut many uh
subject areas from the list of classes
that are required or list of areas that
are required uh to make up an adequate
education every single Granite State
student has the constitutional right to
the opportunity of a robust public
education that's not a barebones
education that's an education that
prepares them for career for Workforce
for higher education for full
participation in Civic life beyond High
School
graduation this bill will not get our
students there and it is short changing
them if we adopt it by changing the list
of subjects that comprise an adequate
education it will eventually affect
funding because that is what our funding
formula is based on and if our state
does not fund it in many places our
local districts cannot continue to fund
it so it's fine to say well your local
schools can still offer these subjects
most of our local districts are so
strapped by our current unconstitutional
funding formula that they are struggling
to keep up with what they are currently
offering and in many places is you see
right now there are cutbacks on the
table it would continue to grow that Gap
we have from one District to another
between what is offered in a public
education and remember every single
child in the state has the right to that
same robust opportunity of a public
education so for the sake of all of our
grand estate children you really need to
find this an expedient to legislate and
I do have copies I'll bring them down
thank you U Mike um followed by uh is
there someone named Dan just filled in
first name if you could when you get up
if you could tell us your last name also
for the
record y this
is good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Mike appleberg I'm
the president of the United Way of
Greater ashaa I'm here also to express
our strong opposition to HB
283 just going to make a couple of
additional points that haven't been made
made that this proposal it's not only
detrimental to the future of our
students but it also contradicts
long-established brain science regarding
how children learn and develop I'd like
to give you just a couple of examples
Decades of research in neuroscience and
education have shown a diverse and
well-rounded curriculum as essential for
cognitive development as regards the
specific elements that have been
addressed in this bill arts and
education Arts education and in in and
Innovation research from John Hopkins
University and the Dana Harbor
Foundation have shown that music and
visual arts strengthen neural
connections related to memory problem
solving and emotional regulation these
skills are necessary for leadership in
technology business and the Sciences
World languages and Global engagement
the American Academy of Neurology has
found that bilingual individuals have
stronger executive functioning and
multitasking skills engineering
technology and Workforce Readiness um in
other words stem the National Science
Foundation has shown that early exposure
to stem
significantly enhances students
abilities to tackle complex problem
solving and
innovation personal finance and literacy
the Journal of economic behavior e and
organization has found that students
with financial literacy and education
demonstrate improved long-term Financial
stability and lastly computer science
and technology mit's brain and cognitive
Sciences
Department which I'm certain that the
representative is well aware of
has shown that learning computational
thinking enhances students ability to
break down complex problems and approach
them methodically hb2 83 not only
contradicts the science of how young
minds develop but it also weakens our
Global competitive competitive
competitiveness for these and many other
reasons I urge you to vote HB 283
inexpedient to legislate and I do have
copies of my testimony great thank you
very much if you can bring them
forward U Mike excuse me Dan uh my name
is Daniel kraky um I'm a father of two
young children from marac New Hampshire
um Daniel crackie K r a c ke uh house
build 283 is a shameful gutting of the
academic experience every single public
school student in the state of New
Hampshire uh
deserves representative mcquire did not
provide one solid statistic to prove his
point I am the product of a well-rounded
public education and it has allowed me
to be a critical thinker in this world
it's important now more than ever that
we're able to think independently and
analyze and use our brains to figure out
what is truth and what is
lie
um it's I was informed about this by a
friend on Thursday last week and I was
honestly infuriated I have two young
kids who have Bright Futures and I want
them to be given all of the
opportunities that I was given as a
child uh by taking these subjects out of
the
curriculum you're dumbing down New
Hampshire and our CH our kids
and it's hurtful and things like this
will push hardworking people who want to
raise smart independent strong kids out
of this state and lower all of the
standards here I came to this state
for a better life and to raise my family
and if things like this happen this is
not the place for me to raise my family
at all thank you thank you very much uh
Chris
jocks okay not seen her Heather
Gilligan followed by Sylvie Stewart
good
afternoon my name is Heather Gilligan
I'm a faculty member in the music
department at Keen State College I'm
here to strongly oppose HB 283 our
children deserve a well-rounded
education I have professional training
in both the Arts and the sciences and
I'd like to talk about the importance of
Arts in education people think
creativity is associated with the Arts
and while this is true it would be wrong
to assume that creativity somehow belong
bels to the Arts as a former chemist my
work in the lab required creativity my
electrician is one of the most creative
people I know from marketing Specialists
to dentists and doctors creativity is a
critical component of
success as a faculty member at Keen
State we talk a lot about Job Readiness
the ability to apply one's skills to the
job market to be a productive member of
society the best way we can prepare our
students for success in the New
Hampshire Job Market is to teach them to
think
creatively the Arts are also a vehicle
for important life skills students who
study music and other forms of art have
better iand coordination they are more
collaborative they learn important
communication skills they have better
organizational skills they feel more at
ease with self-directed projects they
learn to be fluent with various
Technologies they are not afraid to take
risks the Arts teach discipline and work
ethic in other words our school C culum
benefits from the Arts in many
immeasurable ways this is not about
teaching our kids a form of
entertainment after all the ma the vast
majority of our students who study the
Arts in the K through2 system will not
go on to become professional musicians
or painters or actors this is about
building a school curriculum that will
set our kids on a path to success in any
field they choose what kind of education
will position our children for the best
chance of success after they finish
their schooling it is the very subjects
this bill proposes to eliminate please I
implore you to deem this legislation
inexpedient to legislate give our youth
an opportunity to thrive to learn
creative problem solving in order to
become successful adults HB 283 is not
the answer thank you very much uh sopie
Stewart and followed by gwend gwendaline
leari good after afternoon and thank you
Mr chairman and members of the committee
my name is Sylvia Stewart I live in
nashaa I was a music teacher in the
nashwa school district for 16 years and
I'm now an assistant at the Hollis
montauri school I am here to very much
oppose HB 283 I have four main points
the first thing is I think that this is
a very disrespectful bill I think
teachers did not go to six or four plus
six years for a back bachor and a
master's degree to teach to ATT test to
teach only limited subjects in the
schools they love children they're
passionate about what they do they're
creative about what they do and I find
it a disrespectful bill for that reason
students don't want to be dumbed down
parents want a quality education I think
these things go without
speaking um I also feel this bill is
ignorant of educational theory pedagogy
psychology curriculum design cognitive
function and brain development as Dr
Howard Gardner of Harvard University
said we have multiple intelligence
intelligences spatial
artistic um cooking
musical uh help me here there were about
eight of them much more than just the
disciplines of math reading and writing
and therefore you need to appeal to all
those intelligence
by including all these subject areas
when you
teach um I really much think that
education is
interdisciplinary no one can argue that
math has nothing to do with any of the
other subjects no one can argue that
science doesn't have something to do
with history that music doesn't have
something to do with math as other
people have said the brain doesn't learn
math in one section and English in
another section and writing everything
is connected we're also connected as a
world we cannot have an ethnocentric
education and we can't have a Department
of Education that no longer exists
serving as a model for our state to no
longer have an education department
thank you very much thank you very much
for your
testimony gindin followed by Michelle
Bickford
good afternoon chair good afternoon all
the representatives that are here thank
you um my name is gwendaline laari and
I'm here because I do care very much and
I do oppose
um I do oppose this Bill H from
happening and reason being I grew up in
the 60s in New Hampshire I Didn't Have
Art and I didn't have a lot of the
classes that would have helped me more
um luckily my second grade teacher
played piano so we got to sing but um at
the Mary Foss School in Salem tiny tiny
but growing up here I always felt like
something was missing in my life and it
was being an artist I had art class at
15 at Salem High School but didn't have
what it took to get into a school after
I couldn't get into certain colleges or
even Artmy because I didn't have enough
art under my belt
um and I was upset by that and my skills
could have been better if I started
right from the beginning and learning
more I didn't get that so all the more
reason I fought hard I became a graphic
designer I went to a three-year Art
School the one that let me in in Boston
and I did do well from there I moved to
California and I did commercial artwork
for a while then I had children and I
decided I loved teaching them and
teaching art they didn't have art in
their classes and California 40 kids per
a first grade classroom my daughter
still wasn't reading and this is very
personal so it's my own story when we
ended up moving back to New Hampshire
where my kids have never been but um and
with a my husband and and two kids they
got to go to London Derry school system
and I was beaming at the changes that I
saw in my children's education from
being here number one less CL less
people in a class my daughter who was um
still in first grade still couldn't read
she learned to read in two months being
here they integrated storytelling and
drawing that embellished that for her so
I'm so proud of being a member I was
raised in New Hampshire I'm prouder to
be a part of New Hampshire now and I got
to be an educator at the school district
in Jerry and I can't tell you enough how
much it meant to me to see my my
students do better and flourish so thank
you for listening and I know time is
short so thank you thank you very
much uh Michelle
Bickford good afternoon my name is
Michelle Bickford and I live in
hopkington New Hampshire and I'm also a
sixth grade teacher of social studies
and writing but my passion is teaching
Civics I moved here about 28 years
ago um from from the state of Florida
and I was immediately impressed by the
state of New Hampshire and its Common
Sense politics where people could
contribute to society and make positive
change my teacher colleagues and I work
tirelessly to educate our children I've
taught all of those core subjects that
we were talking about but I firmly
believe that art and music and World
Language geography civics history
computer science personal science
technology and economics are critical to
a quality education and competing in the
world Beyond New
Hampshire our students deserve this
bills like HB 283 only disrupt our work
and I'm very much opposed to it um only
a couple of years ago
um my hopk students and I were invited
to the New Hampshire state supreme court
we presented on the topic of learning
about
Civics my students let the group know
how they felt it prepared them for the
future and that they learned that one
day they may be called to serve on a
jury and perform have the honor to
participate and perform that civic
duty they learn how bills become laws
and how to testify in front of
committees for bills being presented my
students learn about our state and
federal election process where New
Hampshire has a very rich
history at the State of New Hampshire
Supreme Court many government officials
shook my hand and the hands of my
students that day thanking us for
bringing Civics into the
classroom I want to just thank you very
much for hearing my testimony today and
please vote against HB 283 thank you
thank you very much uh representative
Damon
followed by Leslie
Woodard thank you Mr chair could I ask
you to recognize a person who needs to
leave shortly to speak before me is that
permissible I'm sorry would could you
could repeat that I'm asking if you
could recognize a person who needs to
leave shortly to speak before
me okay her name is
Gian thank you very much
hi my name is GI jel I'm a a me uh a
citizen of Madbury New Hampshire I'm
also on the school board for oyer River
Cooperative School District I'm not
speaking on behalf of the entire board
today I'm speaking of myself um I'm on
the finance committee there as well as
sustainability and uh there's a lot of
things here that a lot of people have
discussed and mentioned in a much more
eloquent way than I can do today and I'm
very grateful for all the speakers who
came up here and spoke so well about
their personal experiences as Educators
and parents and the importance of having
this bill be defeated hopefully be in
expedient to
legislate I'm speaking today because
there's a couple things one is I want to
make sure that my voice was heard and I
want to emphasize that the people who
registered in opposition to this bill
and even the ones who registered in
favor of this bill online are equal in
testimony to what I'm saying today I
don't think we should be able to ignore
the people who are not able to be
present the second thing is is that when
I'm talking about the school district
that I'm in one of the things that's the
strength of our district is that there's
a whole bunch of electives that the
students can take people actually come
to the district for that this bill is
actually going to be eliminating a lot
of those electives which means they
won't have the diversity of classes of
why they actually moved to the schools
district to the in the first place the
second part is is that we don't know
what the future looks like if you're
limiting everything into little boxes
you're limitating people's and
children's ability to adapt to the
Future the exact skills that you need
change what we actually really need is
the ability to learn and having an
expansive set of classes so we can do
that is pivotal we need people in
students in the future who are adaptable
who are resilient who can be independent
thinkers capable of critical analysis
effective communication problem solving
this bill cuts into all of those things
because education doesn't exist in a
silo when you're learning something it
crosses all those classes other people
have spoken to this exact thing where
math math doesn't just exist in a math
class math exists in art class it
definitely exists in engineering class
it exists in all those other places
another thing I'd like to add just is
saying with a Schoolboard member is that
a lot of these things actually under
company based education cross classes
and
credits so just one second so the thing
is is what this bill actually is doing
is attacking the funding on it so I want
to say that one of the person spoke to
this much better than I did here since
I'm out of time but the people who are
sitting here and the people who have
commented online are not fooled by the
intent of this bill this bill is to
attack adequacy funding and make it so
public education is under attack and
make it so it's underfunded that is the
purpose of this
bill so please in this be to legislate
thank you could could I just double
check your your last name so I make sure
I have the right card yeah jela g LS y
yes thank you very much representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
commmentating the previous speaker good
afternoon committee
for the record I'm State Rep hope Damon
representing the nine communities of
Sullivan District 8 which includes five
school districts all with significant
participation in the free and reduced
School meals program as many know a
marker of low socioeconomic status I
live in and represent the small town of
cin in 2022 our school budget was cut
53% following a floor motion by a free
stator the vote was 20 to 14 if that had
been the final outcome our school would
have closed
this bill though promoted by the sponsor
as increasing local control is actually
fully aligned with the Free State agenda
reduce course requirements to minimal so
the state can provide even less funding
than it already inadequately does which
will certainly reduce education quality
and outcomes and then the free sters can
further dismantle Public Schools until
eventually none exist in New
Hampshire after a 7 we Grassroots
campaign cyon restored our school budget
in a landslide
377-2 vote there's only 600 voters in
our town similarly the 29,000 opponents
to this bill online and have you noticed
that 100% of the people testifying in
person today oppose HB 283 should tell
the house to defeat this egregious Bill
and finally it alerts all of us to vet
who you elect to represent
free Staters do not support public
education where 87% of New Hampshire
kada 12 students learn thank you thank
you Leslie Woodard followed by uh Bruce
Burke yes good afternoon members of the
education policy and administration
committee my name is lesie Woodard from
and I'm from
Londoner I'm a retired music teacher
from there and my husband and I moved
there with my
daughter because of the education she
would receive there especially the Arts
education I oppose this bill for many
reasons by removing so many subjects
important to a full and happy life this
bill excuse me will make learning a
drudgery for students and much more
difficult for many students as students
learn in many different ways it will
also be a disaster for their future
lives leaving them with many fewer
career paths and giving them virtually
no education about the world or how it
works this will also be a disaster for
our country and our world in the long
run I am here in part because I have 10
grandchildren four of whom attend school
here in New Hampshire
I do not want to see them relegated to
this below subpar
education the Arts help a child to learn
about themselves in the world as well as
their place in
it Studies have proven that students do
better in academic classes when they're
involved in playing a music
instrument also the Arts bring people
together which I have seen over and over
again as a certified music practitioner
I also know the Arts are healing I've
personally experienced this healing and
watched it happen over and over again as
well the Arts tie all other subjects
together it is definitely a big part of
an adequate education I respectfully
asked what could possibly make anyone
think that social studies are not part
of an adequate
education and without
those that's two minutes already
I just wanted to say that
[Music]
um with other languages when I worked at
Nike years ago one of my bosses could
speak eight languages they sent her all
over the world being able to speak so
many languages opened up not only the
world of work to her but the world
itself we cannot take that away from our
children
um please I feel the same yes about the
others and I just wanted to say
um I appreciate you're listening to my
testimony and I hope all will oppose
this egregious bill that would dumb down
our children's education thank you so
much for listening thank you is Bruce
Burke
here followed by Dave M I have to say a
couple things in uh I've listened
carefully so I'm going to eliminate most
of my comments thank you for being the
most underpaid Professionals in the
State uh I would just give one more fact
because you've gotten so many facts
today
uh
China graduates more Engineers I'm
thinking about the previous Bill China
graduates more Engineers each year than
the total number of college gradu ues in
the United States each
year so as you think about this previous
Bill uh we need to do more I'm just
going to give my uh submit my testimony
there are some specifics here on the
Holocaust why I think it's important
particularly in our society today and
also the reference earlier to
Gardener uh eight theories of education
so you've listened long you're just
looking for more evidence I'll submit my
comments thank you thank you
is Dave mad
here Cen
n Zach
Sheen cannot see him either how about
yesd um do you want to hand in his
testimony
I'd rather not have you read uh written
testimony we can just pass it out to the
committee thank
you um Randy
Britain followed by Kristen
bbau Mr chairman members of the
committee hi my name is Randy Brittain
I'm from Grantham I'm actually the
technology director at Grantham Village
School I've been there for 10 years I'm
a retired Navy public affairs officer uh
the reason I'm here is to stand in
opposition of uh HB 283 specifically I'm
going to address the computer science
and digital literacy item that's been
cut uh one of the things that we've
talked about at Grandam Village School
quite a bit is this notion of digital
citizenship okay it's an extension of
three things that we talk about every
day at the school which is to be safe
respectful and responsible and we extend
that to being good digital Citizens
online also being safe respectful
responsible online that um education
that we're providing to these kids is
crucial for them understanding what
their place in the digital world is and
what responsibilities they have when
they're executing their lives in a in
the digital world uh I've been to many
of the Christa mcff conferences that
they have in Manchester one of the
speakers several years years ago was a
young lady probably about 14 or so who
talked about uh how her Digital Life was
not a separate entity it was her it was
part of who she was and this is in fact
the way that our children these days are
living I have a a senior in high school
a daughter who's a sophomore at UVM
and their Digital Life is their life the
notion that you would somehow strike
digital literacy as one of the core
components of an adequate education is
just abhorent to me to understand that
you know you're not going to have that
be one of the core skills that children
in the state of New Hampshire are going
to have as a critical component of their
education is just baffling to to
me um the previous bill that was being
discussed in here was talked about as
stem a lot of times people talk about it
as Steam and I'll wrap up Mr chairman
just a minute the a in Steam is for Arts
that includes things like being creative
when you're writing code for example
it's not just a matter of the technology
it's it's incorporating creativity into
that too so I would just reiterate that
I oppose HP 283 um and reiterate too I
think education is not a zero sum game
all of these things that are in here are
critical to the entire education of a
whole person for a citizen in New
Hampshire thank you thank you
Kristen bbau followed by Robert Moore is
it possible for a gentleman to go ahead
he must pick up his child after school
okay mine will be quick
too
what's what's the name the name is Paul
bunker thank you very much for hearing
me I am a technology professional a
musician and have been an educator and
I'm I am a citizen of Epsom and I was
involved in the school board meeting
that was discussed earlier as my fellow
towns person has pointed out the
consensus was not in support of the
ideology behind this
bill I think that it's important for us
to remember that we we have children
saying the Pledge of Allegiance every
day and instead of rehashing my
opposition which I've already registered
for the board to remember that if we
don't teach
how do they understand what they're
pledging allegiance to and what they
should be proud of and if we're not
teaching them about the things that have
happened in the past or how to prepare
for the future in a technologically
Centric world how can we expect our
society to continue to move
forward I had my son ask me one day what
a Buffalo Soldier was which eventually
led to a discussion about the
Emancipation Proclamation in the Civil
War this was when he was four years old
and these are subjects that
children need to understand and if we're
not going to teach Civics and I
understand that it isn't to not teach
these subjects but coming from an area
where we won't have the funds and we
have a vote on the 11th to raise taxes
$289 on every
th000 which even before I had kids I was
happy to pay the tax increase because I
understand that a well-informed populace
is the most important part of our
society and if we're not going to teach
them these things how will they
understand it and how will we move
forward thank you thank you very
much uh perhaps state representative Dan
McGuire means well but I'm opposed to
this bill dumbing up education takes
even more power away from education it
sends a message that education is not
that important and I believe that's the
Crux of the matter students are seeing
aren't seeing the buyin
learning we have the power to create to
contribute it starts while they're young
not when we're older that's the way our
brains
work it's powerful it creates buyin but
I'm not an art teacher or engineering
teacher I was a social studies teacher
social sciences and history and I know
we know that quote those that have
forgotten their history are condemned to
repeat it
the Holocaust cannot be forgotten even
now we are dealing with something
similar power to control the populace
through media news further this bill
requires only eight credits to graduate
that's heading for the need of no high
school if they don't have to offer it
they won't it's true too many school
districts are struggling and could see
this as a way to keep taxes from
climbing you see we must look ahead at
what new legislation could pave the way
for America's struggling at is is kids
need to create invent they need that
type of buyin students want to be
empowered yes there is an issue but
dumbing down ex education will only
exerp the issue thank
you thank you very much Robert Moore
here followed by Mark
Hampton thank you Mr Sher person
chairman and also members of the
committee uh honored to be here and also
um I applaud your your patience and your
list your listening skills amazing what
you're doing uh I'm Bob Moore I'm from
East Kingston which is in the Sea Coast
of New Hampshire as a retired New
Hampshire public high school science
teacher for 23 years I have witnessed
firsthand the value of an education that
includes World languages art and music
and a social studies curricul ulum that
teaches a historical account of racial
oppression and the Holocaust in Nazi
Germany these events and histories and
art Expressions that tap into personal
struggles and social struggles are of
Paramount
importance to dismiss our full historic
record is to pave the way for as
mentioned earlier for a repeat of
history with no lessons
learned I am in favor of a complete
education including past histories that
celebrate our democracy as well as
educate the mistakes we've made and
learned from
these also the importance of learning
the Democratic process through a civics
class through civic
education um instructs a student to
become an informed voter how else will a
student be prepared to engage in a
democracy when it's time for them to
vote
this is why I'm opposed to House Bill
283 thanks for your time thank you very
much is Mark Hampton
here followed by Megan
Tuttle thank you Mr chairman and
committee members I congratulate you on
your endurance and your patience I will
be brief uh my name is Mark Hampton uh I
live in the town of canterburry my wife
and I have been in New Hampshire since
1970 after a stint in Bolivia in the
Peace
Corps I speak in oppos in opposition to
this bill from the vantage point of a
foreign language educator I taught
Spanish and French for many years in the
conquered School District after which I
was the entire Spanish department at
Colby Sawyer college for a few more
years I'm 8 82 years old so over the
years I've seen and discussed many
curriculum changes in our
schools when I first read about HB 283 I
would I was reminded of the question
what do you call someone who speaks
three
languages the answer of course
is
trilingual and what do you call someone
who speaks two
languages
bilingual how about what do you call
someone who speaks one
language an
American you cannot separate from La uh
excuse me separate language from culture
so learning languages opens our eyes to
the world around us we will be depending
upon today's young people to navigate an
increasingly more complex World studying
foreign languages and cultures
understanding and assessing new
technologies and being grounded in
Civics to name a few are essential so
please consider what passing this bill
might mean for your children and
grandchildren thank
you thank you very
much is Megan Title
Here uh hi Mr chairman uh Brian Hawkins
from Nea New Hampshire Megan had to
leave I will hand in her written
testimony uh but I'll just make a couple
of very quick points uh that she raises
in there do you have a card
um I don't have my card in that Megan
has a card in
though I'll be brief I give you one
minute okay uh I would just urge you to
listen to all the Educators who came
here today um and the retired
Educators uh th uh and from all the
stories that we had sent into us um when
this bill was published I think the
theme that we heard from a lot of them
was the all of the confidence some of
the intangibles that people have talked
about that all of these content areas
provided their students today provided
them when they were in
school those were the things that
enabled them to go on and become
teachers themselves um and so I would
just I'll hand in the testimony but I
would just urge you to listen to all the
um dedicated professionals who came here
today the retired ones who um told you
the stories about their students um and
their lives so thank you very much Mr
chairman please vote against this bill
is ala jblanco
here followed by Jane
Windor good afternoon chair um members
of this committee I'm honored to be here
and to speak in front of you my name is
alvilda jblanco and I'm a resident of
keen
my father lost all of his immediate
family in the Holocaust he came to the
United States as a student a refugee
went to Har um
MIT where he graduated with a degree in
electrical
engineering I was very very happy when
New Hampshire became one of the states
to add a holocaust and genocide curric
um element to its curriculum I think
that it's egregious to remove that from
its curriculum now and that's just one
part
of the social studies um curriculum
which will be gushed to the point of
being unrecognizable I don't know what
it's going to contain if it doesn't
contain history Civics geography what
what does it
have
um I'm not going to repeat what
everybody else said because everybody
has said it better than I I'm not an
educator but the idea that there is it's
a completely false dichotomy to choose
English and math over music and computer
science it seems self-evident I'm not
going to belabor the point when my
father was at MIT studying electrical
engineering he spent most of his time in
the music library listening to music and
learning about music these two things
for him were inseparable and I think
that as everybody has said here today it
is fundamental to an education to
include all of these subjects so as a
resident of keen and citizen of New
Hampshire I urge you to vote no on this
Bill thank you very much Jane Windsor
followed by Janet
briter hi I am Jane Windsor I'm a
retired public school teacher and I live
in New Market I'm here today to oppose
HB 283 which would remove high priority
subjects from the definition of an
adequate education in the 21st century
most of what I had has already been
expressed beautifully so I'll be
submitting a hard copy however I do want
to speak personally at this time because
this part hits me I am the child of
Jewish parents whose family was deeply
impacted by the Holocaust in all the
horrific ways that you can imagine the
removal of civics history the Holocaust
and genocide education is not just a gap
of in knowledge it is
dangerous understanding the horrors of
the past is crucial in preventing hate
and extremism in the future our children
must learn to recognize
Injustice and stand up for what's right
we cannot afford to forget it's our
Collective responsibility to preserve
the memory of these atrocities the
consequences of this bill are not just
about cutting costs they are about
narrowing our students Futures as we
have heard education should ensure all
New Hampshire students regardless of
background have access to the skills and
knowledge they need to thrive cutting
the SI subjects will only deepen the
gaps between communities wealthier
districts will fill them others will
struggle worsening educational
inequality we cannot afford to weaken
our Public Schools especially when so
many families including some of your
constituents rely on free public schools
as their only educational option I urge
you to reject House Bill 283 thank you
for your time your patience and
consideration thank thank you very much
for being
here Janet briter
here Susan
Garcia Hannah
Weissman followed by Carmela Antonelli
chairman and members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
in strong opposition of HB 283
specifically the provision that removes
computer science and digital literacy
from the subjects that qualify as an
adequate education in New Hampshire my
name is Hannah Weissman and I'm the
senior director of policy at code.org a
national nonprofit dedicated to
expanding computer science for all
students in 2025 computer science is a
critical literacy just like math and
reading but it's actually not separate
from math and reading there have been
studies that have shown that when
students take computer science they do
better in math and reading and as you
can imagine as well math and reading are
involved in computer science classes
these are not just disperate
subjects computer science skills are
essential across all Industries um
including some key sectors in New
Hampshire such as advanced manufacturing
life sciences and technology and
regardless of students career path
computer science teaches students to
think creativity um solve problems um
which are valuable in any skill their
future a student may have removing
computer science from New Hampshire's
definition of an adequate education
would send a message that these skills
are optional and they are not New
Hampshire has actually been a leader in
computer science education in 2018 the
state took a forward forward thinking
step by adding computer science to this
list of subjects and this policy has
resulted in 95% of high schools in New
Hampshire offering computer science
which is one of the highest rates in the
country and this progress aligns with
national Trends now 33 states require
their schools to offer computer science
and digital literacy as well if HB 283
passes New Hampshire's progress and role
as a leader in this country is at risk
schools May de deprioritize computer
science leading to fewer courses and of
course fewer students taking them this
would be a backward step at a time when
other states are expanding access and
investing in their students Futures I
urge every member of the education
policy and administration committee to
support New Hampshire students and
econom and economy by rejecting the
removal of computer science from the
list of adequate subjects this is not
just an education policy decision but a
Workforce issue New Hampshire has to
ensure that students are prepared for
the modern world and I urge you not to
take a step backwards thank you thank
you very
much uh Carmela followed by marshan
mcaffrey
yes thank you for your time I really
appreciate coming and speaking to you
all today my name is Carmella antonellis
I'm from Key New Hampshire um I am here
today to express my full and
wholehearted opposition to HB 283 I
stand here before everyone as a daughter
of a teacher sister of a teacher both of
New Hampshire a New Hampshire taxpayer a
New Hampshire local a person who is a
musician a singer practicer of art
through metal smithing and an engineer I
was educated by the public school
systems of New Hampshire and I'm a
graduate at the University of New
Hampshire the introduction of this bill
and the contents within it are extremely
concerning and frankly
terrifying by cutting these subjects
you're leaving behind so many students
and please recognize that cutting these
requirements is a very slippery
slope if you do not invest in our
children and provide them with a diverse
and enriched education what type of
people will they grow up to
be how will they navigate an
everchanging world and be successful in
a chosen profession do you not want them
to be fully
educated how will the children of New
Hampshire grow up to be successful
adults in m MERS of society we if we do
not give them the essential tools to do
so I understand the concerns that were
brought when this this bill was proposed
although I Gravely disagree with the
bill but this is not the solution this
is not the way to correct maybe that the
the issues that we're seeing it points
to another issue put the funds towards
getting these resources towards getting
those Specialists that might be
needed um I want one last thing I wanted
to highlight is that I am employed as an
engineer in New Hampshire I work in
Auburn and when I applied for my first
engineering job they looked at the
subjects that I took other than math
other than
engineering they evaluated me as an
individual not as a test score even
though my GRE scores were
average I work for an international
company and knowing Spanish has been an
asset and an advantage to my career and
all of the courses that I took whether
they were creativity art related courses
or science and engineering those were
all looked at when I was looking to
become a
professional I I'll wrap up right here
um additionally these consulting firms
which are seeing a huge boom um in
growth are looking for creativity in
addition to technical Eng engineering
skills so I please encourage everyone to
really think deep and hard about this
before evaluating this bill and please
do not approve this as the majority of
constituents have stated they do not
support this Bill thank you very much is
Mara yes and uh Sheila Cunningham
following her
good afternoon my name is Marsha
mcaffrey I live in kukuk New Hampshire
for 23 years I worked as an education
consultant at the State Department of
Education I'd like to take a little bit
different tact on this and uh pursue
some uh policy reasons why I believe
this bill is inexpedient to
legislate on December 12th 2024 jel car
adopted revised Ed 306 minimum standards
for public school approval uh the
process that went public in May of 2023
and required an investment of State time
and money uh 8306 rules are uh what the
state uses to enact adequate
education this bill makes no sense in
the context of the newly adopted Ed 306
rules ed360 2 definitions begins with a
academic
standards it says ademic standards means
academic standards as defined in RSA 193
E2 D
a6b the changes presented in this bill
will significantly alter the
requirements for public school approval
and dilute what all students should know
and be able to do as a result of a
public education in our state these
proposed changes also mean that the
state will issue academic standards in
the six areas left unscathed by the bill
and it will remove any requirement for
the lined out areas of study this
proposed language is not at all what was
addressed and passed by gel car in
December it is unclear as to whether
this Back to Basics throwback bill has
any benefit to our students and
Educational Systems what is clear is
that this bill falls short in four
critical areas number one it undermines
our state department of education's core
commitment to personalized learning
number two it does not not consider the
flexibility schools currently have for
providing varied learning opportunities
for students to meet State expectations
for an adequate education number three
it does not consider the local control
Advantage afforded to our school
districts in meeting the state's
recently revised minimum standards and
number four it set severe limits on
public school education risking further
disparity between communities and among
our student Statewide for access to a
comprehensive and robust 21st century
education I've uh elucidated on those
four points in my written testimony I
handed in a copy at the table when I
came in thank you so continue to uh read
why I think this bill should be
inexpedient to legislate thank you
Sheila Cunningham
here not seeing her uh James
Goin followed by David
Trumble hi there uh I come to you as a
retired educator I taught here in New
Hampshire for
38 years and two years in New York state
I've taught language arts social studies
math Math and Science and one thing I
have found out from all of that is that
every one of those subjects contains
every one of the other subjects that
nothing is you know um isolated that
there's language arts and math there's
math in science and in language arts so
that students are getting these core
subjects in a lot of different ways that
we perhaps don't even
consider another thing I want to uh let
you know is that I mean if if one thing
I know about everybody in this room is
that we we were all young students at
one time and think about what you wanted
to be when you were a kid when I was an
elementary uh Elementary School student
I wanted to be a
fireman and then when I was in Middle
School Mr Pine the guidance counselor
asked me what do you want to be when you
grow up and I'm like a
doctor I didn't become a doctor but what
it did was it sent me on a on a course
in high school to take the upper echelon
classes the the harder classes now I'm
came from a very poor background so the
comments that I heard earlier about how
if you're from a lower economic um
status that yeah you're going to bring
things down no that actually pushed me
pushed me further and one thing I know
is that once I got to college I wanted
to become a Broadway a
director and then about halfway through
I changed and I thought what I want want
to do I liked English so I became an
English teacher I know that the English
teacher I became name is because of all
the arts classes and everything else
that took place in my education prior to
my becoming a teacher in fact one thing
I learned here because I taught in
conquered is that a motto of conquered
used to be that what you what what we
will be we are now becoming so what
students are eventually going to be is
dependent on all those classes they take
when they're younger including the arts
classes one last thing two things two of
the greatest lessons I ever learned came
from my High School chorus teacher Mr
Roberts one he taught me that the only
time you ever get sick is when you have
time to get sick cuz that was his
grandmother she never got sick a day in
her life because she didn't have time
and two that if you're going to do
something do it the absolute best that
you can and I I live those two things
every single day because of my chorus
teacher and yet I became a language arts
teacher thank you very much David
Trumble followed by Michael
betet thank you Mr chairman and
committee members it's been a lot of
test testimony I'm going to try and get
to a couple points first is this list of
11 subjects is not just a random list
that you can check check the ones you
want and get rid of the ones you don't
want it's a constitutionally based list
it's required you've heard people
mention the Constitution it says the
words Arts and Science and commerce and
trade then the Claremont decision came
along and then that decision the court
specifically said we have to train our
children for the social economic
scientific technological and political
realities of today's society they need a
grounding in the Arts they need cultural
and historical Heritage and they need
training in academic and Vocational
skills so they can compete favorably in
the job market then the London Dairy
case came along in 2007 because it was
the question or what is inadequate
education the court said you have to
tell us what it is legislature so the
Democrats and Republicans together with
the help from the public wrote 193e it
was a joint effort and they took pride
in their work because they believed in
the value of public education at that
time and that's where they came up with
this list it's not something you can cut
things out of it's required by our
Constitution and why did the Supreme
Court say we have to do this because
it's good for the kids it's good for our
communities and it's good for our state
as a whole they were smart enough to
realize that all of these courses are
important not just for some children it
might be the thing that pulls them into
school it can lead to their career you
heard talk about other careers
specifically from one thing but that all
of these subjects are interrelated it's
a whole person that we're educating not
just a specific course here and there
this is a constitutionally required list
and you can't just chop it with this
Bill thank
you thank you he Michael
betet followed by Taylor
Beav hello everybody um wow this is some
powerful testimony tonight so I won't U
repeat a lot of what has been offered to
you tonight my name is Michael bassette
I'm the assistant superintendent of the
karge Regional School dist District I
will um tell you that I my testimony I
provided a copy to you but um some
points that I didn't hear tonight um
first of all I'm going to tell you that
I'm in favor of this bill wow look at
the shock on your faces actually I'm
only in favor of this bill if you want
to move towards a total totalitarian ISM
type Society I truly believe this right
now so no I really don't believe in this
bill right why because totalitarian
governments justify the suppression of
Arts by emphasizing economic Pro
productivity militarization ID
ideological Purity um let's talk about
some of the cultures that have done that
Nazi Germany for example emphasize the
importance of modernist anomic Guard art
being labeled as degenerate and removing
it from the education system Soviet
Union art was strictly controlled under
the Socialist regime limiting expression
to approved political themes ma China
the the cultural revolution saw the
destruction of artistic and intellectual
Works North Korea I could go on and on
but let's talk about it from its reality
we are doing this because we don't want
to pay for it because some people don't
think it has value that's it it really
comes down to the fact that people in
our communities differ have differing
opinions about the value but I can tell
you this as a New York state teacher of
the year who taught um and I when I was
there as a science teacher there was a
chemist that spoke earlier to this
concept and I have never in my lifetime
had more impact on my ability to teach
than when I recognize the beauty of art
and its influence on things such as
crystallization forms or uh for for
example the languages that were being
spoken in Greek or Latin which were
becoming beautiful elements of the
language of science when I was talking
with kids about the language connections
that were being taught in other
classrooms so I implore you please
please please take a look at what
they're tell telling you is a cost
savings measure and really look at the
fundamental element that's at play
because this is just
propaganda thank
you Taylor Brown followed
by Hugh
curly uh hi my name is Taylor bevon uh
thank you for your time I'm here to
oppose uh HB 283 I believe it was
representative wheeler wheeler who
mentioned Conan high school and Jeffrey
as an underfunded High School I can tell
you firstand it's it's underfunded
that's uh that's where I went and
there's also been a mention by the
sponsor of this bill that school boards
aren't being forced to cut these
programs but that uh they're not being
required to promote them but I can tell
you from my time at uh Conan high school
that the first thing they'll do is cut
these uh the best class I took at that
school was a class taught by uh Spanish
teacher actually teaching genocidal
studies about uh the Holocaust and other
genocides this class was extremely
important in developing my critical
thinking skills and my knowledge and
understanding of the world and I think
those are really the points of Education
in general especially public education
it's a responsibility to emphasize those
critical thinking skills because the
reality is in K through 12 you cannot
give everybody the answers to every
problems but you can give them the tools
to solve those problems I think that uh
HB 283 misunderstands the purpose of
education and I think it misses the mark
on trying to solve the problems that
schools teachers and students are facing
thank you thank you very much for
sticking around is Hugh Curley here
uh how about Joseph
minty followed by John Hall or Jonah
Hall hello my name is Joe Mundy um thank
you for hearing me today I'll just uh
try to make a couple points that I
actually don't think have been made I am
here to voice my opposition uh for this
bill I um I was I'm the past president
of New Hampshire music educators
Association I'm also the K3 12
Performing Arts director for the Salem
School District uh representing the
whole District in all music and theater
activities um and the thing that I just
like to point out about uh in this case
Arts education specifically is um the
value in it you know when we think about
what our students need to be successful
what any of us in this world have needed
to be successful I'm going to stick with
my argument that I don't think
content-based knowledge is really where
we're at anymore we all have a little
tool in our pocket right now that can
find the answer to any question we have
um so when we think think about where
success comes from it's about other
skills and that's where I would argue
this bill is falling short it's getting
rid of subject areas that are going to
develop all these other skills that are
truly the skills that allow us to be
successful in life so I'm thinking about
things like perseverance a sense of
self-worth self-discipline and a work
ethic a sense of belonging and value in
the eyes of others creativity and
flexible thinking resilience Logic the
development of motor skills um authentic
high stakes performance experiences and
front of live audiences emotional
maturity um understanding of one's role
within a group and working with others
collaboratively patience critical
thinking and those are the skills we
develop with all these other areas that
uh this bill proposes to cut so um
that's it you know in the end I think
when you think about what success comes
from and what allows all of us adults to
be successful in this world it's all
these other things and by you know uh
supporting this bill I think we'd just
be missing the point entirely on what
allows us to be successful so please uh
oppose this bill and thank you for your
time today thank you very
much Mr Hall yes my name is John Hall
from Amherst New Hampshire and I speak
in opposition to Bill H
283 uh I would like to point out that
grade school K through 12 is really the
last chance for structured formal
education in for all of our students
some students may be lucky enough to go
on to University and receive extra
education but this is really the last
time that a majority of our students
will get a formal education i' like to
speak about world languages I'm one of
those Americans who can only speak
English I did take two years of French
and two years of Latin in grade school
but I forgotten a lot of that however I
spent a lot of my time today in Latin
America I wish I'd studied Spanish which
is the second most spoken native
language in the world with mandarin
being being first I think in modern day
world maybe we should spend some more
time learning these
languages students in grade school don't
know all the things that they will need
to know in the future it up to us the
adults in the room to help them
understand what they have to learn and
finally I'd like to put in a little plug
for uh Financial personal
financial about 70% of the bankruptcies
in the United States today come from
people who are
underinsured people who don't understand
how Insurance Works my first job out of
college was for an insurance company but
I was a programmer but they made us
spend two weeks of understanding
Insurance what deductibles are what we
need to cover our needs credit card fees
are astronomically large at one time I
was in personal debt up above my ear
years but because my knowledge of
personal finance I was able to refinance
my house on the second mortgage and get
out of that that structure thank you
thank you very much perfect timing is
there Janet is it
Lenin followed by Michaela deiner
good afternoon um I'm assuming everyone
who has been in this room today had the
privilege of the
standards of an American
Education my husband and I moved to New
Hampshire in 1979 with no children we
did not object to paying School tax
because I think that every child is
everyone's
responsibility I see no reason and do
not
understand why anyone would lower the
standards of the
many rather than raise the standards of
the
few for a private education which is
expensive our free education was for the
underprivileged and the privileged
please vote against this Bill thank you
thank you very
much Michaela and then uh Amelia
Thompson if she's
here good afternoon Representatives my
name is Michaela Deiter I'm a member of
the do school board I'm also on staff
for the New Hampshire school funding
fairness project today I speak only for
myself though my 14-year-old autistic
son he's a freshman at over High School
his name is Harrison he's great for the
first time in his life he's thriving in
school this year he's taking a mixture
of core academic classes like language
arts Math and Science as well as the
classes he loves the most band intro to
Arts musical theater he's a proud member
of the Dober High School marching band
and at this very moment he's in a
rehearsal for the March production of
bye-bye birdie representative Maguire
stated the removal of these courses
would allow for more time to be spent on
core classes with the goal of raising
standardized test scores but Research
indicates students who take music
courses score higher on the SATs
especially in verbal and math they
receive more academic honors and awards
and they score higher on standardized
tests than their non-banded peers a
study done in the British Columbia
reported in American Psychological
Association and published in the Journal
of educational psychology reads and I
quote it is believed that students who
spend school time in music classes
rather than in furthering developing
their skills in math science and English
classes will underperform in these
disciplines our research suggests that
in fact the more they study music the
better they do in those subjects the
American Council on the teaching of
foreign languages reports that students
who study foreign languages tend to
achieve higher scores on the Act and the
SAT particularly in the verbal sections
representative Maguire stated and I
quote this bill has zero to do with
State funding end quote in fact it has
everything to do with State funding the
state has spent the last five years and
millions of taxpayer dollars on outof
state attorneys in the conval and Rand
lawsuits to argue for the narrowest
possible definition of an adequate
education comprised of only the 11
subjects laid out in the statute
reducing required courses would
ultimately reduce what the state must
pay for my final comment is
representative Maguire stated and I
quote would you rather be able to do
math and deal with numbers at a higher
level or learn
French why then would the prime sponsor
think that eliminating personal finance
literacy is a good idea learning about
student loan repayment compound interest
household budgeting these are the life
skills New Hampshire graduates need that
will carry them confidently and
successfully through life please itl
this Bill thank you very much thank you
is Amilia Thompson
here and then Emily
Soul good to meet you all oh my name is
Amelia and I'm a constituent from New
Market New Hampshire I'm here because
the core learning areas of the Arts and
Civics and language have brought me to
where I am today and built me up and so
have the teachers that taught those
things I don't want to kick the L out
from under me and I don't think anyone
in this room wants to either so I
strongly oppose this bill and I think
that we need to think of students as
human beings and not just test takers
not just like a drain on our taxes or
financial resources they're human beings
and deserving of support and I think
that we need to work together and find a
way to be able to fund that support this
bill is not not that funding not this
bill is not the answer taking away
funding for these core classes of the
Arts language Civics all of these things
is not the right answer thank you for
your
time thank you very much is Emily here
followed
by Teresa
Wyman hi everybody I'm Emily soul and
I'm here today to oppose House Bill 200
83 I was born down the street at
conquered Hospital 25 years ago I
attended marac Valley high school and a
new which is a New Hampshire public
school and I was on conquered highs
robotics team the year we went to World
Championships when it came time to go to
college I chose the University of New
Hampshire and I was asked to come back
for my Master's Degree which I just
completed this summer what did I study
you ask economics political science
pre-law communication and ultimately
public policy
the only reason that I was able to do
any of that is because of the hard work
of my teachers and the law that forces
schools to provide those classes for
me everybody else has made a lot of the
points I wanted to make so instead of
that I would like to focus on what this
would do to our society we interact with
each other every single day every time
you go out of the house you talk to
people who used to be students this
isn't about what your tax dollars do or
don't do for somebody else's kid or if
you ever meet that person it's about the
fact that when you go to the grocery
store the person who is stocking the
shelves who is bagging your groceries
and who is working that cash register
for you was a student here it's about
the fact that when you are old and in a
nursing home the people who are caring
for you and keeping you alive do you
want those people to be well educated or
not when you go to a meeting like this
do you want people to have intelligent
things to say do you want the Democracy
that we have in the state of New
Hampshire that flame to carry on or do
you want this Hall to be empty
do you want nobody to know where to go
or how to
talk I am who I am because of the
education I received and the teachers
that gave it to me I would be lost I
would be desolate and I would be Hollow
and empty if I didn't have the economics
classes and the political science
classes that brought me to the
conclusions that I've come to in my
life oppose this bill determine that it
is inexpedient to legislate and protect
the future adults and fellow people that
it would affect thank you
thank
you is Teresa Wyman
here yes I'm Teresa Wyman and I am here
partly because a young woman about
aelia's age called me this weekend and
said can you go and testify she is a
speech therapy assistant in Wakefield
and she and the teachers in her school
are very upset that this this um hearing
was scheduled during school hours so
none of them are able to
come and she is somebody who believe me
has worked hard for her
education for myself I find this entire
Bill appalling I could speak to every
subject that is proposed to be gotten
rid
of because I'm an amateur musician I'm
just going to address music it's already
been addressed but there are documented
studies that music helps improves math
it improves overall learning and memory
improves mental health happiness and
well-being I want to add to that music
promotes community and Community is so
important in our world in our fractured
world
today and to quote someone who is a
semi-professional musician which I am
not music will take you where money
won't if money is so important
than let's look at our music can can do
I've been some amazing places because of
music I also in the moment I might have
left want to speak to the Holocaust my
dad wrote books about the
Holocaust anti-Semitism is up
360% in this country in the last year
according to the Anti-Defamation
League and my last comment is I believe
this is the camel's in the tent to try
to get rid of decent education and I
abore that idea I haven't had lunch yet
and I'm sure I have a parking ticket
that's how passionate I feel about
this thank you is Reed cotton
here followed by Claudia
Estelle good afternoon thank you all for
your
patience uh readed Cotton live in
conquered taught for 40 years in the
city of Manchester Memorial High School
I am the first uh teacher of the deaf
and also nationally certified
interpreter of American sign language in
the state of New Hampshire I have taught
American sign language for the duration
of my employment there and have managed
to generate at least a dozen of the
interpreters who have interpreted with
our various Governors over these past
three
decades I think the key component that
our sponsor may be neglecting is what
happens after your bill is passed what
happens when all the new criteria have
been completed and high school students
are graduates after two years of high
school what do we do with 16year olds
looking for full-time work I don't know
what did you do when you were
16 it could be a very complex ugly
animal that we create as a result of
this
legislation um and my second comment
is I have been a holocaust educator for
also many decades and have worked to
have the survivors come and talk to our
students and one Survivor has left me
with a message that I will never forget
and that is we are all sheep be careful
who your Shepherd is thank
you thank you very much is Claudia still
here and then Kathy
Harter hi I'm Claudia stelle from aworth
I have been a public school educator in
New Hampshire for over 30 years and I my
children were educated in public school
um I speak in opposition to this bill I
did write testimony that's in the portal
and I also emailed it but I apologize I
emailed it to the wrong committee so
when I get home I'll email it to your
committee um I so a couple of things I
want to point out one thing that I have
not heard anybody speak about today is
that the effect on public high schools
of this curriculum in terms of their
accreditation
so one uh person spoke about the
qualifications that our students would
need to be able to apply to
colleges well colleges also look to see
that students are coming from accredited
high schools and these the curriculum
that this bill proposes takes away some
of the requirements for accreditation um
I I'm sorry I'm been out of uh that
system for a while so but certainly uh
World languages certainly um probably uh
personal finance Civics um having a good
library and so forth um the second thing
I wanted to point out is that having had
a lot of time in schools and teaching
students who weren't always very
enthusiastic about my math classes um
kids need to have a reason to be in
school they love to have something that
inspires them it can be a shop class can
be um playing sports and so therefore
they want to do well in their English
class so that they can pass but they
need something that motivates them and
so all the courses that are offered are
important for that the second thing is
is that through those courses they get
opportunities that they might not have
otherwise foreign language classes take
kids on trips and the last thing I want
to say is that people have already said
but um I'm part of the grain population
of New Hampshire and I would like to
know that we are educating people who
are going to be able to take care of us
thank you thank you very much is Kathy
Harter
here how about Cassandra
Bush and then Mary Beth
Brentwood hi am Andra I'm a mother I'm a
homeown homeowner and conquered I'm also
an associate Dean at Southern New
Hampshire University although I am here
today speaking on behalf of my myself I
do not represent the school I hav't hard
a discussion of AI here today and I
think that that's relevant too in
today's world being able to recite facts
doesn't get you very far you need
critical thinking you need analysis you
need to be able to contextualize things
that are happening in terms of our
historical and political world you can't
do that without these
subjects I also question what makes
these subjects like history and
geography
extras how can people engage in
political discourse vote Voice opinions
on International politics if they don't
even know where Russia China or Mexico
are education is part of what drives
people to live in the state I have the
resources and I will move if the quality
of education in the state goes down what
happens to our school budgets when
people who can afford to move
do my parents did not graduate from
college we sometimes literally did not
have enough money to keep the lights
on I would not be where I am today if I
did not get the classes the access to
college that I got because of the
education I got at a small town in New
Hampshire where I can almost guarantee
these courses would have been cut if
they had that option it feels to me like
the sponsor of this bill feels like
children that live in those less
affluent towns the child that I was was
less entitled to a quality
education I know that students on
reduced lunch typically don't do as well
in school that's because students who
are worried about being safe and having
enough food to eat don't usually have as
much time to study I argue the solution
is not that we do less for those
students but that we do more thank you
thank you very much is Mary Beth
Bentwood
here how about Jack
Finley hi Jack Finley
I just wanted to um let people know
because I I wasn't planning on coming
here today but when he was introducing
his bill I was the superintendent of
Epsom I am the superintendent of Epsom
that he referenced um and the intent of
that meeting with representative Maguire
was to advocate for additional State
education funding not to maintain
minimal funding and diminish the quality
of Education in New Hampshire I just
want to make sure that people didn't
jump to the conclusion that I was
supporting this so that was the original
intent behind the meeting was to
advocate for additional State funding so
I just wanted to clarify to make sure
everybody's I know I only said 30
seconds so I think I get it thank you
very much thank
you Carolyn
Eastman hi my name is Carolyn Eastman
I'm from Hampton New Hampshire I'm a
longtime public educator I've been an
assistant superintendent at Oyster River
I was at Greenland Central School and Ry
junior high as a middle school teacher
one thing that I want to point out I'm
so proud of all the people that came and
spoke spoken opposition of this bill I
myself am opposed to this bill as well
what hasn't been mentioned is there was
mentioned about Civics education and the
recent adoption of a civic's requirement
in high school but in 2022 there was
House Bill 1671 which made personal
finance a core academic subject in
public schools that covers the topics
such as employment income money
management credit debit debt management
planning savings and
investing one of the PE I want to also
mention that uh representative lad
representative cordelli representative B
representative Allard representative
Moffett and uh Senator Reagan were in
support of this partisan
bill um and here we are um I also want
to mention that the Ed 306s are we often
call them in education the minimum uh
the minimum standards for public school
approval this would make a I don't know
what this bill would be called but maybe
it would be the minimum substandards for
minimum Public School approval I don't
know what we also argued that it wasn't
they weren't in fact the Ed 306s minimum
standards but they were what we believe
to be an adequate education inv voided
we want more and I talk to students high
school students across the state and I
talk to them every day in various high
schools across this across the state of
New Hampshire and they're all concerned
about big things they're concerned about
how they're going to afford things
they're concerned about climate they're
concerned about their what their world's
going to be whether or not they'll be
employable what's going to happen to
their families um they're worried about
big things and we ask why aren't they
learning math and Ela and from a nape
score there are so many other
distractions similar to bills like this
that take us away of what our jobs are
in public education that it really hurts
our kids um I also want to mention that
when I think about the distractions we
have social media that's a big
distraction as well and if there was
something that could help us with that
my gosh wouldn't it be a wonderful thing
but thank you all for your time I know
it's been a long day thank you very
much Heather
durgen is Heather Heather here
congratulations Heather you get the
prize I don't know what the prize is but
you get it Bingo um so I'm Heather
durgen
I am a mother of three I live in
Northfield New Hampshire um all three of
my children have gone through the public
school system um I have gone through the
public school system my husband as well
um we chose to live in New Hampshire and
educate our children here primarily
because my husband grew up in
Northfields um he moved back after
marrying me um
and all three of my children have
benefited in different ways uh from
their education experience uh our
youngest currently is a junior in high
school and he'll be turning 17 this may
um he actually wanted to leave school to
come here and speak and I he got sick so
he's not here um I was actually working
at his school um which is why I came
here late so I appreciate you guys uh
being here and hearing all of the
testimony I wasn't here for um but I do
oppose this house bill 283 uh strongly
as well as all of my children and my
granddaughter um who is going to be
starting kindergarten in the fall um so
thank you so much for your time and
consideration I know that you guys work
tirelessly so I applaud you guys for
doing that um and that's all thank you
thank you very much so
I I believe that concludes uh the house
bill 238 testimony I want to thank um
all the committee members who hung in uh
everyone who came to testify U but
certainly not least the sergeant-at-arms
staff and our uh committee staff who um
we couldn't do all this without so thank
you everybody and have a safe drive home
for